deep learning has become one of the most
debated technologies in the last decade
it is being widely used in various
sectors of business to ease human tasks
if you're looking to learn deep learning
you're in the right place hi guys
welcome to this complete deep learning
tutorial by simply learn my name is
rahul and today we will learn the
various essential topics deep learning
that you need to know
now let's have a look at the different
topics we'll be covering in this video
first we'll watch a short animated video
to understand ai in five minutes then
we'll learn what is deep learning and
see how to install tensorflow on ubuntu
after that we'll look at what is
tensorflow and understand deep learning
in depth with a use case demo then we'll
see how to detect objects using
tensorflow object detection api and the
different deep learning frameworks
available in python then we'll
understand how convolutional neural
networks and recurrent neural networks
work finally we'll get an idea about the
various deep learning applications and
learn a few important deep learning
interview questions that will help you
build your career in deep learning with
that let's get started ever wondered how
google translates an entire web page to
a different language in a matter of
seconds or your phone gallery groups
images based on their location all of
this is a product of deep learning but
what exactly is deep learning deep
learning is a subset of machine learning
which in turn is a subset of artificial
intelligence artificial intelligence is
a technique that enables a machine to
mimic human behavior machine learning is
a technique to achieve ai through
algorithms trained with data and finally
deep learning is a type of machine
learning inspired by the structure of
the human brain in terms of deep
learning this structure is called an
artificial neural network let's
understand deep learning better and how
it's different from machine learning say
we create a machine that could
differentiate between tomatoes and
cherries if done using machine learning
we'd have to tell the machine the
features based on which the two can be
differentiated these features could be
the size and the type of stem on them
with deep learning on the other hand the
features are picked out by the neural
network without human intervention of
course that kind of independence comes
at the cost of having a much higher
volume of data to train our machine
now let's dive into the working of
neural networks
here we have three students each of them
write down the digit nine on a piece of
paper
notably they don't all write it
identically the human brain can easily
recognize the digits
but what if a computer had to recognize
them
that's where deep learning comes in
here's a neural network trained to
identify handwritten digits
each number is present as an image of 28
times 28 pixels
now that amounts to a total of 784
pixels
neurons the core entity of a neural
network is where the information
processing takes place
each of the 784 pixels is fed to a
neuron in the first layer of our neural
network
this forms the input layer
on the other end we have the output
layer with each neuron representing a
digit with the hidden layers existing
between them
the information is transferred from one
layer to another over connecting
channels
each of these has a value attached to it
and hence is called a weighted channel
all neurons have a unique number
associated with it called bias
this bias is added to the weighted sum
of inputs reaching the neuron
which is then applied to a function
known as the activation function
the result of the activation function
determines if the neuron gets activated
every activated neuron passes on
information to the following layers
this continues until the second last
layer
the one neuron activated in the output
layer corresponds to the input digit the
weights and bias are continuously
adjusted to produce a well-trained
network so where is deep learning
applied in customer support when most
people converse with customer support
agents the conversation seems so real
they don't even realize that it's
actually a bot on the other side in
medical care neural networks detect
cancer cells and analyze mri images to
give detailed results self-driving cars
what seem like science fiction is now a
reality apple tesla and nissan are only
a few of the companies working on
self-driving cars so deep learning has a
vast scope but it too faces some
limitations the first as we discussed
earlier is data while deep learning is
the most efficient way to deal with
unstructured data a neural network
requires a massive volume of data to
train let's assume we always have access
to the necessary amount of data
processing this is not within the
capability of every machine and that
brings us to our second limitation
computational power training in neural
network requires graphical processing
units which have thousands of cores as
compared to cpus and gpus are of course
more expensive and finally we come down
to training time deep neural networks
take hours or even months to train the
time increases with the amount of data
and number of layers in the network so
here's a short quiz for you arrange the
following statements in order to
describe the working of a neural network
a the bias is added b the weighted sum
of the inputs is calculated c specific
neuron is activated d the result is fed
to an activation function some of the
popular deep learning frameworks include
tensorflow pytorch keras deep learning
4j cafe and microsoft cognitive toolkit
considering the future predictions for
deep learning and ai we seem to have
only scratched the surface in fact horus
technology is working on a device for
the blind that uses deep learning with
computer vision to describe the world to
the users replicating the human mind at
the entirety may be not just an episode
of science fiction for too long the
future is indeed full of surprises and
that is deep learning for you in short i
hope that's got you excited to learn
deep learning we now have richard and
mohan who will explain the various
concepts of deep learning hello and
welcome to the session on installing
tensorflow hello and welcome to the
session on deep learning my name is
mohan and in this video we are going to
talk about what deep learning is all
about some of you may be already
familiar with the image recognition how
does image recognition
work you can train this application or
your machine to recognize whether a
given image is a cat or a dog and this
is how it works at a very high level it
uses artificial neural network it is
trained with some known images and
during the training it is told if it is
recognizing correctly or not and then
when new images are submitted it
recognizes correctly based on the
accuracy of curse so a little quick
understanding about artificial neural
networks so this is the way it does is
you provide a lot of training data also
known as labeled data for example in
this case these are the images of dogs
and the network extracts some features
that makes a dog a dog right so that is
known as feature extraction and based on
that when you submit a new image of dog
the basic features remain pretty much
the same it may be a completely
different image but the features of a
dog still remain pretty much the same in
various different images let's say
compared to a cat and that's the way
artificial neural network works we'll go
into details of this very shortly and
once the training is done with training
data we then test it with some test data
too which is basically completely new
data with which the system has not seen
before unlike the training data and then
we find out whether it is predicting
correctly or not thereby we know whether
the training is complete or it needs
more training so that's at a very high
level artificial neural network works so
this is what we are going to talk about
today our agenda looks something like
this what is deep learning why do we
need deep learning and then what are the
applications of deep learning one of the
main components the secret sauce in deep
learning is neural networks so we're
going to talk about what is neural
network and
how it works and some of its components
like for example the activation function
the gradient descent and so on and so
forth so that as a part of working of a
neural network we will go into little
bit more details how this whole thing
works so without much further ado let's
get started so deep learning is
considered to be a part of machine
learning so this diagram very nicely
depicts what deep learning is at a very
high level you have the all-encompassing
artificial intelligence which is more a
concept rather than a technology or a
technical concept right so it is it's
more of a concept at a very high level
artificial intelligence under the hood
is actually machine learning and deep
learning and machine learning is a
broader concept you can say or a broader
technology and deep learning is a subset
of machine learning the primary
difference between machine learning and
deep learning is that deep learning uses
neural networks and it is suitable for
handling large amounts of unstructured
data and last but not least one of the
major differences between machine
learning and deep learning is that in
machine learning the feature extraction
or the feature engineering is done by
the data scientists manually but in deep
learning since we use neural networks
the feature engineering happens
automatically so that's a little bit of
a quick difference between machine
learning and deep learning and this
diagram very nicely depicts the relation
between artificial intelligence machine
learning and deep learning now why do we
need deep learning machine learning was
there for quite some time and it can do
a lot of stuff that probably what deep
learning can do but it's not very good
at handling large amounts of
unstructured data like images voice or
even text for that matter so traditional
machine learning is not that very good
at doing this traditional machine
learning can handle large amounts of
structured data but when it comes to
unstructured data it's a big challenge
so that is one of the key
differentiators for deep learning so
that is number one and increasingly for
artificial intelligence we need image
recognition and we need to process
analyze images and voice that's the
reason deep learning is required
compared to let's say traditional
machine learning it can also perform
complex algorithms more complex than
let's say what machine learning can do
and it can achieve best performance with
the large amounts of data so the more
you have the data let's say reference
data or label data the better the system
will do because the training process
will be that much better and last but
not least with deep learning you can
really avoid the manual process of
feature extraction those are some of the
reasons why we need deep learning some
of the applications of deep learning
deep learning has made major inroads and
it is a major area in which deep
learning is applied is healthcare and
within healthcare particularly oncology
which is basically cancer related stuff
one of the issues with cancer is that a
lot of cancers today are curable they
can be cured they are detected early on
and the challenge with that is when a
diagnostics is performed let's say an
image has been taken of a patient to
detect whether there is cancer or not
you need a specialist to look at the
image and determine whether it is the
patient is fine or there is any onset of
cancer and the number of specialists are
limited so if we use deep learning if we
use automation here or if we use
artificial intelligence here then the
system can with a certain amount of the
good amount of accuracy determine
whether a particular patient is having
cancer or not so the prediction or the
detection process of a disease like
cancer can be expedited the detection
process can be expedited can be faster
without really waiting for a specialist
we can obviously then once the
application once the artificial
intelligence detects or predicts that
there is an onset of a cancer this can
be cross-checked by a doctor but at
least the initial screening process can
be automated and that is where the
current focus is with respect to deep
learning in healthcare what else
robotics is another area deep learning
is majorly used in robotics and you must
have seen nowadays robots are everywhere
humanoids the industrial robots which
are used for manufacturing process you
must have heard about sophia who got
citizenship with saudi arabia and so on
there are multiple such robots which are
knowledge oriented but there are also
industrial robots that are used in
industries in the manufacturing process
and increasingly in security and also in
defense for example image processing
video is fed to them and they need to be
able to detect objects obstacles and so
on and so forth so that's where deep
learning is used they need to be able to
hear and make sense of the sounds that
they are hearing that needs deep
learning as well so robotics is a major
area where deep learning is applied then
we have self-driving cars or autonomous
cars you must have heard of google's
autonomous car which has been tested for
millions of miles and pretty much
incident free there were of course a
couple of incidents here and there but
it is
considered to be fairly safe and there
are today a lot of automotive companies
in fact pretty much every automotive
company worth its name is investing in
self-driving cars or autonomous cars and
it is predicted that in the next
probably 10 to 15 years these will be in
production and they will be used
extensively in real life right now they
are all in r d and in test phases but
pretty soon these will be on the road so
this is another area where deep learning
is used and how is it used where is it
used within autonomous driving the car
actually is fed with video of
surroundings and it is supposed to
process that information process that
video and determine if there are any
obstacles it has to determine if there
are any cars in the site will detect
whether it is driving in the lane also
it has to determine whether the signal
is green or red so that accordingly it
can move forward or wait so for all
these video analysis deep learning is
used in addition to that the training
overall training to drive the car
happens in a deep learning environment
so again a lot of scope here to use deep
learning couple of other applications
are mission translation so today we have
a lot of information and very often this
information is in one particular
language and more specifically in
english and people need information in
various parts of the world it is pretty
difficult for human beings to translate
each and every piece of information or
every document into all possible
languages there are probably at least
hundreds of languages or if not more to
translate each and every document into
every language is
pretty difficult therefore we can use
deep learning to do pretty much like a
real time translation mechanism so we
don't have to translate everything and
keep it ready but we train applications
or artificial intelligence systems that
will do the translation on the fly for
example you go to somewhere like china
and you want to know what is written on
a signboard now it is impossible for
somebody to translate that and put it on
the web or something like that so you
have an application which is trained to
translate stuff on the fly so you
probably this can be running on your
mobile phone on your smartphone you scan
this the application will instantly
translate that from chinese to english
that is one then there could be web
applications where there may be a
research document which is all in maybe
chinese or japanese and you want to
translate that to study that document or
in that case you need to translate so
therefore deep learning is used in such
situations as well and that is again on
demand so it is not like you have to
translate all these documents from other
languages into english and one shot and
keep it somewhere that is again pretty
much an impossible task but on a need
basis so you have systems that are
trained to translate on the flag so
mission translation is another major
area where deep learning is used then
there are a few other upcoming areas
where synthesizing is done by neural
nets for example music composition and
generation of music so you can train a
neural net to produce music even to
compose music so this is a fun thing
this is still upcoming it needs a lot of
effort to train such neural net it has
been proved that it is possible so this
is a relatively new area and on the same
lines colorization of images so these
two images on the left hand side is a
grayscale image or a black and white
image this was colored by a neural net
or a deep learning application as you
can see it's done a very good job of
applying the colors and obviously this
was trained to do this colorization but
yes this is one more application of deep
learning now one of the major secret
sauce of deep learning is neural network
deep learning works on neural network or
consists of neural network so let us see
what is neural network neural network or
artificial neural network is designed or
based on the human brain now human brain
consists of billions of small cells that
are known as neurons artificial neural
networks is in a way trying to simulate
the human brain so this is a quick
diagram of biological neuron a
biological neuron consists of the major
part which is the cell nucleus and then
it has some tentacles kind of stuff on
the top called dendrite and then there
is like a long tail which is known as
the axon further again at the end of
this action are what are known as
synapses these in turn are connected to
the dendrites of the next neuron and all
these neurons are interconnected with
each other therefore they are like
billions of them sitting in our brain
and they're all active they're working
they based on the signals they receive
signals as inputs from other neurons or
maybe from other parts of the body and
based on certain criteria they send
signals to the neurons at the other end
so they they get either activated or
they don't get activated based on so it
is like a binary gates so they get
activated or not activated based on the
inputs that they receive and so on so we
will see a little bit of those details
as we move forward in our artificial
neuron but this is a biological neuron
this is the structure of a biological
neuron and artificial neural network is
based on the human brain the smallest
component of artificial neural network
is an artificial neuron as shown here
sometimes it's also referred to as
perceptron now this is a very high level
diagram the artificial neuron has a
small central unit which will receive
the input if it is doing let's say image
processing the inputs could be pixel
values of the image which is represented
here as x1 x2 and so on each of the
inputs are multiplied by what is known
as weights which are represented as w1w2
and so on there is in the central unit
basically there is a summation of these
weighted inputs which is like x1 into w1
plus x2 into w2 and so on the products
are then added and then there is a bias
that is added to that in the next slide
we will see that passes through an
activation function and the output comes
as a y which is the output and based on
certain criteria the cell gets either
activated or not activated so this
output would be like a zero or a one
binary format okay so we will see that
in a little bit more detail but let's do
a quick comparison between biological
and artificial neurons just like a
biological neuron there are dendrites
and then there is a cell nucleus and
synapse and an axon we have in the
artificial neuron as well
these inputs come like the dendrite if
you will act like the dendrites there is
a like a central unit which performs the
summation of these uh weighted inputs
which is basically w1 x1 w2 x2 and so on
and then a bias is added here and then
that passes through what is known as an
activation function okay so these are
known as the weights w1 w2 and then
there is a bias which will come out here
and that is added the bias is by the way
common for a particular neuron so there
won't be like b1 b2 b3 and so on only
weights will be one per input the bias
is common for the entire neuron it is
also common for or the value of the bias
remains the same for all the neurons in
a particular layer we will also see this
as we move forward and we see deep
neural network where there are multiple
neurons so that's the output now the
whole exercise of training the neuron is
about changing
these weights and biases as i mentioned
this artificial neural network will
consist of several such neurons and as a
part of the training process these
weights keep changing initially they are
assigned some random values through the
training process the weights the whole
process of training is to come up with
the optimum values of w1 w2 and wn
and then the b for or the bias for this
particular neuron such that it gives an
accurate output as required so let's see
what exactly that means so the training
process this is how it happens it takes
the inputs each input is multiplied by a
weight and these weights during training
keep changing so initially they are
assigned some random values and based on
the output whether it is correct or
wrong there is a feedback coming back
and that will basically change these
weights until it starts giving the right
output that is represented in here as
sigma i going from 1 to n if there are n
inputs wi into x i so this is the
product of w1 x1 w2 x2 and so on right
and there is a bias that gets added here
and that entire thing goes to what is
known as an activation function so
essentially this is sigma of w i x i
plus a value of bias which is a b so
that entire thing goes as an input to an
activation function now this activation
function takes this as an input gives
the output as a binary output it could
be a zero or a one there are of course
to start with let's assume it's a binary
output later we will see that there are
different types of activation functions
so it need not always be binary output
but to start with let's keep simple so
it decides whether the neuron should be
fired or not so that is the output like
a binary output 0 or 1. all right so
again let me summarize this so it takes
the inputs so if you're processing an
image for example the inputs are the
pixel values of the image x1 x2 up to xn
there could be hundreds of these so all
of those are fed as so these are some
values and these pixel values again can
be from 0 to 56 each of those pixel
values are then multiplied with what is
known as a weight this is a numeric
value can be any value so this is a
number w1 similarly w2 is a number so
initially some random values will be
assigned and each of these weights are
multiplied with the input value and
their sum this is known as the weighted
sum so that is performed in this kind of
the central unit and then a bias is
added remember the bias is common for
each neuron so this is not the bias
value is not one
bias value for per input so just keep
that in mind the bias value that is one
bias per neuron so it is like this
summation plus bias is the output from
the section this is not the complete
output of the neuron but this is a bias
for output for step one that goes as an
input to what is known as activation
function and that activation function
results in an output usually a binary
output like a zero or a one which is
known as the firing of the neuron okay
good so we talked about activation
function so what is an activation
function an activation function
basically takes the weighted sum which
is we saw w1 x1 w2 x2 the sum of all
that plus the bias so it takes that as
an input and it generates a certain
output now there are different types of
activation functions and the output is
different for different types of
activation functions moreover why is an
activation function required it is
basically required to bring in
non-linearity that's the main reason why
an activation function is required so
what are the different types of
activation functions there are several
types of activation functions but these
are the most common ones these are the
ones that are currently in use sigmoid
function was one of the early activation
functions but today relu has kind of
taken over so relu is by far the most
popular activation function that is used
today but still sigmoid function is
still used in many situations these
different types of activation functions
are used in different situations based
on the kind of problem we are trying to
solve so what exactly is the difference
between these two sigmoid gives the
values of the output will be between 0
and 1. threshold function is the value
will be
0 up to a certain value and beyond that
this is also known as a step function
and beyond that it will be 1. in case of
sigmoid there is a gradual increase but
in case of threshold it's like also
known as a step function there's a rapid
or instantaneous change from zero to one
whereas in sigmoid we will see in the
next slide there is a gradual increase
but the value in this case is between
zero and one as well now relu function
on the other hand it is equal to
basically if the input is 0 or less than
0 then the output is 0 whereas if the
input is greater than 0 then the output
is equal to the input i know it's a
little confusing but in the next slides
where we show the relu function it will
become clear similarly hyperbolic
tangent this is similar to sigmoid in
terms of the shape of the function
however while sigmoid goes from 0 to 1
hyperbolic tangent goes from -1 to 1 and
here again the increase or the change
from -1 to 1 is gradual and not like
threshold or step function where it
happens instantaneously so let's take a
little detailed look at some of these
functions so let's start with the
sigmoid function so this is the equation
of a sigmoid function which is 1 by 1
plus e to the power of minus x so x is
the value that is the input it goes from
0 to minus 1. so this is sigmoid
function the equation is phi x is equal
to 1 by 1 plus e to the power of minus x
and as you can see here this is the
input on the x axis as x is what the
value is coming from in fact it can also
go negative this is negative actually so
this is the zero so this is the negative
value of x so as x is coming from
negative value towards zero the value of
the output slowly as it is approaching
zero it it slowly and very gently
increases and actually at the point let
me just use a pen at the point here it
is it is 0.5 it is actually 0.5 okay and
slowly gradually it increases to 1 as
the value of x increases but then as the
value of x increases it tapers off it
doesn't go beyond one so that is the
speciality of sigmoid function so the
output value will remain between zero
and one it will never go below zero or
above one okay then so that is sigmoid
function now this is threshold function
or this is also referred to as a step
function and here we can also set the
threshold in this case it is that's why
it's called the threshold function
normally it is 0 but you can also set a
different value for the threshold now
the difference between this and the
sigmoid is that here the change is rapid
or instantaneous as the x value comes
from negative up to zero it remains zero
and at zero it pretty much immediately
increases to 1 okay so this is a
mathematical representation of threshold
function phi x is equal to 1 if x is
greater than equal to 0 and 0 if x is
less than 0. so for all negative values
it is 0 which since we have set the
threshold to be 0. so as soon as it
reaches 0 it becomes 1. you see the
difference between this and the previous
one which is basically the sigmoid where
the increase from 0 to 1 is gradual and
here it is instantaneous and that's why
this is also known as a step function
threshold function or step function this
is a relu a relu is one of the most
popular activation functions today this
is the definition of relu phi x is equal
to max of x comma 0. what it says is if
the value of x is less than 0 then phi x
is
0. the moment it increases goes beyond 0
the value of phi x is equal to x so it
doesn't stop at one actually it goes all
the way so as the value of x increases
the value of y will also increase
infinitely so there is no limit here
unlike your sigmoid or threshold or the
next one which is basically hyperbolic
tangent okay so in case of relu remember
there is no upper limit the output is
equal to either 0 in case the value of x
is negative or it is equal to the value
of x so for example here if the value of
x is 10 then the value of y is also 10
right okay so that is relu and there are
several advantages of relu and it is
much more efficient and provides much
more accuracy compared to other
activation functions like sigmoid and so
on so that's the reason it is very
popular all right so this is hyperbolic
tangent activation function the function
looks similar to sigmoid function the
curve if you see the shape it looks
similar to sigmoid function but the
difference between hyperbolic tangent
and sigmoid function is that in case of
sigmoid the output goes from 0 to 1
whereas in case of hyperbolic tangent it
goes from -1 to 1 so that is the
difference between hyperbolic tangent
and sigmoid function otherwise the shape
looks very similar there is a gradual
increase unlike the step function where
there was an instant increase or instant
change here again very similar to
sigmoid function the value changes
gradually from -1 to 1. so this is the
equation of hyperbolic tangent
activation function yeah so then let's
move on this is a diagrammatic
representation of the activation
function and how the overall data how
the overall progression happens from
input to the output so if you get the
input from the input layer by the way
the neural network has three layers
typically there will be three layers
there is an input layer there is an
output layer and then you have the
hidden layer so the inputs come from the
input layer and they get processed in
the hidden layer and then you get the
output in the output layer so let's take
a little bit of a detailed look into the
working of a neural network so let's say
we want to classify some images between
dogs and cats how do we do this this is
known as a classification process and we
are trying to use neural networks and
deep learning to implement this
classification so how do we do that so
this is how it works so you have four
layer neural network there is an input
layer there is an output layer and then
there are two hidden layers and what we
do is we provide labeled training data
which means these images are fed to the
network with the label saying that okay
this is a cat the neural network is
allowed to process it and come up with a
prediction saying whether it is a cat or
a dog and obviously in the beginning
there may be mistakes a cat may be
classified as a dog so we then say that
okay this is wrong this output is wrong
but every time it predicts correctly we
say yes this output is correct so that
learning process so it will go back make
some changes to its weights and biases
we again feed these inputs and it will
give us the output we will check whether
it is correct or not and so on so this
is a iterative process which is known as
the training process so we are training
the neural network and what happens in
the training process these weights and
biases you remember there were weights
like w1 w2 and so on so these weights
and biases keep changing every time you
feed these which is known as an epoch so
there are multiple iterations every
iteration is known as an epoch and each
time the weights are dated to make sure
that the maximum number of images are
classified correctly so once again what
is the input this input could be like
thousand images of cats and dogs and
they are labeled because we know which
is a cat and which is a dog and we feed
those thousand images the neural network
will initially assign some weights and
biases for each neuron and it will try
to process extract the features from the
images and it will try to come up with a
prediction for each image and that
prediction that is calculated by the
network is compared with the actual
value whether it is a cat or a dog and
that's how the error is calculated so
let's say there are 1000 images and in
the first run only 500 of them have been
correctly classified that means we are
getting only 50 accuracy so we feed that
information back to the network further
update these weights and biases for each
of the neurons and we run this these
inputs once again it will try to
calculate extract the features and it
will try to predict which of these is
cats and dogs and this time let's say
out of thousand 700 of them have been
predicted correctly so that means in the
second iteration the accuracy has
increased from 50 percent to 70 percent
all right then we go back again we feed
this maybe for a third iteration fourth
iteration and so on and slowly and
steadily the accuracy of this network
will keep increasing and it may reach
probably you never know 90
95 percent and there are several
parameters that are known as hyper
parameters that need to be changed and
tweaked and that is the overall training
process and ultimately at some point we
say okay you will probably never reach
hundred percent accuracy but then we set
a limit saying that okay if we receive
95 percent accuracy that is good enough
for our application and then we say okay
our training process is done so that is
the way training happens and once the
training is done now with the training
data set the system has let's say seen
all these thousand images therefore what
we do is the next step like in any
normal machine learning process we do
the testing where we take a fresh set of
images and we feed it to the network the
fresh set which it has not seen before
as a part of the training process and
this is again nothing new in deep
learning this was there in machine
learning as well so you feed the test
images and then find out whether we are
getting a similar accuracy or not so
maybe that accuracy may reduce a little
bit while training you may get 98 and
then for test you may get 95 percent but
there shouldn't be a drastic drop like
for example you get 98 percent in
training and then you get 50 percent or
40 with the test that means your network
has not learned you may have to retrain
your network so that is the way neural
network training works and remember the
whole process is about changing these
weights and biases and coming up with
the optimal values of these weights and
biases so that the accuracy is the
maximum possible all right so a little
bit more detail about how this whole
thing works so this is known as forward
propagation which is the data or the
information is going in the forward
direction the inputs are taken weighted
summation is done bias is added here and
then that is fed to the activation
function and then that is that comes out
as an output so that is forward
propagation and the output is compared
with the actual value and that will give
us the error the difference between them
is the error and in technical terms that
is also known as our cost function and
this is what we would like to minimize
there are different ways of defining the
cost function but one of the simplest
ways is mean square error so it is
nothing but the square of the difference
of the errors or the sum of the squares
of the difference of the errors and this
is also nothing new we have probably if
you're familiar with machine learning
you must have come across this mean
square now there are different ways of
defining cost function it need not
always be the mean square error but the
most common one is this so you define
this cost function and you ask the
system to minimize this error so we use
what is known as an optimization
function to minimize this error and the
error itself sent back to the system as
feedback and that is known as back
propagation and so this is the cost
function and how do we optimize the cost
function we use what is known as
gradient descent so the gradient descent
mechanism identifies how to change the
weights and biases so that the cost
function is minimized and there is also
what is known as the rate or the
learning rate that is what is shown here
as slower and faster so you need to
specify what should be the learning rate
now if the learning rate is very small
then it will probably take very long to
train whereas if the learning rate is
very high then it will appear to be
faster but then it will probably never
what is known as converge now what is
convergence now we are talking about a
few terms here convergence is like this
this is a representation of convergence
so the whole idea of gradient descent is
to optimize the cost function or
minimize the cost function in order to
do that we need to represent the cost
function as this curve we need to come
to this minimum value that is what is
known as the minimization of the cost
function now what happens if we have the
learning rate very small is that it will
take very long to come to this point on
the other hand if you have large higher
learning rate what will happen is
instead of stopping here it will cross
over because the learning rate is high
and then it has to come back so it will
result in what is known as like an
oscillation so it will never come to
this point which is known as convergence
instead it will go back and forth so
these are known as hyper parameters the
learning rate and so on and these have
to be those numbers or those values we
can determine
typically using trial and error out of
experience we we try to find out these
values so that is the gradient descent
mechanism to optimize the cost function
and that is what is used to train our
neural network this is another
representation of how the training
process works and here in this example
we are trying to classify these images
whether they are cats or dogs and as you
can see actually each image is fed in
each time one image is fed rather and
these values of x1 x2 up to xn are the
pixel values within this image okay so
those values are then taken and for each
of those values a weight is multiplied
and then it goes to the next layer and
then to the next layer and so on
ultimately it comes as the output layer
and it gives an output as whether it is
a dog or a cat remember the output will
never be a named output so these would
be like a zero or a one and we say okay
zero corresponds to dogs and one
corresponds to catch so that is the way
it typically happens this is a binary
classification we have similar
situations where there can be multiple
classes which means that there will be
multiple more neurons in the output
layer okay so this is once again a quick
representation of how the forward
propagation and the backward propagation
works so the information is going in
this direction which is basically the
forward propagation and at the output
level
we find out what is the cost function
the difference is basically sent back as
part of the backward propagation and
gradient descent then adjust the weights
and biases for the next iteration this
happens iteratively till the cost
function is minimized and that is when
we say the whole the network has
converged or the training process has
converged and there can be situations
where convergence may not happen in rare
cases but by and large the network will
converge and after maybe a few
iterations it could be
tens of iterations or hundreds of
iterations depending on what exactly the
number of iterations can vary and then
we say okay we are getting a certain
accuracy and we say that is our
threshold maybe 90 accuracy we stop at
that and we say that the system is
trained the trained model is then
deployed for production and so on so
that is the way the neural network
training happens okay so that is the way
classification works in deep learning
using neural network and this slide is
an animation of this whole process as
you can see the forward propagation the
data is going forward from the input
layer to the output layer and there is
an output and the error is calculated
the cost function is calculated and that
is fed back as a part of backward
propagation and that whole process
repeats once again okay so remember in
neural networks the training process is
nothing but the finding the best values
of the weights and biases for each and
every neuron in the network that's all
training of neural network consists of
finding the optimal values of the
weights and biases so that the accuracy
is maximum and i am going to take you
through the process of setting up this
tensorflow development environment as
some of you may be aware it's not that
easy to set up the tensorflow
environment there are several components
there are several possibilities for
example
you can set up on windows you can set up
on ubuntu now ubuntu has multiple
versions which version to use and then
you have python which release of python
to use whether to do a pip install
whether to do install using anaconda and
how do you then link it up with jupiter
notebook these are multiple
possibilities and it takes up a lot of
time to try all of these so today what
i'm going to do is show you a tried and
tested method of setting up the
tensorflow environment and this will
help primarily those who are starting
with tensorflow so that they don't have
to waste so much time on setting up the
environment in experimenting with the
installation and setting up of the
environment now what we are going to do
is i will show you a method by which you
you know it is a tried and tested method
and of course tensorflow home page has a
install page and it shows you some ways
to install but again the challenge is
the same there are multiple versions
multiple methods shown there so it's
highly confusing for somebody who is new
as to decide which one which path to
take so in today's session what we are
going to do is we will set up tensorflow
on ubuntu and i am going to show you in
a virtual box but then if you are using
a laptop with ubuntu installed you can
straight away use the same method
however we need to keep one thing in
mind that the various releases and
versions of ubuntu and
python and tensorflow not all of them
are compatible with each other so these
versions and releases need to be very
specific so i will tell you which is the
version and releases what combination is
best suited for you to get started and
later on of course you can then
experiment with other possibilities and
other releases and so on once you get
familiar with tensorflow to start with i
would also like to mention that it is a
good idea to install or start with
ubuntu environment or linux any other
linux also but here we will focus on
ubuntu rather than windows so for those
who are already let's say using a
windows system the question may arise
what do we do but there is an easy
option as you can see i'm actually using
a virtual box so you need to install
virtualbox let me just show you so this
is the virtual box oracle vm virtual box
and there are tons of videos on youtube
how to install a virtual box and how to
create ubuntu image i think we will not
spend time on that but if you're using
windows and my preference would be to
set up a virtual box
set up your environment in ubuntu image
so we will start by assuming that you
have an ubuntu environment especially
release 14.04 lts there are multiple
ubuntu versions and again we will not
try to get the latest and the greatest
versions or latest and greatest releases
but the focus here is to take the
releases and versions which are working
and where you will not waste time so the
setup process will be smooth if you
stick to these releases you can of
course experiment later on with other
versions and try out but here we will be
working with ubuntu 1404 lts and we will
use python 3.4 and we will use
tensorflow 1.5 this is a tried and
tested combination and i would also
recommend that you use the same if you
want a smooth start and so let's get
started with that
let me login to my ubuntu system okay so
we have the ubuntu system running here
now if you go to tensorflow.org
there is a page which
mentions how to install tensorflow and
as you can see there are multiple
possibilities you have ubuntu you have
windows and
mac os and so on and so forth and if you
go to ubuntu for example further you
will get
multiple options whether you want cpu or
gpu and
whether you want to do a pip install or
using a virtual native pip virtual env
anaconda and so on and so forth so all
these options are
very complicated or rather very
confusing i would say not complicated
depending on whether you're expert or of
course i am talking about beginners here
but if you click on some of these
options they may look very easy so for
example if you go back and
if you select for example native pip it
may appear like oh this is just you know
one
single or two steps and that's about it
everything gets installed you see here
it should be just one step install it
you say 3 install tensorflow and
everything gets installed unfortunately
it doesn't work that way so it's not as
easy as so don't get kind of fooled by
the simplicity of the of the
documentation here again it's not their
fault because of the multiple
combinations of releases and so on and
so forth it is not that easy so what we
will do is we will take a slightly
roundabout method which is using
anaconda which has a few more steps but
you're sure that this is going to work
so that is what we are going to do and
that's what i am going to show you so
what are the steps involved of course i
will not go exactly by what they have
mentioned here as i said i will show you
the steps which are again sure shot to
work whereas
here again if you follow just this
document there will be some variations
which they have kind of not documented
so that's the reason i will show you the
steps separately all right so these are
the main four steps you need to download
and install anaconda and then create a
virtual environment with python and the
release as i mentioned is python 3.4 and
we will install tensorflow version 1.5
and then we will install and configure
jupiter which will be our development
environment all right so let's get
started this is our ubuntu and let's get
a terminal started here and
okay yes so
all right so we started the terminal and
then what we'll also do is we'll go to
the anaconda website because we need to
install anaconda we need to download and
install anaconda so for that you need to
go to the anaconda website so you can
just open a browser and
google and you will find anaconda
website
so this is the site anaconda.org
click on this link and it will take you
to the anaconda website
you don't have to sign up or anything
like that just look for the download
anaconda
so just click on that it will take you
to the download pages and it
automatically recognizes that you are on
ubuntu so it will show you the links to
download all right so as you can see it
has
recognized that you're on a linux
operating system so
you can just click on this download and
it will start the download there are two
versions of course python with python
3.6 and 2.7 i
recommend you start with python 3.6 now
just want to clarify that we will be
actually using python 3.4 this is just
for
the
initial installation
but subsequently when we set up the
virtual environment you will see there
is one more step there where we set up
the virtual environment there we will
actually be using python 3.4 so just
that you are not confused all right so
it has started the download we just say
no thanks for this and it is downloading
while it is downloading you can
click on this
link saying how to install anaconda so
there are a couple of steps mentioned
there that we will be using so let me
just in the meanwhile click on this for
some reason the network is a little slow
so it's taking time all right so
once the download is done we will be
using the options that are mentioned
here now the first step of course is we
we are already doing the first step
which is downloading the installer for
linux the second step is not mandatory
so it's an optional step most often you
can actually skip that and third step is
what we are going to do and
since we are using at this point we are
using python 3.6 we should use this
command so basically
the terminal we have opened here is is
to use or to run this command that's the
reason i open this terminal however make
sure that the download is complete
before you run this command so we'll
just wait for a couple of minutes and
we'll come back once the download is
done all right so as you can see the
download is done this is a fairly large
file so if you are on a slow internet or
low internet bandwidth then it might
take quite a while it's about uh
578 mb and so this is the file now what
you need to do is
you need to go back to this installation
steps and let me minimize this and
yeah so
this is the command that you need to run
so you can just directly copy and paste
this command from here
okay so i do copy right mouse click
now it will ask you a bunch of questions
as documented here so most of them you
need to just say enter or yes and that's
about it except for the last step i will
just show you what i mean and here you
need to do press enter multiple times
just to make sure you agree to all these
agreement uh the license agreement and
so on and so forth so once you do
multiple
enters it will
bring you to the next step
all right so now here again they say do
you accept the terms you just say yes
and then press enter and here it will
ask you a couple of questions and pretty
much you need to just go for the default
version press enter to confirm you just
say press enter and
this is primarily when it will pretty
much start the installation
process of anaconda this might take a
little while depending again on your
internet speed so you need to have some
patience we will also probably come back
once this installation is done or if i
if it asks for any further questions
all right so here you'll get again one
more question do you used to
wish the installer to prepend
so you just say yes for this question
and
keep going now the last question
i think we are pretty much at the end
and that is about microsoft
vss i guess
yeah vs code so for this you can just
say no because we will not be using this
and
that's it you're done so this is a
completion of installation of anaconda
so it's always a good idea to exit and
start a fresh terminal okay so
let's start again terminal
so we are done with the
installation of anaconda the next step
is to create a virtual environment with
python 3.4 so for that this is the
command conda create dash n
and this is the name of your virtual
environment you can give any name but
for easy reference i have given us
tensorflow and we have to specify the
python version as i mentioned earlier we
will be using the combination of python
3.4
and
tensorflow 1.5 now this is not the
latest version python has probably 3.6
at this point at the time of creation of
this video and even tensorflow probably
has the latest version as 1.7 but then
these combinations sometimes may not
work and i found that after several
trials and errors 3.4 with 1.5 seems to
be most reliable and that's the reason i
have chosen this i would recommend you
to try with this first if you're a
beginner and later on maybe you can try
out the other permutations and
combinations all right one step i just
wanted to show you is before we do the
installation or creation of the virtual
environment if you want to just clarify
or confirm whether anaconda has been
installed or not you can run what is
known as anaconda navigator so you just
say anaconda
navigator
okay we need to edit this part hold on
one second i guess it is
all right so you see here when you start
anaconda navigator
this
anaconda navigator will open up that is
the indication that anaconda has been
installed properly so that's just a
quick check and you don't have to do
anything just you can go back and close
it
once this comes up and
then in the meanwhile let me just open
one more terminal
for the creation of the
virtual environment
and um
yeah so this is your anaconda navigator
and you can just say okay don't show me
just say okay
and
then you can close this
you can say file you can do a file exit
or you can click on close button
whichever
all right so we will exit from here
we have a
terminal open here we will use this for
our next steps all right so what we have
to do now is
type in
this
piece of
code or this command
for some reason copy paste is not
working so
it's a small command so it shouldn't be
that big of an issue so we say conda
and we say
create
so this is the command for creating a
new environment slash
dash n
and then we give the name of the
environment so we will we can give any
name for uh
convenience i'm just calling it
tensorflow
but you can actually name it anything
and then we need to specify with the
which version of python so we say pip
python
and then that is equal
3.5
okay so it will create an environment
this will take a little while it will
ask you a question just say yes and then
it will be done
so this is just a warning you can simply
ignore that
and
for the question that it asks you just
say yes and i think you should be good
all right so it says do you want to
proceed you say yes then enter
this will again take a little bit little
time so we will probably move forward
and then come back once this is done
all right so
the environment has been created now
it's always a good idea to whenever some
of these steps get over or each step
gets over you just exit the terminal and
start afresh with a new terminal for
some reason sometimes it causes problem
if you continue so i found that it is
a safe practice to each time exit the
terminal and start afresh now that we
have an environment created
we can by the name tensorflow you can
enter that environment by calling the
command source
activate
tensorflow to name whatever name you
have given so you'll see here once you
do that you will get this the name of
the environment will be shown here so it
is like your own again a special
environment within within the system and
from here onwards you can do other stuff
like actually installing tensorflow and
so on and you will see that it has
installed python 3 here so 3.4 right so
it is installed that's what we during
creation of this environment we wanted
python 3.4 so that is what it is showing
but we are not yet done so we need to
still install tensorflow so in this
environment you need to
run a command which will actually
install the correct combination of
tensorflow now this is as you can see
it's a slightly complicated command with
install
dash dash ignore install so
what we can do is uh from within here we
can go and
go to tensorflow install page and there
is a sample code there you can pick up
from there so that you don't have to
type in so much
so we say tensorflow
tensor
flow
dark and i'll also open up probably a
notepad here so that we can construct
that command and go here
you say
ubuntu
if you come further down there will be
by the way we are doing cpu installation
i think
that is clear we are not there is a
possibility to do gpu as well we will
probably create a separate video for
that
and
if we go here
yeah so
again you probably if you follow the
entire document out here it may still
not work so i do not recommend that for
now at least for beginners but just to
copy this command because this is a
fairly complicated command so this is
much easier to copy it from here that's
the reason i'm
on this page
and we will
then
modify it according to yes okay let's
say
copy
and don't do it directly here because
that is probably not yet the right
command
let us go and create a notepad
page
empty document
i'll just say
tf.txt
okay this is just a temporary file what
we need to do here is we need to adjust
this command to suit the
versions that we are installing here so
let me just explain what it is what you
need to do
so first thing you can get rid of this
one
yes okay
now here these parts you can simply
ignore
here you need to go and change it to
version
1.5
and i think we are good with that okay
so
the cp34 indicates your python 3.4
so later on when you're trying to
experiment and if you want to
do
other combinations of tensorflow and
python version then you can change this
for example you can change this to 3 6
both these places you need to change
this to 3 6 if you are using with python
3.6 and similarly if you want the latest
version which is of tensorflow which is
1.7 you need to change this to 1.7 and
so on but at this point to start with if
you are a beginner i would recommend
that you stick to this tensorflow 1.5
with python 3.4 this is tried and tested
and it works okay just a word of caution
that just by changing these versions it
the whole thing
will not work there may be other places
where you may have to some of the steps
may change so just a word of caution
that just by changing this if you want
to try out with a different version some
of the steps may also change so don't
think that just by changing this just
one particular command you will be
fine okay so
that's been my experience so to start
with i would recommend use this
particular combination all right so it
looks good
uh tensorflow 1.5 and
let me
just reconfirm with my notes and i think
it looks good so this is install ignore
1.5 cp34 cp34
and so on okay
okay so let's hit enter
so it started the process again this
might take a little while so we will
pause the recalling and then get back
when the
installation is done okay so looks like
this installation is done
and as always let us
exit and then come back now
you're currently in the environment
virtual environment
and it's a good practice before you exit
out of the terminal to come out
out of the virtual environment so just
like you did source activate
you need to do source deactivate
and
the name tensor
flow okay you will come back to the
original command prompt and then from
here you can
do an exit now we need to validate
whether the tensorflow installation has
gone through properly or not so
the way to validate is to
first start python and then import
tensorflow library see if it imports
without error so that's the best way to
validate so we'll open a terminal
and whenever you want to get into
the
environment this is how you have to do
come to environment and then say source
and obviously you can also use existing
so source activate
tensorflow okay
so we do this and you need to run python
from here remember you should say
python3 because you have installed item
3.4 now here when you say import
tensorflow
as df
when you get back a prompt like this
without any errors that means tensorflow
installation has been successful if
tensorflow was not installed properly
you will get an error saying tensorflow
is not available or module doesn't exist
or something like that so tensorflow
installation is done but now we will go
through the process of installing
jupyter notebook so that you can do your
development so let me just exit
and in order to install your jupyter
notebook which is your which is going to
be your development environment we will
first
install ipython using conda so conda
install ipython and then pip install
jupiter so let's first do the
ipython conda
install
python
again it will ask you a question saying
these are the components do you want to
install you just say yes
all right you say yes
once again it will take a little while
so we might pause the recording and come
back once it is done
great so that did not take much
time anyways so we will
as usual we will
exit which is
source deactivate
tensorflow
exit and then we will start a fresh
terminal
in order to install
jupiter
now in some places
they may say
install jupiter using pip3 but in my
experience it did not work with p3 and
that's the reason we will use pip
however just keep in mind you need to
first go to the environment so
source activate
tensorflow
and you need to use this command which
is pip install jupyter usually when
you're on python 3 you use pip3 but as i
said it did not work so
in my experience it works with pip
install and not p3 so pip install
jupyter
i hope you already noticed that it is
jupy per
and not jpi
so again it's probably taking a little
while we will pause the recording and
come back once it is done
okay so jupiter installation is also
done
once again
you need to it's a good idea not you
need to but it's a good idea to
come out of this terminal session and
then start afresh
so we exit and we have a fresh terminal
already available here
and
we will once again
go to tensorflow
and we say
jupiter
notebook
that's how you start your jupyter
this looks good now only thing is since
we are running
uh for the first time what you need to
do is if you come back to your command
prompt
it will show you that if you are running
it for the first time it will say that
you need to copy paste this link so you
you can just for the first time only
once you need to do this
copy this
and
paste it in your
browser
and remember this is only the first time
when you're running jupyter you need to
do this
subsequently you don't have to it will
automatically
open up all right so now that we have
jupyter installed and
it starts up we need to test whether
tensorflow
is working fine or not and in order to
do that you can create a new
notebook
and you say import
tensorflow
as tf and shift enter if everything is
fine then supply is installed properly
you don't get any errors and then it
works fine this is an indication that
tensorflow got installed successfully
and that's about it so
that's all about installing tensorflow
with python 3.4 so remember this is
installation of tensorflow 1.5 with
python 3.4
on ubuntu and uh once again in case you
have a windows system in fact i have
also done it on a windows system you can
use virtual blocks to create a virtual
environment ubuntu environment and then
follow these steps and there are tons of
videos to create virtual box and that's
the reason
we have not included those steps in this
and if there are any comments there are
better ways to do this please mention it
in the comment section below or if you
need any further help just mention it
and with your email we will respond to
you in order to develop a deep learning
application how do you go about
primarily there are two or three
components that are required in order to
develop deep learning application you
need obviously a programming language so
typically python is used and that's what
we are going to use in this particular
video but you can also use other
languages like java or c plus plus and
so on and there are some libraries that
are readily available and for primarily
for doing
machine learning and deep learning
programming so these are a list of
libraries these are by no means the
exhaustive list but some of the most
common ones like keras theano tensorflow
and so on and so forth tensorflow has
nowadays become very very popular this
is developed by google and it is an open
source library and keras was there
before now keras has actually now become
a part of tensorflow as well so it is
one player about tensorflow so in that
sense they're well integrated so
combination of keras and uh tensorflow
is uh pretty good then of course you
have a torch and tl4j and so on and so
forth so there are multiple libraries
but this video is about tensorflow and
we will be focusing on tensorflow what
are the benefits of tensorflow and what
are its components and our towards the
end we will show you a code in python
we've written a code in python by the
way tensorflow can be used with multiple
languages it supports multiple languages
though python is by far the most popular
language so let's take a look at what
exactly is tensorflow and why we are so
excited about tensorflow so tensorflow
offers um apis now we can earlier
without when these libraries none of
these libraries were there even then we
were doing people were doing machine
learning and deep learning and so on but
the coding mechanism was much more
complicated what these libraries like
tensorflow offer is they provide kind of
a high level api so that we don't have
to go really deep into writing all the
stuff that is required let's say to
prepare a neural network and to even
configure or even to program a neuron
and so on right so these are done by the
library so all you need to do is they
offer a higher level api you need to use
that api and call that api and maybe
pass the data and that would pretty much
it's much easier rather than actually
going down and writing everything by
yourself so tensorflow that way it
offers apis for to write your code in
python or even c plus plus and and so on
other languages java as well it has an
integration with r as well apparently
okay and it supports cpus as well as
gpus now deep learning applications are
very compute intensive especially the
training process needs a lot of
computation it takes very long as you
can imagine that because the the data
size is large and there are so many
iterative processes there are so much of
mathematical calculations matrix
multiplication and so on and so forth so
for that if you perform these activities
on a normal cpu typically it would take
much longer but
gpus are graphical processing units you
must have heard gpus in the context of
games and so on because where you need
the screen needs to be of high
resolution and the images need to be of
high resolution and so on so gpus that
as the name such as graphical processing
unit were originally designed for that
but since they are very good at handling
this kind of iterative calculations and
so on now they are kind of they are
being used or leveraged rather for doing
or developing deep learning applications
and tensorflow supports gpus as well as
cpus so i think that's one of the major
advantages of tensorflow as well now
again what is exactly tensorflow it's a
open source library developed by google
and open source and primarily for deep
learning development but tensorflow also
supports traditional machine learning by
the way so if you want to do some
traditional machine learning we can do
it however it is probably a bit of an
overhead to use tensorflow for doing
traditional machine learning and this is
really good for performing deep learning
activities and again if you want to get
into more details about what's the
difference between machine learning and
deep learning there is another video
about it you can probably take a look at
that video what else it is developed
originally for large numerical
computations so originally when
tensorflow was developed they never
thought of it as a keeping deep learning
in mind but ultimately it so happened
that it's really uh very good for deep
learning development and therefore
google has open sourced it and
tensorflow as the name suggests the data
is in the form of what is known as
tensors these are like multi-dimensional
arrays and they are very handy in
handling large amounts of data and we
will see that as well as we move forward
and then of course the execution
mechanism is in the form of graphs so
that makes it much easier to execute
this code in a distributed manner across
a cluster of computers and and also
using gpus and so on and so forth right
so that's a quick overview about what is
tensorflow we will see a little bit more
detail the two major components that is
basically the tensors and the graphs
let's take a look at what they are so
what are tensors tensor is as i
mentioned earlier it is like a
multi-dimensional array in which the
data is stored now when we are doing
deep learning especially the training
process you will have large amounts of
data and the data is in typically in a
very complicated format and it really
helps when you are able to put this use
this or store it in a compact way and so
tensors actually offer a very nice and
compact way of storing the data handling
the data during computation this is not
really for storing on your hard disk or
things like that but in memory when you
are doing the computation tenses are
really really very handy in terms of
keeping the data compact because they
are like multi-dimensional arrays so the
data is stored in tensors and then it is
fed into the neural network and then you
get the output all right so there are
some terms associated with tensors let's
get ourselves familiarized one is uh the
dimension and another is the rank so
what is dimension typically dimension is
like the number of elements in a way so
for example this is a five by four
dimension tensor and then you can have
again the multi dimensions right so you
can this can be like three by three by
three so that is uh the dimension and
then you have ranks so what are tensor
ranks ranks are basically traditionally
we would have thought of as dimensions
that is actually in this case it is
called rank so it becomes easier when we
see examples so a tensor's rank is
supposed to be zero when there is only
one element we also call this as scalar
so just one element and this is not
really a vector it's just an element
like 200 it's also known as a scalar so
such a tensor is supposed to be having a
rank of zero then you have let's say a
one dimensional array this is a vector
with a row of elements this has rank of
one now if you have traditionally what
we called as a two dimensional like a
matrix for example then the rank is two
and in this case the rank is three and
it can have more ranks as well as i
mentioned it is like a multi-dimensional
array so you can have rank five six and
so on okay so those are the
terminologies in tensorflow terms
dimensions and ranks so this is just to
make sure that we are picking the same
language so whenever we talk about the
rank of a tensor you understand what
exactly is meant by that now in addition
to tensors in which the data is actually
stored all right so the data is stored
in the tensors and then once you have
the data there is a computation that
needs to be done now the computation
happens in the form of graphs so what we
typically in a tensorflow program what
we do is it's not like traditional
programming where you just write a bunch
of lines and then everything gets
executed in sequence here we prepare
graphs various nodes and then these are
executed in the form of a session and
they use the data from these tensors now
i know this is a slightly new concept
for a lot of you so it may be a little
difficult to probably understand in the
first cut but when we look at the code
when we go into the tutorial the code
walkthrough i think that time it will
become much clearer as well but to start
with just uh we need to keep in mind
that we have to first prepare a graph
and when you're preparing the graph no
none of the code is actually getting
executed you write the code to prepare
the graph and then you execute that
graph so that's the way by creating a
session that's the way tensorflow
program works so and each of these
computation is represented as what is
known as a data flow graph and we will
also see that whenever you start
tensorflow when you create an object
tensorflow object there will be what is
known as the default graph and then if
required i know probably in the
beginning it may not be required but in
more advanced programming you can
actually have multiple graphs instead of
the default graph you can create your
own graph and have multiple graphs and
use it as well but there is always
whenever you create a tensorflow object
there will be a default graph and this
will be very nicely illustrated in the
example code that we will take to
explain this so there it becomes much
clearer than in these slides so the
graph gets executed and it processes all
the data that we are feeding all the
external data will be fed in the form of
what is known as placeholders and then
you have variables and constants again
this will also become clear when we take
a look at the code and once you have the
graph then the execution can be enabled
either on regular cpus or on gpus and
also in a distributed mode so that the
processing becomes much faster as i
mentioned the training of the models in
deep learning takes extremely long
because of the large amount of data and
therefore using tensorflow actually
makes it much easier to write the code
for gpus or cpus and then execute it in
a distributed manner so this is how the
tensorflow program looks so there is uh
you need to build a computational graph
that's the first step and then you
execute that graph so the first step is
to write the code for preparing the
graph and then you create what is known
as a session and then in that session
you ask the session to execute this
graph so this will again become much
clearer when we look at the code now
what are the various elements of a
tensorflow program as i mentioned
tensorflow program is slightly different
from regular programming that we do so
even if you're familiar with python this
may still be new for you the way you
write a tensorflow program is different
from the regular python programming that
you would have done or even machine
learning program you would have written
some machine learning program using
scikit-learn or regular python libraries
this is different from even that so let
us see what are the various elements so
first of all the way we handle data
inside of a program itself is a little
different from how we normally do in a
normal programming language a variable
is a variable in your program right so
you have anything that can keep changing
you just create as a variable or even
constants in fact are actually created
as variables but in tensorflow the
storage in the program consists of three
types one is constants another is
variable and the third is a placeholder
so and they are difference between these
types and we will see how they vary and
how they are used and so on so constants
are like variables which cannot be
changed so for example if you define a
constant like this this is how you
define a constant by the way the
simplest format is like this like for
example b is equal to t f dot constant
and then you give a value here the
slightly more advanced version is you
also specify the type so you say
tf.constant 2.0 tf load 32 so the type
is of type float now in case of
constants you cannot during the
computation you cannot really change
these values so for example if you want
to change the value of b from 3 to 5 or
any other number it is not possible so
that is the meaning of constant all
right so then we have variables so
variables we're all familiar with what
are variables whenever we use
programming we use variables so this is
pretty much the same this is the way you
define variables df dot variable now one
thing you need to note is this is the
only type in which we have v capital
okay constant has c a small c and
placeholder as small p but variable as
capital v and tf.variable and then you
give the a value and then you can
specify what is the type and then you
can use the variable change the variable
at any point in time with a different
value and so on you can update the
variable and so on so we will see all of
this in the code i will illustrate how a
variable is defined and how it can be
changed whereas the constant cannot be
changed and so on and so forth and then
we have placeholders placeholders are
really a special type and this may be
something completely new for many of us
who have been doing programming but in
tensorflow this is a completely new
concept so this is very important to
understand this placeholders are like
variables but only thing is that they
are used for feeding the data from
outside so typically when you are
performing some computations you need to
load data from a file or from an image
file or from a csv file or whatever so
there is a provision with the special
kind of variables which can be fed in a
regular basis because the reason one of
the reasons for having this kind of
provision is that if you get the entire
input in one shot typically it may be
very difficult to handle the memory and
so on so i think that was the reason
they came up with this mechanism where
you can feed in patches and there is a
certain way of populating the
placeholder we call this feed dig feed
underscore dick and this is a parameter
name by the way and you feed the
placeholders right that is the meaning
here so there is a certain way of
feeding the placeholders and we will
again see this in the example code as we
move forward okay so there are three
types one is the constant which cannot
be changed once you assign a value then
you have variables which are like normal
variables we are all familiar with and
then you have placeholders this is
primarily for feeding data from usually
from outside but of course you can also
for temporary testing purpose you can
feed within the program as well but
primarily the purpose of a placeholder
is to get data from outside so all right
so those were the constants variables
and placeholders that is how you
handle data within the tensorflow
program and then you create a graph and
once you create a graph then you have
what is known as a session and then you
create a session object and you create a
session and then you run a particular
computation or a node or an operation
and so typically what you need to do is
every variable or a computation that you
perform is like an operation or a node
within a graph so initially the graph
will be what is known as the default
graph the moment you create a tensorflow
object or tf this tf here you see this
is the tensorflow object and again in
the code when we go into the code it
will become much easier to understand so
when you create a tensorflow object
there is like a default graph which
doesn't have any operations no nodes or
anything like that so it's like a clean
slate the moment you
assign variables or constants or
placeholders each of them is in
tensorflow terms it is known as an
operation again you need to get familiar
with these terms and they are not very
intuitive this is not really an
operation you're just creating a
constant or a variable but and this c is
equal to a into b would traditionally or
would intuitively be an operation here
you're actually performing an operation
but in tensorflow terms each of these
everything is an operation so if you're
creating a constant that is an operation
another constant or variable that's an
operation so you can actually run each
of these and they are also known as
referred to as nodes and when you're in
your session you will actually
run each of these you can potentially
run each of these nodes okay so a
typical example would look like this so
you have two constants created a is
equal to tf.constant its value is 5 b is
equal to this and then you say c is
equal to a into b and then you create a
session now remember all this you're
just creating a graph at this point no
execution has happened all right so only
at this point once you create a session
and then you say session or says dot run
c is when actually this whole thing will
get executed all right so that is a
different way of programming compared to
our traditional way of writing programs
so you need to get used to this new
format and when we look at the code as
we move forward and when we look in the
jupyter notebook it will become much
easier probably to understand this
rather than in the slide so these are
the slides showing the code but what we
can do is go straight into the
lab and take a look at the various
examples that are there and starting
from the very basic one how you create
variables and so these are some of the
slides that are showing so this is about
how to create variables how to create
constants and the variables or constants
can also be strings so this is like our
first hello world program and we will
talk about placeholders how to define a
placeholder and how to execute and
populate the placeholder values into
placeholder we will see these examples
in the lab actually i will run the code
and
we will also perform a small computation
of adding and multiplying these
variables and
we will in the end we will take up a use
case implementation using tensorflow so
let's first go and see those examples
and then come back and i'll explain this
use case and then we will execute the
use case in the lab so let's go and
check our lab okay so i'm in the jupyter
notebook environment and
this is one of the development
environments we can use this is regular
python anytime you do python programming
we use gypted notebook or there are
rather of course there are other ways of
using other tools like pycharm and so on
but for this particular tutorial i'm
comfortable using jupyter notebook so i
will show you in jupyter notebook so
this is the very basic example to
demonstrate how to create variables and
constants and placeholders and what is
the difference between them how they
behave and so on and as i mentioned the
assumption here is that you know at
least some basic python programming or
some programming language so at least
you understand the code here and first
two pieces of code you will not need
machine learning background but when we
do the use case or the case study there
it is expected that you know at least
some basic machine learning concepts so
in case you need to brush up the machine
learning part you may have to do that
before you go to the third one but here
just at least some idea of programming
will be sufficient so what are we doing
here in this particular line or in this
particular cell we are importing
tensorflow it is uh as i mentioned it is
a library so we are importing tensorflow
and we are calling it tf so this is just
a name you can give it any name but it
is very common and everywhere wherever
tensorflow programming is done it is
always named as tf but you can name
anything actually okay so this will
import the tensorflow into my session
now this is the way to create a variable
so let's start by creating a variable
and this is the name of my variable i'm
starting by giving a name called 0 and i
say 0 is equal to tf dot variable and
then i'm giving the value of the
variable here so this is the very basic
way and the simplest way to create a
variable we will see a little later
there are other formats as well but the
bare minimum way of creating a variable
is this so i'm creating a variable by
the name zero and as i mentioned you
need to pay attention to the capital v
here in case of variable it is a capital
v uppercase constant and placeholders
are
lowercase now i'm creating a constant
then the constant i am naming it as 1
and the way to create a constant is tf
dot constant and then you give the
value of the constant so the value of
the variable here is zero and the value
of constant here is one and again
constant you can also have additional
parameters like a name and so on
probably you must have seen in other
tutorials or in other places where the
code is written but the basic format
construct to create a constant is this
this is sufficient to create a constant
so i created one variable and one
constant now what else can we do again
here there is no real execution
happening we are just building a graph
we have not yet executed any tensorflow
code we are building a graph and i will
show you how the graph looks as well
first let us understand the constants
and variables and so on and then i will
show you how the graph is generated and
so on so what i want to do here is i
want to add 0 and 1 and put it into a
new variable called new value so what i
do here tensorflow offers these methods
like add assign multiply or
you have matrix multiplication matmul
and so on right so i will use one of
those methods which is tf.add and then
pass these two as parameters so we can
add a variable and a constant there are
no restrictions on that so this is a
variable and this is a constant so if i
do this it will be okay i did not
execute this code so it is giving an
error now we are good okay so what it
has done is new value will be equal to
tf dot add 0 1 so then we have one
variable and one constant now let's say
i want to change the value of the
variable because that is possible right
so we want to change the value of the
variable to something some new value so
we have in this case new value has one
because we added a zero and a one so new
value has one now i want to assign this
to this originally what we called as
zero so i will call that as update is
equal to tf dot assign so assign is
basically changing the value so that's
what we are going to do here now it has
not complained we'll just say fine right
there are no issues now let us try this
something similar
with this 1 as well so 0 is a variable
so we were able to change the value and
we will in a little while we will see
what exactly those values are but before
doing that now let's say i will
uncomment this part and i want to do
something similar for my constant right
1 is a constant now i want to let's say
change the value of the constant and
make that also something different okay
so if i execute this piece of code it
will give an error now again the error
message may not be very intuitive this
doesn't say that you cannot do this for
a constant it will just say tensor
object has no attribute assign now that
sometimes may be confusing especially
when you are starting but the meaning
here is that one is a constant and
you're trying to modify the constant so
it will not allow that's the reason it
is complaining so let's put that back in
the comment and
okay so that is done so only variables
you can modify now what you have to do
let's skip this piece of code i'll come
back to this in a bit
but let's say we start by creating you
remember i told you we need to create a
session so the way to create a session
there are a couple of ways of creating a
session but this is for beginners this
is the easiest way all you need to do is
assign a variable called says or you can
give any name and that is equal to tf
dot session that is a session method
here and you create a session object by
the name says now what i'll do is i'll
skip this as well i there is a purpose
behind that now let's go ahead and run
this piece of particular operation
remember i mentioned that everything you
need to run so as of now the code has
not really got executed tensorflow code
has not got executed you only created
the graph so only when you
run through the session is when that
actually the program gets executed so
when you do this now you see observe
that it is giving an error okay the
reason behind that is remember we skip
these two lines of code for variables
okay this and then this now this is
something very very important to observe
if you have variables in your code what
i mean by that is let's say you are not
using variables but you have only
constants and placeholders then this
will not complain and you will not get
this error but in our case we also have
variables so whenever you have variables
in that case you need to do an
initialization and this is just a
standard code there is nothing that we
need to add or modify or anything like
that this is a standard piece of code
you create this name of course can be
anything you can give us any name but
this global variables initializer is
what you need to call tf.global
variables initializer this will kind of
initialize all the variables that you
may be using and then again remember
this doesn't execute anything right so
all you're doing here is you're creating
an operation but in order to run that
operation you need to also run this
known as
run init underscore op so this operation
you need to run after creating the
session all right so we executed this
now let us execute this and now when i
run this piece of code it will run
successfully okay i hope you observed
that so it is whenever you use variables
these two lines of code one is the
operation you need to create an
operation for saying global variables
initializer and then you need to run
before running anything else you need to
do a session.run this operation okay
again only if you're using
variables of course you invariably in
all your programs you will use variables
you cannot just write a program with
constants and placeholders so you can
pretty much assume that this has to be
there in pretty much all the programs
now again why
this has not been taken care of in the
library that's a different question but
you need to keep in mind and always
remember if you don't do this for
whatever reason if you're forgotten you
will get an error and the error won't be
intuitive so you need to remember this
that this could be because of the
variables okay good so we have seen how
to create a constant and we have seen
how to create a variable and we have
seen that you cannot modify or update a
constant and we have also seen if you
have variables that you need to execute
or have these two lines of code to
initialize the variables and then we
have seen that after creating a graph
how to run the graph in a session and i
will show you a little bit more in
detail how exactly the graph gets
created and how it gets executed but
this was the first very quick code on
creating variables and constants now we
will keep going and
we will also show you or i will show you
the placeholders but before that one
more small piece of code so this is how
you write a for loop okay so we are
saying five times you run this piece of
code now like any python program this is
nothing different so you have a for loop
and this is indented that's the reason
and therefore you say session.run update
so this will run five times and it will
get printed that's all so update will
run for five times each time it will
come and do this particular operation
that's all we are we are asking the
system to do so let me just run that and
show you let me yeah so it will
okay so it has done five times
one that's four it is basically adding
if you recall it starts from zero it
adds one to zero then one to one one to
two and so on so it's nothing but it is
generating five numbers one two three
four five that's it okay so then
you can also have your constants as
strings for example so you can also work
in a similar way you can work with
string so most of the computation
happens
mainly on numerical values so we
normally had handle numbers but
there will be situations where you may
have to handle strings as well or text
as well so this is an example of text
operation so you can similar to numbers
you just create strings or store
in constants instead of a number you say
hello is equal to tf.constant and then
you assign the string that you want it
to be assigned and then the next one is
one more string which is for world and
then you say add these two so it is
nothing but concatenation of these two
words hello and
world
so we will do that and remember this is
only creation of the graph right so in
order to actually execute this graph you
need to run the session now you need to
keep in mind we don't have to create the
session once again because once you
create a session till you close the
session it remains valid okay so we have
created this session here now till you
say says dot close it will remain for
you so that's why we did not create one
more so we are just reusing that session
says dot run hello world so in this
hello world what is the operation that
we are doing here the operation is add
these two concatenate these two so if i
run this it will print hello world okay
now that's string operation now we will
take a look at placeholders so this is
slightly more complicated and something
new even for people who have been
writing programs so but i'll just
explain it with uh with a quick example
first of all how do you declare or
create a placeholder you just do
tf.placeholder and the p is lowercase
only in case of variables the b is
uppercase but otherwise constant and
placeholders it is lowercase and you
just say because as i mentioned this is
a placeholder it doesn't have any value
so you unlike a constant or your
variable you can't usually you will not
specify any value you just say what type
of placeholder you want and very often
most of the cases it is a floating point
so we just say placeholder of type
float32 so this tf.float32
tells the system that it is a floating
point okay and then so let me just run
this and then you can do some or define
some computation like for example b is
equal to a into two now remember here
right now a has no value but what we are
saying here is at any point later on
when a gets some value then b should be
equal to twice the value of a that's all
we are saying here okay and also as i
mentioned earlier
we are not yet executing anything we are
just creating the graph here okay so now
you have that now how do you feed the
value or populate the placeholder there
is a certain syntax in which you can
populate the placeholder and you do that
using what is known as a dictionary
you're all probably familiar those with
python especially must be familiar with
the dictionaries so you need to create a
dictionary and then pass that
in order to feed the placeholder so in
this particular example if i want to run
something if i want to calculate or
compute b obviously i need to feed the
value of a so the value of a i'm feeding
using this dictionary and i'm saying
that a is equal to 3. now there are
multiple ways of populating the value of
a because it typically this won't be
just a single a scalar value like in
this case right remember scalar so it's
just one value one number typically it
would be a vector or
a tensor very often it is a tensor so we
will see step by step so we can start
with the very basic example where a can
be a scalar so in this case a is equal
to 3 that's what we are saying feed
underscore dict in this case feed
underscore dick is the
name of a variable by the way so you
can't give anything else here so if you
just say feed is equal to this it will
give you an error all right so keep that
in mind either you specify feed
underscore dick is equal to and give the
dictionary pass the dictionary or you
straight away like in this case this is
another format so let's see first let me
execute this it has given 6 okay i think
let me see if i can clear out this
particular cell so it becomes easier to
understand okay so it is giving you six
let me do that once again clear out this
and then okay and let me change the
format so this is one way of doing it
another way is you don't even have to
specify the name of this parameter feed
underscore deck you just pass the
dictionary and it will
execute okay but typically this makes
the code readable so that's the reason
most of the places whenever you find
tensorflow code you will see that they
explicitly mention feed underscore date
so that the code is readable otherwise
it can get confusing so i will also
comment this and retain the other format
okay so i hope it's clear so what we are
doing here we are running the operation
b and what exactly is bb is twice a a
into 2 so therefore what we are doing
and a has not been
doesn't have any value out here right so
that's why we are feeding the value of a
and then the operation gets completed so
a gets a value of 3
and then it gets multiplied by 2 because
that's what we said here therefore b
gets a value of 6 and that's what is
being fed into result and that's what is
getting printed here okay now as i
mentioned a need not be just a scalar
value it can be a vector with a
multi-dimension uh array and so on and
so forth so let's start showing you uh
examples of that again let me just clear
out the outputs let me clear this and
let me also clear this for now okay you
can also do
before running up this you could we
could also do clear all output all
output clear it will clear everything
but that will we'll have to start all
over again so i am just doing
individually all right so
in this example we are taking a one
dimension array where rank is equal to
one and i'm feeding three four five now
let us see what happens if i run this
right as you can imagine it gets
multiplied each number gets multiplied
so the result is 6 8 10 okay now as i
said it can get more complicated now
let's say this is a multi-dimensional
vector so if you what happens if you
feed this okay so as you can see this is
pretty complicated now but if you feed
this again all you're doing is
there is okay there is a slight change
here again you can also
create your dictionary outside and feed
that here you don't have to directly do
it here like in this case you see there
are variations of the exact syntax in
the way you write it right so there is a
slight variation so in this case you are
creating the dictionary straight away
here kind of inline but here you created
the dictionary separately because it's
more complicated and then you are
passing that dictionary here so i said
dictionary is equal to a and then i'm
saying this is what should be the value
of a this is and i'm feeding that and
then i'm
using directly that dictionary here okay
so this is equivalent to putting this
code here right so if we execute this
what happens same so you get because a
was a let's say this is a
three by
four by two right so that is one yeah
three by four by two right so you see
here this is a multi-dimensional array
so you feed that and the values you see
here is one two three it became two four
six four five six became eight ten
twelve seven eight nine became 14 16 18
and so on and so forth okay i hope now
you got an idea about placeholders and
in real life what happens is you
typically won't create these
dictionaries manually in since this is a
quick demo we did this you will actually
read the data into this dictionary and
then you feed that when you're doing the
computation okay so it could be a csv
file or it could be a image file so the
input is basically read and fed in
usually it is also done in patches so
you don't read the entire thing because
there can be large amount of data so
that is the idea behind having these
placeholders and the way we feed these
placeholders there is a provision that
is a deliberately that has been made a
provision for this kind of getting data
into the program in chunks okay now in
this particular example we will close
the session here and then i will show
you what is the other way of creating a
session right so now if i close the
session here now if i try to do anything
with the session it will give us an
error so i will probably not do that
right now now there is another way or
another format and this is a very common
way of using the session but i didn't
want to start off with this because this
could get a little confusing the a
simpler way was to create session saying
says is equal to tf.session but
typically you will do it in what is
known as a width block this is a very
common way of creating session so once
you have the graph you would execute the
graph in a session using a width block
and this is the syntax so you say with
df dot session assess all right and then
you put all your code here so what will
happen is you don't have to explicitly
close the session the moment this width
block gets completed the session gets
closed okay so let's just take a quick
look at this example now if i uh let me
clear this current output be clear okay
so this is the hello world example a
little bit earlier we did that so i'm
doing
with tf.session assassin result is equal
to says dot run hello plus world and
then i say print result okay so within
this with block i'm doing all my
computation and this gets executed now
let's say i try to run remember i
created a session here now if i want to
let's say do something like run sesh dot
run a it is giving an error because the
session is no longer valid
right so you cannot either you have to
run this if you want to run this you
have to run this in this with block
or you shouldn't have closed the session
here right you remember this we said
session.close so since we have closed
the session there is no
active session therefore it is giving an
error okay now there is a third way
of creating a session but for now i will
skip it because that is very very
specific to
notebooks and and so on so we will just
avoid it you start with for beginners i
think the best way is to start with
creating a separate session and then
writing your code and then closing your
session now of course remember if you
don't do this part says dot close it
will not give any error or anything like
that only thing is it's a good practice
and your resources will get released
otherwise
if you do multiple of these programs if
they are running then your resources
will get blocked that's the only thing
and to start with this it is simpler to
do it this way so initially when you're
doing you start with this but as you
move forward as you become familiar with
tensorflow programming i would recommend
all of you to get into this model most
of the programming tensorflow
programming is done like this with df
dot session as says okay all right so
that was one book or one page of a code
that we have done explaining about
variables constants and placeholders now
let me explain how the graph works so in
this example we are going to see how the
graph is created how the graph gets
executed and so on okay now that we got
a understanding of constants and
variables and placeholders okay so we
will start as usual by importing our
library and as i said whenever you
create a tf or tensorflow object there
will be what is known as a default graph
and you can get a handle of that by
saying get default graph so let's do
that and you can display the operations
remember every node in the graph is
considered as an operation right so as
of now as you can see
we have not done anything we have not
created a constant or variable or
nothing right so there was there is no
operation so by the way let's do one
thing let's start with the
all output clear so that
i don't have to again do individually so
we i'll just run these two lines of code
okay now so yeah so we have the default
graph and as of now there are no
operations so there is a method called
get underscore operations which will
kind of display
or show what are the various operations
that have been performed on the graph so
as i said to start with they have no
operations been performed so when i try
to display it's empty there are no
nothing is there no operations okay now
let's see what happens when we slowly
step by step start writing or building
the graph so my first step may be to
create a constant okay remember in the
previous example i have shown you how to
create a constant in the most simple or
the simplest way which is like constant
and then the number right now a small
extension of that is you can actually
give a name to your constant now again
this need not be the same i can say a is
equal to name and xyz i can give
anything here okay this is just for your
reference but here for simplicity
because there is a purpose why i am
using the same name as the name of the
variable and there are other reasons as
well why you would give a name again to
a constant or a variable this is again
useful when we are using what is known
as tensorboard otherwise it doesn't have
much value this additional name doesn't
have much value in this our case also we
will be seeing the graph and that's why
i'm using this but otherwise this having
additionally a name usually doesn't add
much value all right so let's create a
constant
i created a constant now let us see
what's going on in the graph so i will
just say operations is equal to get
operations and if you see here now
you remember here it was blank now you
see the first operation is showing up
and this a that's the reason i put here
so it is showing as a and it says that
okay you have performed an operation
and there is a constant you have created
a constant okay all right so let's move
on let's say we want to create a second
constant and this is b so if i see what
does what are the operations list of
operations that have been performed you
see here there are two of them so you
have operation a which is a constant
then you have an operation b another
constant you recall we in the term
operation here is not very intuitive
right so we are just creating constants
or numbers or variables and it is saying
it's an operation but that's that's a
terminology in tensorflow everything is
an operation here okay all right so then
what else let's say i want to create a
third operation
and that is basically adding which is
this is a real operation in normal sense
as well so let's say i am creating c
which is
adding a and b and the c value obviously
will be a plus b
okay now if we want to see what is in c
and we say c you see here it is not
showing
30 it just says it is a tensor
and it is of type in 32 right because
we have not executed the graph we are
still only building the graph i hope
this makes it easy to understand okay so
we are just building the graph we have
till we do remember till we do a session
and run a particular operation
you're not actually executing anything
okay you're just building the graph all
right so now let us see what are the
operations we have done a b and now c so
you will see there are three of them a b
and c okay now let's do one more
operation which is d
and here i am doing multiplication
remember we did a tf dot add now i'll do
tf dot multiply and i'm multiplying a
and b and i'm calling this operation as
d so a has
i think
10 and b has 20 so
d will be actually 200 when we execute
it right now it is just a tensor and it
is of shape in 32 okay and once again we
can see what are the operations abcd and
let's do one last operation here which
is e which is once again multiplication
of c and d now that c has 30 which is a
plus b and d has 200 which is a into b
so
now c into d will be 30 into 200 which
is which is equal to
6 000 but as we have seen earlier that
multiplication will not happen right now
so now you have built a
fairly
simple but operation graph which
consists of
a b c d e one two three four five
operations okay so you built a small
it's not a very complicated one but a
simple graph now you need to execute
these operations so what you need to do
you need to create a session okay so
says dot tf is equal to session and then
you can run these session
print says dot run e now am i missing
something do i have to initialize the
variables that's a question for you
thing can tell me do i have to
initialize the variables that remember i
ran one piece of code i think you must
have got the answer i don't have to
because i am just using
all constants here i have not used any
variable here right so i don't have to
write execute that piece of code to
initialize the variables so i can just
create a session and run any of the
operations that i want to run so in this
case i am running session e operation e
right this operation e now i can
actually run individually
instead of doing directly e i could have
run only a or i could have run b and so
on and so forth but in this case i have
run e which in turn will do all the
required computations which is for
example assigning the value to a and b
and c doing the multiplication and so on
all those operations will be performed
which are required to do the computation
of e okay now there is a small piece of
code that you can use to find out what
are the various operations that are
there in this particular graph in this
case of course it was very easy very
straightforward i have created abcde
but in normal programming in real life
this can sometimes help to see
how
what is there in your graph what kind of
operations are going on in your graph so
you can write this piece of code and it
may sometimes help debugging as well
okay all right so i finished my session
what do we have to do we need to close
the session right because i did not use
the width block so i need to close the
session as a good practice so i close
the session good so that's how the graph
works
i hope it was helpful in understanding
how variables and constants and
placeholders are created in the previous
example we saw and how exactly you
create a graph and then you actually
execute that graph that's the way
tensorflow program works that's the
structure of tensorflow program okay so
now that we understood the structure of
tensorflow programming let's take an
example and a classification example and
take some real
data from from outside external data csv
file and
try to solve a classification problem
for that let's first go back to the
slides and understand what is the
problem statement and then we will come
back okay so what is the case here we
have some census data and which has all
these features or variables like um the
age of a person
what class work class what is his
education what is his marital status
gender and so on and so forth so there
are a bunch of a bunch of features that
are available and
we have to basically classify or not
classify we have to build a model for
classifying whether the income of this
person
is above 50k or below 50k okay so there
is actually a label data available we
will then try to build a model and then
see what is the accuracy so that this is
a typical machine learning problem
actually but as i said tensorflow can be
used for doing machine learning as well
so we will as a simple example we will
take uh machine learning so this is how
the high level the code looks and in
tensorflow programming we also take a
help of regular python libraries like
for example
it could be numpy or it could be
scikit-learn or it could be pandas in
this case and because before you
actually develop or before you train
your model create your model you need to
prepare the data into a certain format
and sometimes if you're doing machine
learning activity you all are familiar
those familiar with machine learning
will know you need to split your data
into training and test data sets so all
that can be done using regular
non-tensorflow libraries right so these
are like regular python libraries and
scikit learn and so on so we use that
and then prepare the data and then use
tensorflow for performing either the
machine learning or deep learning
activity now so what is the advantage of
using tensorflow the main advantage is
that tensorflow offers high level apis
right we talked about that so in this
case we will be using i'll explain what
is in the slide but before that i wanted
to just show you what is the api that we
will be using so we will be using the
estimator api we will be using the
estimator api to create a classifier
what is known as a linear classifier now
in order to do that you need to prepare
the data and you need to prepare the
data into a certain structure or format
and the api itself needs to be fed in a
certain way so that is exactly what we
are doing before we get into the regular
tensorflow code okay so these slides
will quickly show you what exactly is
happening but i will take you into
jupiter notebook and run that code and
show you so here we are importing the
data the data is the name of the file is
census underscore data.csv it's a csv
file and then there is uh
income bracket is one of the columns
which basically is our target that is
what is used that is the label rather
but this doesn't have numeric values so
it has the income so
we need to convert that into binary
values either 0 or 1. so that's what we
are doing here and then we are splitting
using scikit-learn we are doing
splitting of the data into test and
training right so this is a standard
scikit-learn people
some of you who are familiar with
machine traditional machine learning and
you have done machine learning in python
using scikit-learn will immediately
recognize this this is a sk learner's
scikit-learn and there is a readily
available method to split the data into
training and test that's what we are
doing here and then you need to create
what is known as
feature columns and input functions
before you can call the api estimator
api that's what we are doing here and
data and also there is there are uh
different ways of creating the feature
columns for
numeric values and for categorical
values or rather for continuous values
and categorical values okay so that's
what has been
two types we are doing here we will see
again in the code as well
and
then you create your model so this is
basically model is equal to df.estimator
linear classifier and then you're
feeding the feature columns and also
subsequently you will call the training
by passing the input function and you
specify how many iterations to be done
for the training process and again this
is all typical machine learning process
so there is nothing specific for
tensorflow here and then you evaluate
your model because this is
classification model so you can again
take help of the scikit-learn to test
the accuracy and get the reports
evaluation perform the evaluation and
get the report like this one right so
this is the classification report and
you will see what is the question recall
f1 score and so on again this is a
standard machine learning process all
right so that's pretty much as far as
the code here is concerned once again
let me take you into our
lab and
we will get started with this particular
code now let me clear out the outputs so
that you can step by step you can see
the output so this is our data and
we will actually be this is just a
display here the code starts from here
so before when we start with our
tensorflow part of it as i mentioned we
now remember in the previous examples
the data was kind of cooked up
internally we created some data and we
were using it right the constants
variables and so on here is a real life
example so you are actually getting data
from outside so you know before we get
into tensorflow this is actually regular
python code so we are using pandas for
example to create our data frame so we
will import pandas and then we will
basically read our file into a pandas
data frame and this is how the data
looks right and if you do a head it will
give you about six
readings or observations five or six
observations and then you can take a
look at how your data is looking so for
example you have age work class
education and so on and so forth okay
and you see here this last column income
underscore bracket it says whether the
income is greater than 50k or less than
50k so this cannot be
understood or this cannot be fed into
our
model or
you know so that's the reason we need to
convert this this will not be understood
right so this needs to be converted
saying okay
maybe less than 50 k is 0 and greater
than 50 k is 1 so that conversion needs
to be done before we feed it into our
model so that's what we are going to do
as we move forward so this is the code
for doing that okay so we take this and
then
we define a function
and then we run that function so now we
have wherever it is
less than 50 k it will have 0 and
greater than 50 k it will have 1. so we
have now updated the data then the next
part is to split our data into training
and
test data set so how are we going to do
that we again will take the standard
python library which is scikit-learn sk
learn library
and
we use an existing
function there which is a train test
plate and what we are doing here is
basically splitting the data into i'm
sorry i need to run this
and then this okay sorry about that so
once i run this what is what are we
doing here again those are familiar with
circuit learn will immediately recognize
i'm splitting this into test and train
i'm saying test size is 30 percent so 30
percent of the data should go into test
and training should have 70 okay so
that's all we are doing 0.3 indicates 30
so you can again this can be individual
preferences some people do it like 50 50
some people 20 80 and in our case we are
doing uh 70 30. so training is 70 and
test is 30. okay all right so we have so
far we've been doing regular non
non-tensorflow stuff so preparing the
data so that we can now use for
tensorflow and in tensorflow what we are
doing is we will be using the api called
estimator now estimator in order to call
estimator you need to prepare what is
known as feature columns so feature
columns have to be in a certain format
basically it is nothing but the columns
we have to put them in a certain format
and then when we are calling the the
training we need to pass what is known
as an input function again a certain way
in which you need to pass that function
so that is what we need to do before we
create the model and
run the model for training so the next
few lines will be doing that quick look
at before we even get in once again into
the tensorflow code so this is just
showing us what are the various columns
names of the columns of this data okay
so that is what is shown here and uh
this is more for when i was writing the
code i could copy paste from here that's
the reason i this line of code is there
instead of typing in these values okay
good so now is where the actual
tensorflow action starts so i import
tensorflow and now i will use this
feature column functionality to create
my feature columns
and there is a certain construct how you
create the feature columns again
probably the details of that is out of
scope here but just that you need to
know that we need to create feature
columns and the way you create feature
columns
for
continuous values and for categorical
values is slightly different and that's
the reason you have two different blocks
okay so for categorical values you need
to use what is known as tf dot feature
column dot categorical column width
vocabulary list and again within this
again there are two ways in which you
can create for categorical values one is
a vocabulary list where you know
how many types are there so for example
gender column can have only male and
female so in such a case if there are
let's say a finite number of values for
a given column then you use a column
with vocabulary list okay so and then
you say what is the name of the column
and what are the possible values so in
this case male and female now there will
be situations where the the values that
this column can have
okay first of all it is a categorical
column that means it can have names or
some non-numerical values but the number
of values is probably unknown or
undefined so for example occupation now
occupation can have any value it can be
self-employed it can be a software
professional bank
a teacher doctor so so many
possibilities are there and we don't
know in the given data how many
occupations have been listed right so
that is where you use what is known as
categorical column with hash bucket and
you specify the hash bucket size so what
it what this says is there can be a
maximum of thousand such values so
typically if you give a safe number
safely large number so that you don't
run out of these number of occupations
so i think thousand is a safe number i
don't think there will be more than
thousand occupations in a given data so
that's the idea behind it but that's a
judgment call we need to take what
should be the size of this bucket size
right hash bucket size so these are two
different types for categorical values
for creating the feature column so we
will execute this for all the
categorical columns obviously you need
to know the type of the columns and that
is where if you see right at the
beginning this information was provided
what is the data type and you see here
the column name and what whether it is
continuous or categorical this
information is provided in the census
data wherever we pick this census data
from by the way this was picked from
online from a government website and we
stored locally so on that website it is
mentioned the details of this data were
mentioned and they have mentioned
whether each of these columns is
categorical or continuous so that
information we have to use and we have
to create feature columns using this
categorical
method for the categorical type of
columns and then for numeric or
continuous values you just use what is
known as feature column dot numeric
column okay so these are all continuous
or numeric values like age education
number capital gain capital loss hours
per word these are all numerical values
or continuous values right so you just
say tf.feature underscore column.numeric
underscore column and then give the name
of the column so once you do that i
think i have executed the previous one
yeah this one now so your feature
columns are ready and
you need to basically create a vector of
all these columns and we call that as
feet underscore calls which is which is
like a short form for feature columns
now as you have seen i mentioned earlier
also there are two things that are
needed one is the feature columns and
another is the input function so feature
columns to first create the model and
then to train the model you need to
create an input function so now we have
the feature columns ready next is to
create an input function and there is a
certain way in which you need to
this construct is pretty much a very
common construct so we will use that so
the input function takes these x and y
values for training and tests you
remember these are the x strain is the x
values of the training data set and y
train is the labels of the training data
set so that's what we are using here x
train y train and then we specify what
is the batch size batch size you
remember i mentioned this is what will
say how many records need to be read
each time right so typically in when we
are doing the training process we don't
get the entire data in one shot we do it
in batches so what size you specify here
number of epochs in this case we just
say none but number of epochs is again
probably the definition is not required
here but at a very high level how many
times the entire data has to be passed
through the model right so if you have
thousand records and you pass all the
thousand records three times for
training purpose then you call that as
three epochs right so there is a
difference between the batch size and
epochs so when let's say we have
thousand records and you're saying batch
size is hundred that means there will be
ten batches right so if you take ten
batches then that is one epoch gets
completed okay then you the training
obviously doesn't get completed in one
round okay so you need to pass this data
again maybe a second time or a third
time till you get the right accuracy
that is known as epochs okay again if
you need more details about this you may
have to go through the machine learning
tutorial i think it becomes much clearer
okay so you have your input function as
well let's execute that okay and now we
are ready to create the use the api
right so what will we do we will create
the linear classifier using
tf.estimator.linearclassifier
and
this guy needs feature columns right so
that's why we created we did all that so
much of
manipulations to create this feature
columns so we have feature columns so we
pass that and we create our model there
may be a few warnings don't worry about
that so we will just ignore that and now
we use that model and we actually what
we did is we created an instance of the
model we have not really run anything we
just created a instance of the model now
we will create the node for training so
model.train and this needs the input
function remember we created the input
function so we need to pass the input
function and then we say
the steps is now telling how many
iterations this training
has to be run so we are saying 5000 and
this may be it will probably take a
little long so we will okay but that's
fine i think we will leave it 5000.
sometimes if you have probably a less
powerful machine you can cut it down to
maybe thousand or something like that
but in this case i have a fairly
powerful system so i think it shouldn't
take much long
let's
go ahead and give couple of minutes for
it to get over okay so let us go back
yeah i think this is done you see here
the the hourglass has
disappeared that means this computation
is done yes okay this is done right
saving checkpoint for 5000 that means it
is done so training is done so now what
we have to do we need to do the
evaluation so
again this is a standard machine
learning method so
methodology rather so training has been
done with the training data set now you
need to evaluate using your test data
set so that's what we are doing here for
example you see here x underscore test
is your the test data set remember we
used scikit-learn to split the data into
training and test data set so x
underscore test and a quick question why
are we not using y underscore test here
like we did in case of uh training
obviously we are expecting the model to
predict the values y values right so
that's why we don't pass the y values
here all right so let's execute this for
doing the evaluation all right and then
we
put them in a proper format because the
output doesn't come out in a proper
format so we put it in a lisp format and
then we can just check yeah so this is
done and
we can check what is the first element
in this what is the probabilities and so
on so it's just
a quick way to see if the values are
there or not you can take any value here
right any element here all right now
that the testing is done what we need to
do again we will probably put them in
some kind of this is more of a
formatting thing we will just
run through quickly and then we will use
once again scikit-learn for finding out
the accuracy and so on because
scikit-learn offers what is known as a
classification report functionality so
we will use that and find out how well
our model has performed so you see here
again people with
machine learning background will be
immediately able to recognize this so it
gives us what is the precision what is
the recall
and f1 score
this is pretty much like you're getting
like almost 85 percent accuracy which is
pretty okay and
there are other ways to increase the
accuracy for example you can run the
training for more iterations that is one
way get more data and so on and so forth
or use a
this is a linear classifier we could you
have used a non-linear classifier and so
on so again multiple ways of doing it to
increase the accuracy but the idea here
was to quickly show you a piece of
tensorflow code so what is the
tensorflow object detection api this is
an open source framework which is
actually provided by the tensorflow team
and there are trained models available
and the sample code is also available
which we can use in order to easily
detect objects in images and videos this
is pretty robust and can detect objects
fairly quickly and this is very easy for
people to use as well people with very
less or no knowledge of machine learning
or deep learning can also with a little
bit of python programming knowledge can
actually use this api this library to
build object detection applications this
is a list of libraries that are required
and they have been shown in the code as
well the exact purpose of each of this
library why it is required is out of the
scope of this tutorial but we will see
in the code as we walk through some of
these libraries how and why they are
used the cocoa data set coco stands for
common objects in context so this data
set consists of 300 000 images of
90 most commonly found objects like
chairs and tables and so on and so forth
so
this model has been trained or in fact a
set of models have been trained on this
data set and this is pretty good to
detect the most common objects in the
images and videos so with that let's get
into the code all right so the first
part is to import all these libraries
and this we have shown you in the slides
as well again a large part of this will
be for doing some helper functions and
maybe for visualizing the images and so
on and so forth so that's the reason
they are required as i said the exact
details of each and every library
probably is out of scope but these are
needed so as a first step maybe you just
go ahead and include these libraries and
run the code and maybe a later point we
can discuss what each of these libraries
does now this will work with tensorflow
version higher than 1.4 so if you are
having tensorflow version below 1.4 you
may have to upgrade to a higher version
so let me go ahead and execute the cell
and
we also need this line of code to make
sure that once we
run this object detection the labeled
images are displayed within this
notebook and many of you by now must be
familiar with this and we will import a
few utility libraries and you will see
that we will be using some of these
for
visualization purpose so once the
objects are detected we need to display
the information what that object is and
then what percentage of confidence the
model has so all these details that's
the utility functions that stored here
and then the next part is to prepare the
model as i mentioned we will be using an
existing trained model
the tensorflow team has actually
provided these models the one that we
will be using is ssd with the mobile net
but you can actually use any one of the
ones that are listed in this url let me
just quickly take you through this url
these are a bunch of models trained
models that are readily available for
anybody to use it is open source and let
me scroll down the only thing is that if
there are some of them with the accuracy
is much higher but they take longer and
there are some where the accuracy is not
so high and they are much faster so they
are faster but the accuracy may not be
that very high so you can play around
with some of these and we in this
particular exercise or in this
particular tutorial we are using this
ssd model which is ssd mobile at
question one so that's the model that
we'll be using so in this cell we are
primarily creating a bunch of variables
with the various for example the name of
the model the path and so on and so
forth so that we will be using these
names in the next step which is to
download this model and install it
locally these are also referred to as a
frozen model so once they are trained
and then you kind of extract or you
freeze the model so that's the reason
they are called frozen model so that
others can just use this without any
further training so this is where we
download and extract our model locally
so this will take a little while let me
see if i can wait or maybe pause the
video and come back once it is done
might take a little while let's see if
it
completes i have a pretty high speed
network but even then it takes some time
so that's good but this part is over now
let us see this part and yes both are
done so once that is done we need to
load some label mapping basically what
this will do is your model as you may be
aware by now if you do some
classification the model will actually
not give any output
text it will give some numbers so if
there are five classes it will say okay
this belongs to modern class one or two
or three or five and so on the numbers
now each of these will obviously the
numbers will not make any sense to the
outside world so we need to do some
small mapping so in this case let's say
one may be a chair two maybe a table
three maybe a balloon and so on so that
kind of number to text mapping we need
to do and that is what is being done in
this particular cell and then we have a
helper code which will load the image
and convert it into a numpy array so
that the number array is what gets
processed and used by the model to do
the detection part of it so that is what
this
method is all about so we will be the
later on we will be calling that
function and
next is preparation for detection so
here we are basically telling where the
images are stored and how many images or
what is the naming convention or format
of the images now if you want you can
modify this code for example currently i
have test underscore images as my folder
so let me go and show this to you so
this is under my object detection folder
i have another subfolder where i am
storing my images which is text
underscore images now you can rename
this folder and give some other name and
then in your code you can probably give
that particular name for the subfold
similarly the format of these files what
is the name and format of this files
here it is in a very simple format which
is the names of the files are like beach
one beach to b3 and so on so i have
taken beach as the theme so i have
images which are related to beaches so
this is beach one beach two and then
beach three a few others but we will use
these three for our demo and so that's
what i'm saying here the name of the
images will be beach something dot jpeg
which is uh jpeg format and in this
curly braces basically we will will be
filled with either one two or three
based on in this particular for loop
okay so that is what this is doing all
right so the next step is to run
inference on these images in a loop and
what we are basically doing here is
getting these images one by one and then
running through the model to find out
what are the objects that can be
detected and then against each of the
object a box will be drawn and it will
be labeled with the name and the
percentage of accuracy or confidence
that the model detects these objects
okay so that is
the function here and so let me just run
that piece of code and here is basically
where we are calling this function so we
are loading this images and then we are
calling this function uh for each image
and then we are displaying this using
the matplotlib library so let's run this
it will take one image at a time and
then detect the images now the beauty is
that the same format of the code can be
used for doing object detection in a
video so we have another video for doing
object detection in a video so most of
the code out there will be reused from
here and the only thing is that instead
of reading the images from the local
storage we read the frames from the
video and there is a neat little video
reader that is available and it will be
shown in the other video and frame by
frame we read the video and then pass on
to this function and it will act as if
each of these frames is an image and
then it will do the same object
detection on the entire video so that's
in a separate video just uh look out for
that and actually the information about
that is provided in the cards the eye
symbol so that's the the video object
detection in video that's the separate
tutorial all right so now that we have
all the pieces together this the last
cell is where the whole action takes
place so let's run this and see how it
looks so it will take probably a little
while and there are about three images
let's see what it detects there we go so
good so the first one it has detected a
person and that too with 97 percent
accuracy which is uh i think pretty good
okay and then the next image it detects
umbrella
and chair there are a few other objects
but it's not able to detect it has
detector umbrella with 63 percent
accuracy or confidence rather and the
chair with 58 percent again not bad then
let's see the next image so here these
are actually
balloons hot air balloons but the model
thinks it is a kite which is uh probably
not that bad it sees there is something
in the sky and therefore probably it
thinks it is a kite and it detects that
with 65
confidence okay so that was pretty much
all i wanted to show you in this
particular tutorial about object
detection in images in this video i will
walk you through the tensorflow code to
perform object detection in a video so
let's get started this part is basically
we are importing all the libraries we
need a lot of these libraries for
example numpy
we need image io date time and pill and
so on and so forth and of course
matplotlib so we import all these
libraries and then there are a bunch of
variables which have some paths for the
files and folders so this is regular
stuff let's keep moving then we import
the matplotlib and make it inline and
a few more imports all right and then
these are some warnings we can just
ignore them so if i run this code once
again we could go away right and then
here onwards we do the model preparation
what we're going to do is we're going to
use an existing neural network model so
we are not going to train a new one
because that really will take a long
time and it needs a lot of computation
resources and so on and it is really not
required there are already models that
have been trained and in this case it is
the ssd with mobile net that's the model
that we are going to use and this model
is trained to detect objects and it is
readily available as open source so we
can actually use this and if you want to
use other models there are a few more
models available so you can click on
this
link here and
let me just take you there there are a
few more models but we have chosen this
particular one because this is faster it
may not be very accurate but that is one
of the faster models but on this link
you will see a lot of other models that
are readily available these are trained
models some of them would take a little
longer but they may be more accurate and
so on so you can probably play around
with these other models okay so we will
be using that model so this piece of
code this line is basically importing
that model and this is also known as
frozen model the term we use is frozen
model so we import download and import
that and then we will actually use that
model in our code all right so these two
cells
we have downloaded and import the model
and then once it is available locally we
will then load this into our program all
right so
we are loading this into memory and
the you need to perform a couple of
additional steps which is basically we
need to to map the numbers to
text as you may be aware when we
actually build the model and when we run
predictions the model will not give a
text the output of the model is usually
a number so we need to map that to a
text so for example if the network
predicts that the output is 5 we know
that 5 means it is an airplane things
like that so this mapping is done in
this next cell all right so let's keep
moving and then we have a helper code
which will basically load the data or
load the images and transform into numpy
arrays this is also used in doing object
detection in images so we are actually
going to reuse because video is nothing
but it consists of frames which in turn
are images so we are going to pretty
much use reuse the same code which we
use for doing object detection in images
so this is where the actual detection
starts so here this is the path for
where the images are stored so this is
here once again we are reusing the code
which we wrote for detecting objects in
an image so this is the path where the
images were stored and this is the
extension and this was done for about
two or three images so we will continue
to use this and
we go down i'll skip this section so
this is the cell where we are actually
loading the video and converting it into
frames and then using frame by frame we
are detecting the objects in the image
so in this code what we are doing
basically is there are a few lines of
code what they do is basically once they
find an object a box will be drawn
around those
each of those objects and the input file
the name of the input video file is
traffic it is the extension is mp4 and
we have this video reader it's a
excellent object which is basically part
of this class called image i o so we can
read and write videos using that and the
video that we are going to use is
traffic.mp4 you can use any mp4 file but
in our case i picked up video which has
like car so let me just show you so this
is in this object detection folder i
have this mp4 file i'll just quickly
play this video it's a little slow yeah
okay so here we go this is the video
it's a short one relatively small video
so that for this particular demo and
what it will do is once we run our code
it will detect each of these cars and it
will annotate them as cars so in this
particular video we only have cars we
can later on see with another video i
think i have cat here so we can also try
with that but let's first check with
this traffic video so let me go back so
we will be reading this frame by frame
and
you know actually we will be
reading the video file but then we will
be analyzing it frame by frame and we
will be reading them at 10 frames per
second that is the rate we are
mentioning here and analyzing it and
then annotating and then writing it back
so you will see that we will have a
video file named something like this
traffic underscore annotated and
we will see the annotated video so let's
go back and run through this piece of
code and then we will come back and see
the annotated uh video this might take a
little while so i will pause the video
after
running this particular cell and then
come back to show you the results all
right so let's go ahead and run it so it
is running now and it is also important
that at the end you close the video
writer so that it is similar to a file
pointer when you open a file you should
also make sure you close it so that it
doesn't hog the resources so it's very
similar at the end of it the last piece
or last line of code should be video
underscore writer dot close all right so
i'll pause and then i'll come back okay
so i will see you in a little bit all
right so now as you can see here the
processing is done the hourglass has
disappeared that means the video has
been processed so let's go back and
check the annotated video we'll go back
to my file manager so this was the
original
traffic.mp4 and now you have here
traffic underscore annotated mp4 so
let's go and run this and see how it
looks
you see here just got each of these cars
are getting detected let me pause and
show you so we pause here it says car 70
let us allow it to go a little further
it detects something on top what is that
truck okay so i think because of the
board on top it somehow thinks there is
a truck let's play it some more and see
if it detects anything else so this is
again a car looks like so let us yeah so
this is a car and
it has confidence level of 69 percent
okay this is again a car all right so
basically till the end it goes and
detects each and every car that is
passing by now we can quickly repeat
this process for another video let me
just show you the other video which is a
cat again there is uh this cat is not
really moving or anything but it is just
standing there staring and moving a
little slowly and
our application will our network will
detect that this is a cat and
even when the cat moves a little bit in
the other direction it will continue to
detect and show that it is a cat okay so
yeah so this is how the original video
is let's go ahead and change our code to
analyze this one and see if it detects
our network detects this cat close this
here we go and i'll go back to my code
all we need to do is change this traffic
to
cat the extension it will automatically
pick up because it is given here and
then it will run through so very quickly
once again what it is doing is this
video reader video underscore reader has
a neat little feature or interface
whereby you can say for frame in video
underscore reader so it will basically
provide frame by frame so you're in a
loop frame by frame and then you take
that each frame that is given to you you
take it and analyze it as if it is an
image individual image so that's the way
it works so it is very easy to handle
this all right so now let's once again
run just this cell the rest of the stuff
remains the same so i will run this cell
again it will take a little while so the
r classes come back i will pause and
then come back in a little while all
right so the processing is done let's go
and check the annotated video go here so
we have get annotated dot mp4 let's play
this all right so you can see here it is
detecting the cat and in the beginning
you also saw it detected something else
here there looks like it detected one
more object so let's just go back and
see what it has detected here
let's see yes so
what is it trying to show here it's too
small not able to see but it is trying
to detect something i think it is saying
it is a car i don't know
all right okay so in this video there's
only pretty much only one object which
is the cat and
let's wait for some time and see if it
continues to detect it when the cat
turns around and moves as well just
in a little bit that's going to happen
and we will see there we go and in spite
of turning the other way i think our
network is able to detect that it is a
cat so let me freeze and then show here
it is actually still continues to detect
it as a cat all right so that's pretty
much it i think that's the only object
that it detects in this particular video
okay so close this so that's pretty much
it thank you very much for watching this
video welcome to simply learns deep
learning frameworks my name is richard
kirschner with the simply learn team
that's www
get certified get ahead let's cover some
of the big players in deep learning
today and deep learning is just so
exciting this is the forefront of our
machine learning and artificial
intelligence and where it's at as far as
the cutting edge and what's coming next
that doesn't mean ignore all the machine
learning tools because certainly they've
been around a long time and are a basis
for a lot of deep learning platforms
along with solving the more basic
problems but deep learning is the
cutting edge it is the one that's
finding new solutions to things we never
thought were solvable before and today
we're going to look at uh just a quick
look at tensorflow probably the biggest
package out there right now keras which
is probably one of the biggest growing
packages are there right now pie torch
theano dl4j cafe chainer and the cntk
now all these packages center on deep
learning and neural networks if you
haven't studied our neural networks and
how they function send a note down below
in the youtube video and we'll post some
more information on one of our other
videos just so you have an idea what
deep learning is but let's go ahead and
dive in let's take a look at tensorflow
and as we look at these things i want
you also to notice that a lot of this
overlaps you'll see companies are
investing in all of these different
products to see where they go so these
are all huge players no matter where
you're coming from so let's look at
tensorflow tensorflow was developed by
google brain team it supports languages
both python and r that's a big you'll
see python is probably one of the
biggest players in the data science
neural networks across all the packages
and it doesn't discount in the other
ones certainly a lot of these packages
like tensorflow you can set up an
interface into java and other places but
it was designed and has a very high
functionality in both python and r and
it uses data flow graphs to process data
this is nice because as you build these
neural networks you can actually look at
how the data flows through the neural
network they're easy to build machine
learning models robust machine learning
production powerful experimentation for
research i can't even emphasize that
enough it's very easy to go in there and
switch a couple lines in your tensorflow
setup to try out a new setup a new
neural network to see how it works with
your data going through and if it gives
you better results tensorboard for data
visualization and this is another huge
package that people kind of forget as
part of tensorflow put out by google
brain team and tensorflow is now open
source the tensorflow data visualization
is makes it so quick and easy to put out
your data for visual effects uh when
you're working with your ceo or with
your shareholders and of course you can
use both the r and python visualization
packages too since you're usually
running it in python or r let's go ahead
and talk about cross we mentioned
overlapping earlier cross is probably
the most overlapping package out there
and i'll show you why in just a minute
let's start with the creator of cross or
the founder now cross was originally
developed by francois chole he's the
author of cross and it has over 350 000
users and 700 plus open source
contributors that's big across is
tensorflow might be the biggest or well
most well-known package out there cross
because it overlaps so many other areas
and it's such a high-end development it
is probably the fastest growing package
out there right now and it's got a
high-level neural network api written in
python
so for all us python lovers and data
science a great package to go from there
what makes it interesting is that it
runs on top of tensorflow theano cntk so
it uses their neural networks underneath
and then you use your definition in
cross to define all these packages so
now if you're running tensorflow and you
put cross on top of it you have both the
benefits of cross and all the tools in
tensorflow this is why cross is the
fastest growing neural network or deep
learning package out there and it's used
in several startup research labs and
companies microsoft research you'll see
microsoft has invested in all of these
now so any place you have any of these
coming out microsoft is part of it of
course microsoft with the cntk is their
package and they're highly invested in
that netflix nasa cern are all using
keras for using their data processing
and their deep learning it's user
friendly as it offers simple apis and
provides clear and actionable feedback
upon user error provides modularity as a
sequence of a graph of standalone fully
configurable modules that can be plugged
together with as few restrictions as
possible these two things makes it so
easy to write a cross code a lot of
times you might be messing with
tensorflow and you turn around you can
do the same cross code in a few lines or
let you know significantly less than
you'd write the same code in tensorflow
so you could use cross on top of
tensorflow and cross it's easily
extensible as a new modules are simple
to add this feature makes cross suitable
for advanced research so from cross
we're going to go into pi torch and it's
authored by adam pasquay sam gross
sumith cantala and gregory shannon lua
based scientific computing framework for
machine learning and deep learning
algorithms so this is coming from the
scientific teams they took and there can
guess it's uh pi so it's in python but
it's based on the scientific computing
and so they're looking at answers for
science uh and it employed cuda along
with cc plus libraries for processing
was designed to scale the product of
building models and overall flexibility
if you're a c c plus plus
programmer and that's your programmer
programming of choice you can see why pi
torch might be really
big jump for you because you know the
back end and you can get in there and
see what's going on with that particular
framework and it's widely used in
companies like facebook twitter google
and you find this interesting because
google like i said you'll see microsoft
and google has their hands in all of
these and i'm guessing that facebook and
twitter have probably investigated the
best use
and use these different frameworks
depending on what they're working on so
it provides a flexibility and speed due
to its hybrid front end enable scalable
distributed training and performance
optimization in research and production
using torch.distributed backend deep
integration into python allows popular
libraries and packages to be used for
clear writing neural network layers in
python so remember it's got that dual
layer so if you're running in c plus or
c great language and you can skip over
to python then there's theano and i had
to look this up how to pronounce it even
though i played with it i've only read
the word i've never heard someone say it
i finally went in there and looked it up
it is theano there's a lot of
pronunciations theno and different
things uh so theano uh it's developed by
the university de montreal and it's
written in python and it really centers
on nvidia and uh so you have your
integration there to your gps's which is
huge you'll see the gps modules like in
tensorflow there's a gps module in there
and in cross obviously since it sits on
tensorflow most of these that's where
they're going is the gps can process so
much faster than a cpu so the python
library that allows to define optimize
and evaluate mathematical expressions
involving multi-dimensional arrays
efficiently so when we look at this we
have numpy theano has a tight
integration with numpy for data
computations so if you're a major python
lover and you love the numpy which is uh
you know the number python such as
central aspect of python and data
science uh numpy's the way to go and
then he uses the gpus to perform data
intensive computations which are much
faster than on a cpu and it has
extensive unit testing and
self-verification that can detect and
diagnose many types of errors so seattle
is a pretty solid package
and the fact is written in python and is
designed pretty solid on the gpu makes
it a very big contender in our deep
learning array of uh platforms out there
and then we have deep learning for java
or the dl for they usually call it dl4j
deep learning for java was developed by
a machine learning group led by adam
gibson a wonderful group i got to meet
them they're a lot of fun it's written
in java and scala and that is big if you
are working in big data and the hadoop
and the spark framework those who jump
out at you right off the bat so we have
our dl4j supports different neural
you'll see cnn lstm a convolutional
neural network with a long short term
memory it's connected to the eclipse
foundation so the dl4j was contributed
to eclipse foundation integrated with
hadoop and apache spark i talked about
that earlier since scala
spark is written in scala so we're
talking about big data and big data
processing that's a big name to have on
there and the fact that a lot of
hadoop your mapreduce is based in java
you can see the connection for the
dl4j in big data and so dl4j brings ai
to business environments for use to
distributed cpus and gpus and right
there distributed cpus and gpus so this
can be run across a huge cluster of
computers quite easily it's designed for
that so if you're working in spark and
you have a hundred computers set up on
different racks this would be a really
solid roll it out the
doorway set up for you so he provides a
distributed computing framework as
training with dl4j occurs in a cluster
as we were talking about cluster
computations includes an n-dimensional
array class using nd4j that allows
scientific computing in java and scala
offers a vector space modeling and topic
modeling toolkit that is designed to
handle large text sets and perform in lp
natural language processing so we looked
at dl4j let's take a look at the cafe
developed at bear that's berkeley
artificial intelligence research so
berkeley's at it again cafe stands for
convolutional architecture for fast
feature embedding it's written in c plus
plus within python interface so again we
have another contender for people who
work in the c plus plus realm and want
to be able to go back and forth between
that and python generally used for image
detection and classification used in
academic research projects which makes
sense this is coming out of berkeley
start-up prototypes and large-scale
industrial applications in vision speech
and multimedia and really when you see
vision speech and multimedia all of
these deep learning are addressing these
particular aspects and more
so it's not a big jump when you talk
about vision there is a little bit there
as far as which ones handle the vision
better because then you're doing
different matrixes you know you have a
xy plot coming in and that's a big deal
that's you'll see that in tensorflow
especially caffe supports gpu and
cpu-based acceleration computational
kernel libraries such as nvidia cudn and
intel mlk so it's integrated a little
bit more on the multiprocessor and the
gpu setups in there we're seeing that
all come together most of the packages
now well nvidia is almost in all of
these as far as a gpu acceleration but
we're starting to see the other ones
migrate in there it offers a high speed
can process over 60 million images per
day with a single nvidia k40 gpu that's
huge 60 million images per day uh so
when you're training this thing and you
spend a lot of time training and i mean
that's just huge that's amazing so let's
take a look at chainer uh chainer is one
of those that kind of
i don't hear a lot about but is still a
contender in our setup in here it is
developed by preferred networks in
collaboration with ibm intel microsoft
and nvidia and there we see nvidia again
they've got their hands and everything
and so does intel microsoft and ibm
that's what puts this at one of the top
contenders it has such a huge backing in
the industrial world it's written purely
in python it runs on top of numpy and cu
pi python libraries so that's
straightforward if you're uh like i said
most of stuff in our machine learning is
heading towards the python environment
because it's so flexible it's currently
one of the top used setups in there and
the chain is written right on top of it
in python and it provides a number of
extended libraries we have the chainrim
in and the chain or rl and the chain or
cv and you'll find in deep learning
these little abbreviations are so many
unless you're working with a specific
setup and you're running it i wouldn't
worry too much about memorizing all of
them maybe get your flash cards out uh
but we have chain or mn which is
multiple
nodes rl which is your reinforced
learning and cv
which is your computer vision library uh
so your images and so when you're
working with with chainer you definitely
want to know what those mean and as you
dig in deeper into it uh but these are
they have tons of extended libraries
these are a few of the libraries they
have these are the top ones that are
used so it supports cuda computation it
only requires a few lines of code to
leverage a gpu there's our gpu which
we're seeing across the board on all of
our different neural networks and how
the how they apply that is important
because some of them do a better job
than others it also runs on multiple
gpus with little effort so just by its
name chainer is designed to send it out
there to the different aspects and bring
them back together that's what makes
this one of the reasons chainer is being
developed so it provides various network
architectures including feed forward
nets conv nets recurrent nets and
recursive nets and again now we're
starting to dig in deep into
the neural networks in deep learning as
opposed to the different main players
and most of these cover different
aspects of these you have to really dig
deep to see where these go but chainer
is coming up and it's got some heavy
hitters backing it it has
like i said ibm intel microsoft and
nvidia are part of the development team
there and we're getting down to the end
here we have our microsoft cntk
developed by microsoft research and the
cntk is a deep learning framework that
builds a neural network as a series of
computational steps via directed graph
it supports interfaces such as python
and c plus so again now we have one of
the nice things about this is you'll see
it's it's the interfaces are really
spread out so those are the two main
players with python being the more
commonly used one but we're starting to
see c plus coming in there's a lot of
programmers out there who use c plus
plus and it's used mainly for our
handwritten and you can see some
examples here for what it's used mainly
for so it's designed for speed and
efficiency and that's always that's a
big thing because neural networks just
eat up so much processing power for all
the calculations it takes to program
them so it's designed for speed and
efficiency cntk scales well in
production using gpus but has limited
support from the community so again we
have the big hitters behind it microsoft
research but does not have a huge
community support yet it supposed both
rnn and cnn type of neural models
capable of handling image a nice picture
of the guy writing their handwriting and
speech recognition problems so let's
take a look at implementation in
tensorflow and we're going to build a
neural network to identify handwritten
digits using the
mnist database or the mnist database and
that stands for modified national
institute of standards and technology
database it is a collection of 70 000
handwritten digits and the digit labels
identify each of the digits from 0 to 9.
this is a cool example because it's
simple enough that you could actually
run this through some basic machine
learning categorizing algorithms and
train them and you'll get about the same
answer because again it's simple grid
the digits on the grid don't have a huge
amount of variation like you would say
an automated driving car looking at the
environment so you can still do this
with a lot of your
different linear models and stuff like
that you can solve this and you'll get
about the same answer when i ran a
comparison between tensorflow and
between some basic uh regression models
or category models in machine learning
they came up pretty even as far as their
output uh so this is kind of where we
start to see the complexity of something
coming in in this case a tensor you know
or a grid of information where the deep
learning model does as good as the
regular models and when you get past
this kind of complexity and features
suddenly the neural networks come up
with better answers better solutions and
a better build and that's why there's
such a move into neural networks is we
live in a complicated world and it's
just really cool we can do with this so
the handwritten digits from the nist
database they come in the data set is
used to train the machine a new image of
a digit is fed and the digit is
identified and if you've looked at any
of our other machine learning tools
where we're doing training where we
train our model to fit and then you test
it out this will look pretty familiar
and there is some tools out there for
say untrained categorizing where it's
just looking for features that fit
together so there are tools that don't
need that training but this is where we
talk about neural networks we do need to
train them and this is what we're
looking at for this i'm going to use the
anaconda navigator just because it's a
very nice visual tool you might be in
pycharm or one of your other ides for
editing python because we are looking at
python tensorflow and under anaconda we
have the notebook which is something we
use pretty regularly and they have the
jupiter lab the jupiter lab is the
jupiter notebook but with tabs and a few
new features so we'll be using the
jupiter lab today and under the
environment you'll want to go ahead and
and if you haven't yet you'll see that i
have a number of different setups in
here right now i have the python version
3 6 and the tensorflow in this case i
have tensorflow 1.12 if we scroll down
you can see that here we go tensorflow
and it's version 1.12 and in here if you
haven't yet you'll need to install those
and go in and just open our terminal and
if you've never used the anaconda or if
you're in your other thing you might
have something simple like pip conda is
what i use for my install and you can
simply do conda install tensorflow that
should bring in the most current version
now when i installed this a few months
ago python version i'm not going to run
this because i already have installed on
here python version 3.7 the newest one
out still had a couple glitches with the
tensorflow i believe they fixed it as of
writing of this but i'm going to stick
with 3 6 just so i don't get any
surprises on there so this is python
version 36 with tensorflow 1.12 on here
and if you haven't installed it yet you
also want to install numpy for this
example that's numbers python or
n-u-m-p-y
you just simply run an install on there
keep in mind if you're in anaconda and
you've created one of these environments
specific to this keep with conda if
you're going to use conda if you're
going to use pip keep with pip don't
install one package with pip and one
under conda because that's how they
track those version numbers and how they
fit together and you can end up with a
problem they don't pip doesn't see conda
and vice versa so just keep that in mind
when you're running your installs we'll
go ahead and open up jupiter lab we're
going to launch that so here's my
jupiter lab one of the really cool
features of jupiter lab is you have tabs
now so you can open up multiple uh
notebooks this is nice because i have my
notes i'm working on and then our actual
window we're looking in and we'll go
ahead and zoom in a little bit here
there we go so you have a nice hopefully
easy to see fonts and then we'll go
ahead and do a simple or get our imports
out of the way and so we're going to
import our tensorflow as tf that's
pretty much a standard for tensorflow
numpy our numbers python as py and we'll
import our matte plot library as plt
again these are very common so if you
see tf or py or plt this is a standard
that most people use do you have to no
you could just do import numpy instead
of doing as py and then from
tensorflow.examples.tutorials this is
always nice because they actually
include data set we're going to play
with so we're going to import input data
so there's our data coming in that's all
we're doing is telling it this is where
it's coming from and if we can tell
where it's coming from we need to go
ahead and create a variable with that
information in it and we'll just call
this mnist nist or minst you know i
don't really know how they pronounce
that i should probably look that up it's
a very common data set to use and
there's our input data and we're going
to read
data sets and this is if you look at
this we imported input data from our
tensorflow and so this is a tensorflow
read statement for their tutorials so
this isn't like some special python
setup this is just their setup makes it
easy to pull it in so once we get into
their data sets we need to go and tell
what kind of data set and again this is
what we brought in but it's going to be
the ninth data and this part is very
important one
hot equals true this means that instead
of importing a value from zero to nine
we evaluate the data set it's going to
bring it in as one hot whenever we see
one hot encoder we're flattening that
out and we have true false for zero true
false for one true false for two so our
output if you remember from our output
from the slide we did earlier in this
case i grabbed the one for bike price
doesn't really matter which one we use
this has one output so we have our bike
price on this we're going to have
instead of one output we're going to
have 10 outputs representing each of the
digits in there and this code really
isn't going to show us anything it's
good to see what we're actually looking
at so let's go ahead and do a figure ax
equals go into our plot library subplots
10 comma 10. and that is if you remember
we talked about tensor tensor being data
coming in this is a 10 by 10 grid or 100
pixels on there and if we're going to
display it let's go do k
0 for i in range 10 just a simple loop
through on the data let's do what is it
for j in range 10 so i actually
misquoted that 10
10 by 10 is not the actual size of the
pixels the actual pixels are going to be
um we look at the shapes and we'll get
into that in just a second here we'll
take a quick look at the shape on there
uh turns out they're
what are they are i believe 28 by 28. uh
so let's take a look at that and we're
just going to plot these what are we
looking at what are we working with as a
data scientist you should always be
looking back at your data and seeing
what it looks like and get that human
perspective because you just never know
you know the the computer might put
something out that looks makes no sense
and at that point you want to go back
and reevaluate what you did so we're
going to go ahead and plot we're going
to plot 10 digit you know 10 of the
digits by 10 of the digits and here's
our ax we'll create the ij on our
subplots and we're going to do an image
show we're going to look at the training
image for images of k and then we want
to reshape this we're going to reshape
this and we're going to reshape this 28
by 28. that's how i knew i had it wrong
is because i looked down my notes it's
like oh no that says 28 it's not 10 by
10. and i should know that already
because i've done enough messing with
this data set that i should remember but
it's 28 by 28 and the aspect we're going
to do is auto and this is all if you
look at this here's our variable nist
the nist is coming from data set so this
is all part of the tf tensorflow
learning or examples tutorial in there
and then we'll go ahead and do k
plus equals one so we just keep paging
through our different
images and let's see what that looks
like let's go ahead and do a plot
show and we'll go ahead and run this so
we can take a look and see what we have
here and so we have a nice plot here and
you can just see that we have uh some
random numbers showing up in each one
these little subplots if you're wanting
a copy of this code put a note down in
the youtube video and let us know or
come visit us at
www.simplylearn.com and we'll send you
out a copy of what we're working on and
get a copy of that for your own setup uh
so now we've taken a look we can just
see we have here's our pictures that are
coming on we plotted them so we have an
idea of what we're looking at let's go
ahead and print let's look at the shape
of the features uh so when we have this
we have our nist train
images and we'll do the shape on there
let's take a look and just see what
we're looking at
as far as
our count and everything and so you can
see here we have 55 000 that's basically
how many images we have and this by 784
and in this data set there's also our
labels so let's take a look at that we
have our next train labels shape let's
take a look and see what that looks like
uh and there we have 10 because there's
10 digits so we brought in that's our
output we're looking at and so we have
there we go 55 000 they match they
should match because you should have
equal numbers in both of those you know
here's our data in and here's our answer
if you remember this is a bunch of zeros
and with one each each one will be zero
zero zero one would be what letter four
or something like that so let's take a
look at what our one hot encoding did
for the first observation and this is
when we're exploring data you really
want to dig in there and just see what
the heck am i looking at so we're going
to look at the labels and this would be
the first label that comes up and we'll
go ahead and run this and we look at
that you can see this is what i'm
talking about 0 0
is zero two is zero three is zero four
is zero five is zero six is zero seven
equals one so our very first label is a
seven but a very first label comes up
that it's a seven and so we don't have
like zero through nine we have a bunch
of zeros and just the one to mark it as
a seven on here so now we've kind of
looked a quick look at the data and in
here you might ask some questions like
what is 784 24 times 24. remember that's
the size of our grid on there or our
tents are coming in so 784 is a setup on
there and we've gone through all this
viewing the data we'll go ahead and
start looking at our tensorflow so let's
take our x variable this is going to be
our training set we'll do a placeholder
and then we're going to have these come
in as float now if i remember correctly
they're actually you know zero or one
for the values because they're either
but we have them coming in as a float
value and we have a little bit of a
shape coming in here and there's our 784
uh so we let it know that this is what's
what our input is for our tensorflow and
this is our training set so we'll just
put a label on there to help us track
that train set and then w and with w
we'll go ahead and do tf variables and
we'll do this as
zeros variables to have zeros and we'll
set this as
784 by 10 10 being the output 784 being
our number of variables in and this is
our weights remember we have a bias in
there too
and i'll go back over this in just a
second as we see how that fits together
in our tensorflow and we'll do this one
with our variables again we have 10 so
we're going to do the bias we do the
same kind of format and setup on here
and so we'll do that as as tf zeros of
10. so we'll just create an array of 10
there and this is our bias so with these
three lines
and there's actually they're coming out
with the eager execution which would
bypass some of what we're doing but this
is important to understand is the first
thing you have to do with tensorflow is
we have to allocate a space for the
variables in our tf placeholder and our
tf variable with our weights and our
biases this actually hasn't done
anything yet so all it is is
placeholders that's why it's okay to use
zeros you could have just as easily used
ones or anything else and it wouldn't
matter the next stage is to go ahead and
set up some of the functions going on
but before we do that just note that
this hasn't done anything even if i
execute it all it's done is created
placeholders until we do the final
initialization and so we need to go
ahead and set up we'll do y equals
tf.nn.softmax
and the code for this is tf.mat mole xw
plus b and this is our
sum let's just put a note here so we can
keep track of what's going on we're
finding weighted sum of inputs plus the
bias so there's our plus b the bias and
then we need to go ahead keep um let's
do y underscore and again another
placeholder and this one will set up
it's actually we'll put in as tf
placeholder on here tf placeholder float
nun 10. there's our one hot encoder
going on there so our 10 values coming
out and we'll do a cross
entropy on here and this is going to be
minus tf reduce
sum and we'll do y here's our y
underscore which is remember we have
your y output and your actual output uh
so this will be our y underscore times
the t f log of y and then finally
before we do the actual initialization
of all our variables we'll set up our
train step this equals our gradient
descent optimizer very important
remember we looked at that chart on our
slides and so we've set up all these
formulas and here's our gradient descent
optimizer and as it keeps looking it
keeps looking for that zero value that's
what we're doing with that particular
formula so let's take a look and see
what we're doing here we just put
together all of our pieces for
tensorflow and you know the devil's in
the details we have here our training
set coming in we have to put a
placeholder on there we have our
variables with our weights we have our
biases coming out and then we put in our
the weighted sum so here's uh summizing
our summation here then we have our y
variable output so there's our y um how
it works and then of course the actual
output on there and then we have our
cross entropy coming in and that's our
minus tf dot reduced sum the y times the
tf log of y and then the training step
gradient descent optimizer and we're
using a 0.01 in this and we're going to
minimize cross entropy so we're going to
let it do all the work so once we've set
up all of these different layers we've
allocated for them we need to go ahead
and initialize them so we're going to do
an init tf initialize and it's going to
be all variables one of the cool things
is they're in the process of doing away
with this so all these steps would be
bundled into one instead of having to
add placeholders you initialize them in
the same process going on and then
finally everything in tensorflow is
based on your session now this is
changing that there's other options to
be able to run this but we want to go
ahead and do a session there's our tf
which is a tf session and then we want
to go ahead and do session run and what
are we going to run well we did
initialization of all our variables uh
so this is what we're running and this
is where actually once we do this we
actually create our tensorflow object so
this whole piece of code right here is
our tensorflow object we have our input
coming in with our weighted variables
coming in our soft max for our metamode
going out how does it added together for
our y value and then we have the actual
float value coming out checking on our
all the way down so you can see all the
different stages going through that
we're setting up and this is one of the
reasons that a lot of people like
tensorflow is because you can designate
all these different pieces one step at a
time this is also one of the reasons
people don't like tensorflow is because
you have to designate all the different
layers coming down and there's a lot of
steps being made right now to minimize
this to make it either easier to
automate it or to allow you to do more
complicated things and all those steps
are still at play so it's worth looking
into the more advanced version what's
going on with cross on top of tensorflow
it's also important to understand what's
going on in these individual levels if
you're going to play with them it's
important to understand hey what's going
on with the uh finding the weighted sum
of the inputs plus the bias because
there's other ways to do that there's
all kinds of other tools in there now
but this is the basic setup that you
want to do on a tensorflow coming in and
we want to go ahead and just run and
init our tensorflow so let's go ahead
and do that let's run this we do get a
warning here because there's a move to
use global variables this is one of the
changes they're making but as far as
this example is not going to make a
difference because we're doing once we
initialize it this is initializing our
variables and again these are only
placeholders up here until we initialize
them and i would highly suggest put a
note down there or go over to
simplylearn.com and let them know and
have them email you a copy of the code
so you can actually play with this code
right here because this is the body of
what's going on in tensorflow this is
the build in neural networks and then
once we've done that now comes kind of
the fun part is we need to go ahead and
train it so we've created our tensorflow
we've created our network and now we
need to go ahead and train it uh so
let's put together that training code
and let's just do uh for i and range uh
1000 0 to 1 000. so we're just going to
look at the first 1000 in our training
and the way we pull that data from our
mints train next batch of 100 uh so you
look at this we're going to be doing
groups of 100 and then there's going to
go through a thousand of them this is
very important that tensorflow builds
this in this is one of the downsides of
doing sklearn or one of the older
packages is they don't let you batch
groups in they wanted to have it all up
front and then you have to build your
own batch programs right now this lets
us go ahead and do that and you can see
here we have batch x of s batch y of s
and so there's our x and our y you can
look at this as our training of x and
our train of y or the data in and the
answer in uh and then we simply do our
session run uh so here's our session
that we've created we're going to run it
and we want to do the train step where
we initialized our train step up here in
our tf and so there's our train step
feed it's a dictionary dictionary coming
in which we're going to create right
here is x is our batch x of our sample
comma and our y underscore is going to
be our batch of our y sample uh and so
this goes through and we've now hit the
run button and we've trained our session
we've trained this setup on here and
once we've trained it then we need to go
ahead and find out how good our accuracy
was and actually start running some
predictions through there so we'll go
ahead and create a correct prediction
when this is where our tf dot equal
we'll use our arg max y of 1 and t of
argmax of y of underscore of one to help
us get the correct predictions on there
and then we want to use that to feed
into an accuracy and so our accuracy is
going to be tf reduce
mean and we'll take that and we'll do a
cast and this is the correct prediction
that we're sending in there and it is a
float value keep it simple and let's go
ahead and print this out so we can see
what we're looking at so what are we
printing out uh we need to do a session
run this session runs going to be on the
accuracy where did accuracy comes from
this is our we're casting our tf on
there with the correct predictions on
that so here's our accuracy feed in so
it needs a dictionary for the data
coming in we're going to create our
dictionary and x is going to be our nist
test images and y underscore there is
going to be our nist dot test labels let
me just double check and make sure i
have that typed in there correctly there
we go and let's go ahead and run that
and see what comes up and we end up with
a 0.9165
for our accuracy which means our trained
neural network does a pretty good job
letting us know what these different
symbols are i'm guessing that a 7 and a
three and a four uh something that as
humans we kind of take for granted i
even have trouble reading this so i
don't know if i would be able like that
first one i would sit there for a long
time figuring out that's a seven versus
a two that could have easily been a two
to me so you can see we do a pretty good
job analyzing this data and this is used
to analyze something very complicated on
these images very different than uh just
a straight value of uh cost of sales and
here's our return and our marketing we
can now create this nice neural network
that does all kinds of cool things today
we're going to be covering the
convolutional neural network tutorial
do you know how deep learning recognizes
the objects in an image and really this
particular neural network is how image
recognition works it's very central one
of the biggest building blocks for image
recognition it does it using convolution
neural network and we over here we have
the basic picture of a hummingbird
pixels of an image fed as input you have
your input layer coming in so it takes
that graphic and puts it into the input
layer you have all your hidden layers
and then you have your output layer and
your output layer one of those is going
to light up and say oh it's a bird we're
going to go into depth we're going to
actually go back and forth on this a
number of times today so if you're not
catching all the image don't worry we're
going to get into the details so we have
our input layer accepts the pixels of
the image as input in the form of arrays
and you can see up here where they've
actually labeled each block of the bird
in different arrays so we'll dive into
deep as to how that looks like and how
those matrixes are set up your hidden
layer carry out feature extraction by
performing certain calculations and
manipulation so this is the part that
kind of reorganizes that picture
multiple ways until we get some data
that's easy to read for the neural
network this layer uses a matrix filter
and performs convolution operation to
detect patterns in the image and if you
remember that convolution means to coil
or to twist so we're going to twist the
data around and alter it and use that
operation to detect a new pattern there
are multiple hidden layers like
convolution layer rel u is how that is
pronounced when that's the rectified
linear unit that has to do with the
activation function that's used
pooling layer also uses multiple filters
to detect edges corners eyes feathers
beak etc and just like the term says
pooling is pooling information together
and we'll look into that a lot closer
here so if you're if it's a little
confusing now we'll dig in deep and try
to get you squared away with that and
then finally there is a fully connected
layer that identifies the object in the
image so we have these different layers
coming through in the hidden layers and
they come into the final area and that's
where we have a one node or one neural
network entity that lights up that says
it's a bird
what's in it for you we're going to
cover an introduction to the cnn what is
convolution neural network how cnn
recognizes images we're going to dig
deeper into that and really look at the
individual layers in the convolutional
neural network and finally we do a use
case implementation using the cnn we'll
begin our introduction to the cnn by
introducing the pioneer of convolutional
neural network jan le he was the
director of facebook ai research group
built the first convolutional neural
network called lynette in 1988 so these
have been around for a while and have
had a chance to mature over the years it
was used for character recognition tasks
like reading zip code digits imagine
processing mail and automating that
process
cnn is a feed forward neural network
that is generally used to analyze visual
images by producing data with a
grid-like topology a cnn is also known
as a convent and very key to this is we
are looking at images that was what this
was designed for and you'll see the
different layers as we dig in near some
of the other some of them are actually
now used since we're using uh tensorflow
and cross in our code later on you'll
see that some of those layers appear in
a lot of your other neural network
frameworks but in this case this is very
central to processing images and doing
so in a variety that captures multiple
images and really drills down into their
different features in this example here
you see flowers are two varieties orchid
and a rose i think the orchid is much
more dainty and beautiful and the rose
smells quite beautiful of a couple rose
bushes in my yard they go into the input
layer that data is in sent to all the
different nodes in the next layer one of
the hidden layers based on its different
weights and its setup it then comes out
and gives those a new value those values
then are multiplied by their weights and
go to the next hidden layer and so on
and then you have the output layer and
one of those notes comes out and says
it's an orchid and the other one comes
out and says it's a rose depending on
how it was well it was trained what
separates the cnn or the convolutional
neural network from other neural
networks is a convolutional operation
forms the basis of any convolutional
neural network in a cnn every m image is
represented in the form of arrays of
pixel values so here we have a real
image of the digit eight
that then gets put on to its pixel
values represented in the form of an
array in this case you have a two
dimensional array and then you can see
in the final in form we transform the
digit eight into its representational
form of pixels of zeros and one where
the ones represent in this case the
black part of the eight and the zeros
represent the white background to
understand the convolution neural
network or how that convolutional
operation works we're going to take a
side step and look at matrixes in this
case we're going to simplify it and
we're going to take two matrices a and b
of one dimension now kind of separate
this from your thinking as we learned
that you want to focus just on the
matrix aspect of this and then we'll
bring that back together and see what
that looks like when we put the pieces
for the convolutional operation here
we've set up two arrays we have in this
case are a single dimension matrix and
we have a equals five three seven five
nine seven and we have b equals one two
three so in the convolution as it comes
in there's gonna look at these two and
we're gonna start by doing multiplying
them a times b and so we multiply the
arrays element wise and we get five six
six
where five is the five times one six is
three times two and then the other six
is two times three and since the two
arrays aren't the same
size they're not the same setup we're
gonna just truncate the first one and
we're gonna look at the second array
multiplied just by the first three
elements of the first array now that's
gonna be a little confusing remember a
computer gets to repeat these processes
hundreds of times so we're not going to
just forget those other numbers later on
we'll see we'll bring those back in and
then we have the sum of the product in
this case 5 plus 6 plus 6 equals 17. so
in our a times b
our very first digit in that matrix of a
times b is 17. and if you remember i
said we're not going to forget the other
digits so we now have 3 2 5 we move one
set over and we take 3 2 5 and we
multiply that times b and you'll see
that 3 times 1 is 3 2 times 2 is 4 and
so on and so on we sum it up so now we
have the second digit of our a times b
product in the matrix and we continue on
with that same thing so on and so on so
then we would go from
seven five to seven five nine to five
nine seven this short matrix that we
have for a we've now covered all the
different entities in a that match three
different levels of b now in a little
bit we're going to cover where we use
this math at this multiplying of
matrixes and how that works but it's
important to understand that we're going
through the matrix and multiplying the
different parts to it to match the
smaller matrix with the larger matrix i
know a lot of people get lost at is you
know what's going on here with these
matrixes uh oh scary math not really
that scary when you break it down we're
looking at a section of a and we're
comparing it to b so when you break that
down your mind like that you realize
okay so i'm just taking these two
matrixes and comparing them and i'm
bringing the value down into one matrix
a times b we're reducing that
information in a way that will help the
computer see different aspects let's go
ahead and flip over again back to our
images here we are back to our images
talking about going to the most basic
two-dimensional image you can get to
consider the following two images the
image for the symbol backslash when you
press the backslash the above image is
processed you can see there for the
image for the forward slash is the
opposite so we click the forward slash
button that flips uh very basic we have
four pixels going in can't get any more
basic than that here we have a little
bit more complicated picture we take a
real image of a smiley face
then we represent that in the form of
black and white pixels so if this was an
image in the computer it's black and
white and like we saw before we convert
this into the zeros and one so where the
other one would have just been a matrix
of just four dots now we have a
significantly larger image coming in so
don't worry we're going to bring this
all together here in just a little bit
layers in convolutional neural network
we're looking at this we have our
convolution layer and that really is the
central aspect of processing images in
the convolutional neural network that's
why we have it and then that's going to
be feeding in and you have your relu
layer which is you know as we talked
about the rectified linear unit we'll
talk about that a little bit later the
relu isn't how it act is how that layer
is activated is the math behind it what
makes the neurons fire you'll see that
in a lot of other neural networks when
you're using it just by itself it's for
processing smaller amounts of data where
you use the atom activation feature for
large data coming in now because we're
processing small amounts of data in each
image the relu layer works great you
have your pooling layer that's where
you're pulling the data together pooling
is a neural network term it's very
commonly used i like to use the term
reduce so if you're coming from the map
and reduce side you'll see that we're
mapping all this data through all these
networks and then we're going to reduce
it we're going to pull it together and
then finally we have the fully connected
layer that's where our output is going
to come out so we have started to look
at matrixes we've started to look at the
convolutional layer where it fits in and
everything we've taken a look at images
so we're going to focus more on the
convolution layer since this is a
convolutional neural network a
convolution layer has a number of
filters and perform convolution
operation every image is considered as a
matrix of pixel values consider the
following 5x5 image whose pixel values
are only 0 and 1. now obviously when
we're dealing with color there's all
kinds of things that come in on color
processing but we want to keep it simple
and just keep it black and white and so
we have our image pixels so we're
sliding the filter matrix over the image
and computing the dot product to detect
the patterns and right here you're going
to ask where does this filter come from
this is a bit confusing because the
filter
is going to be derived
later on we build the filters when we
program or train our model so you don't
need to worry what the filter actually
is but you do need to understand how a
convolution layer works is what is the
filter doing filter and you'll have many
filters you don't have just one filter
you'll have lots of filters that are
going to look for different aspects and
so the filter might be looking for just
edges it might be looking for different
parts we'll cover that a little bit more
detail in a minute right now we're just
focusing on how the filter works as a
matrix remember earlier we talked about
multiplying matrixes together and here
we have our two dimensional matrix and
you can see we take the filter and we
multiply it in the upper left image and
you can see right here one times one one
times zero one times one we multiply
those all together then sum them and we
end up with the convolved feature of
four we're going to take that and
sliding the filter matrix over the image
and computing the dot product to detect
patterns so we're just going to slide
this over we're going to predict the
first one and slide it over one notch
predict the second one and so on and so
on all the way through until we have a
new matrix and this matrix which is the
same size as the filter has reduced the
image and whatever filter whatever
that's filtering out it's going to be
looking at just those features reduced
down to a smaller matrix so once the
feature maps are extracted the next step
is to move them to the relu layer so the
relu layer the next step first is going
to perform an element-wise operation so
each of those maps coming in if there's
negative pixels so it says all the
negative pixels to zero
and you can see this nice graph where it
just zeros out the negatives and then
you have a value that goes from zero up
to whatever value is coming out of the
matrix this introduces non-linearity to
the network so up until now we have a we
say linearity we're talking about the
fact that the feature has a value so
it's a linear feature this feature
came up and has let's say the feature is
the edge of the beak you know it's like
or the backslash that we saw you'll look
at that and say okay this feature has a
value from negative 10 to 10 in this
case if it was one it'd say yeah this
might be a beak it might not might be an
edge right there a minus five means no
we're not even going to look at it to
zero and so we end up with an output and
the output takes all these features all
these filtered features remember we're
not just running one filter on this
we're running a number of filters on
this image and so we end up with a
rectified feature map that is looking at
just the features coming through and how
they weigh in from our filters so here
we have an input of a looks like a
toucan bird
very exotic looking real image is
scanned in multiple convolution and the
relu layers for locating features and
you can see up here is turn it into a
black and white image and in this case
we're looking in the upper right hand
corner for a feature and that box scans
over a lot of times it doesn't scan one
pixel at a time a lot of times it will
skip by two or three or four pixels to
speed up the process that's one of the
ways you can compensate if you don't
have enough resources on your
computation for large images and it's
not just one filter slowly goes across
the image you have multiple filters have
been programmed in there so you're
looking at a lot of different filters
going over the different aspects of the
image and just sliding across there and
forming a new matrix one more aspect to
note about the relu layer is we're not
just having one value coming in
so not only do we have multiple features
going through but we're generating
multiple relu layers for locating the
features that's very important to note
you know so we have a quite a bundle we
have multiple filters multiple rail u uh
which brings us to the next step
forward propagation now we're going to
look at the pooling layer the rectified
feature map now goes through a pooling
layer pooling is a down sampling
operation that reduces the
dimensionality of the feature map that's
all we're trying to do we're trying to
take a huge amount of information and
reduce it down to a single answer this
is a specific kind of bird this is an
iris this is a rose so you have a
rectified feature map
you see here we have a rectified feature
map coming in
we set the max pooling with a two by two
filters and a stride of two and if you
remember correctly i talked about not
going one pixel at a time uh well that's
where the stride comes in we end up with
a two by two pooled feature map but
instead of moving one over each time and
looking at every possible combination we
skip a step we skip a few there we go by
two we skip every other pixel and we
just do every other one and this reduces
our rectified feature map which is you
can see over here 16 by 16 to a four by
four so we're continually trying to
filter and reduce our data so that we
can get to something we can manage and
over here you see that we have the max
three four one and two and in the max
pooling we're looking for the max value
a little bit different than what we were
looking at before so coming from the
rectified feature we're now finding the
max value and then we're pulling those
features together so instead of think of
this as image of the map think of this
as how valuable is a feature in that
area how much of a feature value do we
have we just want to find the best or
the maximum feature for that area they
might have that one piece of the filter
of the beak set up i see a one in this
beak in this image and then it skips
over and says i see a three in this
image and says oh this one is rated as a
four we don't want to sum it together
because then you know you might have
like five ones and it'll say ah five but
you might have uh four zeros and one ten
and that ten says well this is
definitely a beak where the ones will
say probably not a beak a little strange
analogy since we're looking at a bird
but you can see how that pulled feature
map comes down and we're just looking
for the max value in each one of those
matrixes pooling layer uses different
filters to identify different parts of
the image like edges corners body
feathers eyes beak etc i know i focus
mainly on the beak but obviously each
feature could be each a different part
of the bird coming in so let's take a
look at what that looks like structure
of a convolution neural network so far
this is where we're at right now we have
our input image coming in and then we
use our filters and there's multiple
filters on there that are being
developed to kind of twist and change
that data and so we multiply the
matrixes we take that little filter
maybe it's a two by two we multiply it
by each piece of the image and if we
step two then it's every other piece of
the image that generates multiple
convolution layers so we have a number
of convolution layers we have
set up in there just looking at that
data we then take those convolution
layers we run them through the relu
setup and then once we've done through
the release setup and we have multiple
values going on multiple layers that are
relu then we're going to take those
multiple layers and we're going to be
pooling them so now we have the pooling
layers or multiple poolings going on up
until this point we're dealing with
sometimes multiple dimensions you can
have three dimensions some strange data
setups that aren't doing images but
looking at other things they can have
four five six seven dimensions uh so
right now we're looking at 2d image
dimensions coming in into the pooling
layer so the next step is we want to
reduce those dimensions or flatten them
so flattening flattening is a process of
converting all of the resultant
two-dimensional arrays from pooled
feature map into a single long
continuous linear vector so over here
you see where we have a pooled feature
map maybe that's the bird wing and it
has values six eight four seven and we
wanna just flatten this out and turn it
into six eight four seven or a single
linear vector and we find out that not
only do we do each of the pooled feature
maps we do all of them into one long
linear vector so now we've gone through
our convolutional neural network part
and we have the input layer into the
next setup all we've done is taken all
those different pooling layers and we
flatten them out and combine them into a
single linear vector going in so after
we've done the flattening we have just a
quick recap because we've covered so
much so it's important to go back and
take a look at each of the steps we've
gone through the structure of the
network so far we have our convolution
where we twist it and we filter it and
multiply the matrixes we end up with our
convolutional layer which uses the relu
to figure out the values going out into
the pooling as you have numerous
convolution layers that then create
numerous pooling layers pulling that
data together which is the max value
which one we want to send forward we
want to send the best value and then
we're going to take all of that from
each of the pooling layers and we're
going to flatten it and we're going to
combine them into a single input going
into the final layer once you get to
that step you might be looking at that
going boy that looks like the normal
into it to most neural network and
you're correct it is so once we have the
flattened matrix from the pooling layer
that becomes our input so the pulling
layer is fed as an input to the fully
connected layer to classify the image
and so you can see as our flattened
matrix comes in in this case we have the
pixels from the flattened matrix fed as
an input back to our toucan or whatever
that kind of bird that is i need one of
these to identify what kind of bird that
is it comes into our ford propagation
network
and that will then have the different
weights coming down across and then
finally it selects that that's a bird
and that is not a dog or a cat in this
case
even though it's not labeled the final
layer there in red is our output layer
our final output layer that says bird
cat or dog so quick recap of everything
we've covered so far we have our input
image which is twisted and multiplied
the filters are multiplied times the
matrix and the two matrixes multiplied
all the filters to create our
convolution layer our convolution layers
there's multiple layers in there because
it's all building multiple layers off
the different filters then goes through
the relu as this activation and that
creates our pooling and so once we get
into the pooling layer we then and the
pooling look for who's the best what's
the max value coming in from our
convolution and then we take that layer
and we flatten it and then it goes into
a fully connected layer our fully
connected neural network and then to the
output and here we can see the entire
process how the cnn recognizes a bird
this is kind of nice because it's
showing the little pixels and where
they're going you can see the filter is
generating this convolution network and
that filter shows up in the bottom part
of the convolution network and then
based on that it uses the relu for the
pooling the pooling then find out which
one's the best and so on all the way to
the fully connected layer at the end or
the classification in the output layer
so that'd be a classification neural
network at the end so we covered a lot
of theory up till now and you can
imagine each one of these steps has to
be broken down in code so putting that
together can be a little complicated not
that each step of the process is overly
complicated but because we have so many
steps we have one two three four five
different steps going on here with sub
steps in there we're going to break that
down and walk through that in code so in
our use case implementation using the
cnn we'll be using the cfar10 dataset
from canadian institute for advanced
research for classifying images across
10 categories unfortunately they don't
let me know whether it's going to be a
toucan or some other kind of bird but we
do get to find out whether it can
categorize between a ship a frog deer
bird airplane automobile cat dog horse
truck so that's a lot of fun and if
you're looking anything in the news at
all of our automated cars and everything
else you can see where this kind of
processing is so important in today's
world and very cutting edge as far as
what's coming out in the commercial
deployment i mean this is really cool
stuff we're starting to see this just
about everywhere in industry so great
time to be playing with this and
figuring it all out let's go ahead and
dive into the code and see what that
looks like when we're actually writing
our script
before we go on let's do one more quick
look at what we have here let's just
take a look at data batch one keys and
remember in jupiter notebook i can get
by with not doing the print statement if
i put a variable down there it'll just
display the variable and you can see
under data batch one for the keys since
this is a dictionary we have the batch
one label data and file names so you can
actually see how it's broken up in our
data set so for the next step or step
four as we're calling it uh we want to
display the image using matte plot
library there's many ways to display the
images you can even uh well there's
other ways to drill into it but matplot
library is really good for this and
we'll also look at our first reshape
setup or shaping the data so you can
have a little glimpse into what that
means uh so we're going to start by
importing our map plot and of course
since i am doing jupiter notebook i need
to do the matplot inline command so it
shows up on my page so here we go we're
going to import matplot library.piplot
is plt and if you remember matplot
library the pie plot is like a canvas
that we paint stuff onto and there's my
percentage sign matplot library inline
so it's going to show up in my notebook
and then of course we're going to import
numpy as np for our numbers python array
setup and let's go ahead and set
x equals to data batch 1. so this will
pull in all the data going into the x
value and then because this is just a
long stream of binary data we need to go
a little bit of reshaping so in here we
have to go ahead and reshape the data we
have 10 000 images okay that looks
correct and this is kind of an
interesting thing it took me a little
bit to i had to go research this myself
to figure out what's going on with this
data and what it is is it's a 32 by 32
picture and let me do this let me go
ahead and do a drawing pad on here so we
have 32 bits by 32 bits and it's in
color so there's three bits of color now
i don't know why the data is
particularly like this it probably has
to do with how they originally encoded
it but most pictures put the three
afterward so what we're doing here
is we're going to take
the shape we're going to take the data
which is just a long stream of
information and we're going to break it
up into 10 000 pieces and those 10 000
pieces then are broken into three pieces
each and those three pieces then are 32
by 32. you can look at this like an
old-fashioned projector where they have
the red screen or the red projector the
blue projector and the green projector
and they add them all together and each
one of those is a 32 by 32 bit so that's
probably how this was originally
formatted was in that kind of ideal
things have changed so we're going to
transpose it and we're going to take the
three which was here and we're going to
put it at the end so the first part is
reshaping the data from a single line of
bit data or whatever format it is into
10 000 by 3 by 32 by 32 and then we're
going to transpose the color factor to
the last place so it's the image then
the 32 by 32 in the middle that's this
part right here and then finally we're
going to take this uh which is three
bits of data and put it at the end so
it's more like we do we process images
now and then as type this is really
important that we're going to use an
integer eight you can come in here and
you'll see a lot of these they'll try to
do this with a float or float 64. what
you got to remember though is a float
uses a lot of memory so once you switch
this into
something that's not integer eight which
goes up to 128 you are just going to the
the amount of ram let me just put that
in here is going to go way up the amount
of ram that it loads so you want to go
ahead and use this you can try the other
ones and see what happens if you have a
lot of ram on your computer but for this
exercise this will work just fine and
let's go ahead and take that and run
this so now our x variable is all loaded
and it has all the images in it from the
batch one data batch one and just to
show we were talking about with the as
type on there if we go ahead and take x0
and just look for its max value let me
go ahead and run that uh you'll see it
doesn't oops i said 128 it's 255. uh
you'll see it doesn't go over 255
because it's basically an ascii
character is what we're keeping that
down to we're keeping those values down
so they're only 255 0 to 255 versus a
float value which would bring this up
exponentially in size and since we're
using the matplot library we can do
oops that's not what i wanted since
we're using the map plot library we can
take our canvas and just do a plt dot im
for image show and uh let's just take a
look at what x0 looks like and it comes
in i'm not sure what that is but you can
see it's a very low grade image
broken down to the minimal pixels on
there and if we did the same thing oh
let's do uh let's see what one looks
like hopefully it's a little easier to
see run on there not enter let's hit the
run on that uh and we can see this is
probably a semi truck that's a good
guess on there and i can just go back up
here instead of typing the same line in
over and over we'll look at three uh
that looks like a dump truck unloading
uh and so on you can do any of the 10
000 images we can just jump to 55
looks like some kind of animal looking
at us there probably a dog and just for
fun let's do just one more uh
run on there and we can see a nice car
for our image number four uh so you can
see we pace through all the different
images it's very easy to look at them
and they've been reshaped to fit our
view and what the
matplot library uses for its format so
the next step is we're going to start
creating some helper functions we'll
start by a one hot encoder to help us or
processing the data remember that your
labels they can't just be words they
have to switch it and we use the one hot
encoder to do that and then we'll also
create a class
cfar helper so it's going to have an
init and a set up for the images and
then finally we'll go ahead and run that
code so you can see what that looks like
and then we get into the fun part where
we're actually going to start creating
our model our actual neural network
model so let's start by creating our one
hot encoder we're going to create our
own here and it's going to return an out
and we'll have our vector coming in and
our values equal 10. what this means is
that we have the 10 values the 10
possible labels and remember we don't
look at the labels as a number because a
car isn't one more than a horse maybe
just kind of bizarre to have horse
equals zero car equals one plane equals
two cat equals three so a cat plus a car
equals what uh so instead we create a
numpy array of zeros and there's going
to be ten values so we have a ten
different values in there so you have
zero or one one means it's a cat zero
means it's not a cat
in the next line it might be that one
means it's a car zero means it's not a
car so instead of having one output with
a value of zero to ten you have ten
outputs with the values of 0 to 1.
that's what the one hot encoder is doing
here and we're going to utilize this in
code in just a minute so let's go ahead
and take a look at the next helpers we
have a few of these helper functions
we're going to build and when you're
working with a very complicated python
project dividing it up into separate
definitions and classes is very
important otherwise it just becomes
really ungainly to work with so let's go
ahead and put in our next helper which
is a class and this is a lot in this
class so we'll break it down here and
let's just start uh oops we put a space
right in there there we go that was a
little bit more readable at a second
space so we're going to create our class
the cipher helper and we'll start by
initializing it now there's a lot going
on in here so let's start with the uh
init part uh self dot i equals zero i'll
come in in a little bit we'll come back
to that in the lower part we want to
initialize our training batches so when
we went through this there was like a
meta batch we don't need the meta batch
but we do need the data batch one two
three four five and we do not want the
testing batch in here this is just the
self all train batches so we're gonna
come make an array of all those
different images and then of course we
left the test batch out so we have our
self.testbatch
we're going to initialize the training
images and the training labels and also
the test images and the test labels so
these are just this is just to
initialize these variables in here then
we create another definition down here
and this is going to set up the images
let's just take a look and see what's
going on in there now we could have all
just put this as part of the
init part
since this is all just helper stuff but
breaking it up again makes it easier to
read it also makes it easier when we
start executing the different pieces to
see what's going on so that way we have
a nice print statement to say hey we're
now running this and this is what's
going on in here we're going to set up
the self training images at this point
and that's going to go to a numpy array
v stack and in there we're going to load
up
in this case the data for d itself all
train batches again that points right up
to here so we're going to go through
each one of these
files or each one of these data sets
because they're not a file anymore we've
brought them in data batch one points to
the actual data and so our self training
images is going to stack them all into
our into a numpy array and then it's
always nice to get the training length
and that's just a total number of uh
self-training images in there and then
we're going to take the self training
images and let me switch marker colors
because i am getting a little bit too
much on the markers up here oops there
we go bring down our marker change
so we can see it a little better and at
this point this should look familiar
where did we see this well when we
wanted to
look at this above and we want to look
at the images in the matplot library we
had to reshape it so we're doing the
same thing here we're taking our self
training images and based on the
training length total number of images
because we stacked them all together so
now it's just one large file of images
we're going to take and look at it as
our our three video cameras that are
each displaying a 32 by 32 we're going
to switch that around so that now we
have each of our images that stays the
same place and then we have our 32 by 32
and then by our three our last are three
different values for the color and of
course we want to go ahead and they run
this where we say divide by 255 that was
from earlier it just brings all the data
into zero to one that's what this is
doing so we're turning this into a zero
to one array which is uh all the
pictures 32 by 32 by three and then
we're going to take the self training
labels and we're going to pump those
through our one hot encoder we just made
and we're going to stack them together
and
again we're converting this into an
array that goes from
instead of having horse equals 1 dog
equals 2 and then horse plus dog would
equal 3 which would be cat
now it's going to be you know an array
of 10 where each one is 0 to 1. then we
want to go ahead and set up our test
images and labels and when we're doing
this you're going to see it's the same
thing we just did with the rest of them
we just changed colors right here this
is no different than what we were doing
up here with our training set
we're going to stack the different
images
we're going to get the length of them so
we know how many images are in there you
certainly could add them by hand but
it's nice to let the computer do it
especially if it ever changes on the
other end and you're using other data
and again we reshape them and transpose
them and we also do the one hot encoder
same thing we just did on our training
images so now our test images are in the
same format so now we have a definition
which sets up all our images in there
and then the next step is to go ahead
and batch them or next batch and let's
do another breakout here for batches
because this is really important to
understand just to throw me for a little
loop when i'm working with tensorflow or
cross or a lot of these we have our data
coming in if you remember we had like 10
000 photos let me just put 10 000 down
here we don't want to run all 10 000 at
once so we want to break this up into
batch sizes and you also remember that
we had the number of photos in this case
uh length of test or whatever number is
in there we also have 32 by 32
by 3. so when we're looking at the batch
size we want to change this from 10 000
to
a batch of in this case i think we're
going to do batches of 100. so we want
to look at just 100 the first hundred of
the photos and if you remember we set
self-i
equal to
zero
so what we're looking at here is we're
going to create x we're going to get the
next batch from the very initialize
we've already initialized it for 0. so
we're going to look at x from 0 to batch
size which we set to 100 so just the
first 100 images and then we're going to
reshape that into
and this is important to let the data
know that we're looking at 100 by 32 by
32 by 3 now we've already formatted it
to the 32 by 32 by 3. this just sets
everything up correctly so that x has
the data in there in the correct order
and the correct shape and then the y
just like the x
is our labels so our training labels
again they go from zero to batch size in
this case they do sell five plus batch
size because the cell phi is going to
keep changing and then finally we
increment the self i because we have
zero so we so the next time we call it
we're going to get the next batch size
and so basically we have x and y x being
the photograph data coming in and y
being the label and that of course is
labeled through one hot encoder so if
you remember correctly if it was
horse is equal to zero it would be um
one for the zero position since this is
the horse and then everything else would
be zero in here let me just put lines
through there there we go there's our
array
hard to see that array so let's go ahead
and take that and uh we're going to
finish loading it since this is our
class and now we're armed with all this
um
our setup over here let's go ahead and
load that up and so we're going to
create a variable ch with the cfar
helper in it and then we're going to do
ch.setup images
now we could have just put all the setup
images under the init but by breaking
this up into two parts it makes it much
more readable and also if you're doing
other work there's reasons to do that as
far as the setup let's go ahead and run
that and you can see where it says uh
setting up training images and labels
setting up test images and that's one of
the reasons we broke it up is so that if
you're testing this out you can actually
have print statements in there telling
you what's going on which is really nice
uh they did a good job with this setup i
like the way that it was broken up in
the back and then one quick note you
want to remember that batch to set up
the next batch since we have to run uh
batch equals ch next batch of 100
because we're going to use the 100 size
but we'll come back to that we're going
to use that just remember that that's
part of our code we're going to be using
in a minute from the definition we just
made so now we're ready to create our
model first thing we want to do is we
want to import our tensorflow as tf i'll
just go ahead and run that so it's
loaded up and you see we got a
warning here
that's because they're making some
changes it's always growing and they're
going to be depreciating one of the
values from float 64 to float type or is
treated as an np float64 uh nothing to
really worry about this doesn't even
affect what we're working on because
we've set all of our stuff to a 255
value or zero to one and do keep in mind
that zero to one value that we converted
to 255 is still a float value but it'll
easily work with either the numpy float
64 or the numpy d type float it doesn't
matter which one it goes through so the
depreciation would not affect our code
as we have it and in our tensorflow uh
we'll go ahead and just increase the
size in there just a moment so you can
get a better view of the um what we're
typing in uh we're gonna set a couple
placeholders here and so we have we're
gonna set x equals tf placeholder tf
float 32 we just talked about the float
64 versus the numpy float we're actually
just going to keep this at float 32 more
than a significant number of decimals
for what we're working with and since
it's a placeholder we're going to set
the shape equal to and we've set it
equal to none because at this point
we're just holding the place on there
we'll be setting up as we run the
batches that's what the first value is
and then 32 by 32 by 3 that's what we've
reshaped our data to fit in and then we
have our y true equals placeholder tf
float 32 and the shape equals none comma
10. 10 is the 10 different labels we
have so it's an array of 10. and then
let's create one more placeholder we'll
call this a hold prob or hold
probability and we're going to use this
we don't have to have a shape or
anything for this this placeholder is
for what we call drop out if you
remember from our theory before we drop
out so many nodes is looking at or the
different values going through which
helps decrease bias so we need to go
ahead and put a placeholder for that
also and we'll run this so it's all
loaded up in there so we have our three
different placeholders and since we're
in tensorflow when you use cross it does
some of this automatically but we're in
tensorflow direct cross sits on
tensorflow we're going to go ahead and
create some more helper functions we're
going to create something to help us
initialize the weights initialize our
bias if you remember that each layer has
to have a bias going in we're going to
go ahead and work on our conversional 2d
our max pool so we have our pooling
layer our convolutional layer and then
our normal full layer so we're going to
go ahead and put those all into
definitions and let's see what that
looks like in code and you can also grab
some of these helper functions from the
mnist the
nist setup let me just put that in there
if you're under the tensorflow so a lot
of these already in there but we're
going to go ahead and do our own and
we're going to create our init weights
and one of the reasons we're doing this
is so that you can actually start
thinking about what's going on in the
back end so even though there's ways to
do this with an automation sometimes
these have to be tweaked and you have to
put in your own setup in here uh now
we're not going to be doing that we're
just going to recreate them for our code
and let's take a look at this we have
our weights and so what comes in is
going to be the shape and what comes out
is going to be
random numbers so we're going to go
ahead and just admit some random numbers
based on the shape with a standard
deviation of 0.1 kind of a fun way to do
that and then the tf variable
init random distribution so we're just
creating a random distribution on there
that's all that is for the weights now
you might change that you might have a
higher standard deviation in some cases
you actually load preset weights that's
pretty rare usually you're testing that
against another model or something like
that and you want to see how those
weights configure with each other now
remember we have our bias so we need to
go ahead and initialize the bias with a
constant
in this case we're using 0.1 a lot of
times the bias is just put in as one and
then you have your weights to add on to
that but we're going to set this as 0.1
uh so we want to return a convolutional
2d in this case a neural network this is
uh would be a layer on here what's going
on with the con 2d is we're taking our
data coming in uh we're going to filter
it strides if you remember correctly
strides came from here's our image and
then we only look at this picture here
and then maybe we have a stride of one
so we look at this picture here and we
continue to look at the different
filters going on there the other thing
this does is that we have our data
coming in as 32
by
3 and we want to change this so that
it's just this is three dimensions and
it's going to reformat this as just two
dimensions so it's going to take this
number here and combine it with the 32
by 32. so this is a very important layer
here because it's reducing our data down
using different means and it connects
down i'm just going to jump down one
here it goes with the convolutional
layer so you have your your kind of your
preformatting and the setup and then you
have your actual convolution layer that
goes through on there and you can see
here we have init weights by the shape
and knit bias shape of three because we
have the three different uh here's our
three again and then we return the tfnn
relu with the convention 2d so this
convolutional has this feeding into it
right there it's using that as part of
it and of course the input is the x y
plus b the bias so that's quite a
mouthful but these two are the are the
keys here to creating the convolutional
layers there the convolutional 2d coming
in and then the convolutional layer
which then steps through and creates all
those filters we saw then of course we
have our pooling
so after each time we run it through the
convectional layer we want to pull the
data if you remember correctly on the on
the pool side and let me just get rid of
all my marks it's getting a little crazy
there and in fact let's go ahead and
jump back to that slide let's just take
a look at that slide over here uh so we
have our image coming in we create our
convolutional layer with all the filters
remember the filters go
you know the filter is coming in here
and it looks at these four boxes and
then if it's a step let's say step two
it then goes to these four boxes and
then the next step and so on uh so we
have our convolutional layer that we
generate or convolutional layers they
use the uh relu function there's other
functions out there for this though the
relu is the
most the one that works the best at
least so far i'm sure that will change
then we have our pooling now if you
remember correctly the pooling was max
uh so if we had the filter coming in and
they did the multiplication on there and
we have a one and maybe a two here and
another one here and a three here three
is the max and so out of all of these
you then create an array that would be
three and if the max is over here two or
whatever it is that's what goes into the
pooling of what's going on in our
pooling uh so again we're reducing that
data down reducing it down as small as
we can and then finally we're going to
flatten it out into a single array and
that goes into our fully connected layer
and you can see that here in the code
right here we're going to create our
normal full layer so at some point we're
going to take from our pooling layer
this will go into some kind of
flattening process and then that will be
fed into the full the different layers
going in down here and so we have our
input size you'll see our input layer
get shape which is just going to get the
shape for whatever's coming in uh and
then input size initial weights is also
based on the input layer coming in and
the input size down here is based on the
input layer shape so we're just going to
already use the shape and already have
our size coming in and of course you
have to make sure you knit the bias
always put your bias on there and we'll
do that based on the size so this will
return
tf.matimole
input layer w plus b this is just a
normal full layer that's what this means
right down here that's what we're going
to return so that was a lot of steps we
went through let's go ahead and run that
so those are all loaded in there and
let's go ahead and create the layers
let's see what that looks like
now that we've done all the heavy
lifting and everything uh we get to do
all the easy part let's go ahead and
create our layers we'll create a
convolution layer one and two two
different convolutional layers and then
we'll take that and we'll flatten that
out create a reshape pooling in there
for our reshape and then we'll have our
full uh layer at the end so let's start
by creating our first convolutional
layer then we come in here and let me
just run that real quick and i want you
to notice on here the 3
and the 32 this is important because
coming into this convolutional layer we
have three different channels and 32
pixels each
so that has to be in there the 4 and 4
you can play with this is your filter
size so if you remember you have a
filter and you have your image and the
filter slowly steps over and filters out
this image depending on what your step
is for this particular setup 4 4 is just
fine that should work pretty good for
what we're doing for the size of the
image and then of course at the end once
you have your convolutional layer set up
you also need to pull it and you'll see
that the pooling is automatically set up
so that it would see the different shape
based on what's coming in so here we
have max toolbar two by two and we put
in the convolutional one that we just
created the convolutional layer we just
created goes right back into it and that
right up here as you can see is the x is
coming in from here so it knows to look
at the first model and set the the data
accordingly set that up so it matches
and we went ahead and ran this already i
think i read let me go and run it again
and if we're going to do one layer let's
go ahead and do a second layer down here
and it's uh we'll call it convo two
it's also a convolutional layer on this
and you'll see that we're feeding
convolutional one in the pooling so it
goes from convolutional one into
convolutional one pooling from
convolutional one pooling into
convolutional two and then from
convolutional two into convolutional to
pooling and we'll go ahead and take this
and run this so these variables are all
loaded into memory and for our flattened
layer
let's go ahead and we'll do since we
have 64 coming out of here and we have a
four by four going in let's do eight by
eight by 64. so let's do
4096. this is going to be the flat layer
so that's how many bits are coming
through on the flat layer and we'll
reshape this so we'll reshape our
convo 2 pooling and that will feed into
here the combo 2 pulling and then we're
going to set it up as a single layer
that's 4096 in size that's what that
means there we'll go ahead and run this
so we've now created this variable the
convo 2 flat and then we have our first
full layer this is the final
neural network where the flat layer
going in and we're going to again use
the relu for our setup on there on a
neural network for evaluation and you'll
notice that we're going to create our
first full layer our normal full layer
that's our definition so we created that
that's creating the normal full layer
and our input for the data comes right
here from the this goes right into it uh
the convo to flat so this tells it how
big the data is and we're going to have
it come out it's going to have 10 24
that's how big the layer is coming out
we'll go ahead and run this so now we
have our full layer one and with the
full layer one we want to also define
the full one dropout to go with that so
our full layer one comes in uh keep
probability equals whole probability
remember we created that earlier and the
full layer one is what's coming into it
and this is going backwards and training
the data we're not training every weight
we're only training a percentage of them
each time which helps get rid of the
bias so let me go ahead and run that and
finally we'll go ahead and create a y
predict which is going to equal the
normal full 1 drop out and 10 because we
have 10 labels in there now in this
neural network we could have added
additional layers that would be another
option to play with you can also play
with instead of 10 24 you can use other
numbers for the way that sets up and
what's coming out going into the next
one we're only going to do just the one
layer and the one layer drop out and you
can see if we did another layer it'd be
really easy just to feed in the full one
dropout into full layer two and then
full layer two dropout would have full
layer two feed into it and then you'd
switch that here for the y prediction
for right now this is great this
particular data set is tried and true
and we know that this will work on it
and if we just type in y predict and we
run that
we'll see that this is a tensor object
shape question mark 10 d type 32 a quick
way to double check what we're working
on so now we've got all of our we've
done a setup all the way to the y
predict which we just did we want to go
ahead and apply the loss function and
make sure that's set up in there uh
create the optimizer and then
trainer optimizer and create a variable
to initialize all the global tf
variables so before we dive in to the
loss function let me point out one quick
thing or just kind of a rehab over a
couple things and that is when we're
playing with this these setups um we
pointed out up here we can change the
four four and use different numbers
there they change your outcome so
depending on what numbers you use here
will have a huge impact on how well your
model fits and that's the same here of
the 1024 also this is also another
number that if you continue to raise
that number you'll get
possibly a better fit you might overfit
and if you lower that number you'll use
less resources and generally you want to
use this in
the exponential growth an exponential
being 2 4 8 16 and in this case the next
one down would be 5 12. you can use any
number there but those would be the
ideal numbers when you look at this data
so the next step in all this is we need
to also create a way of tracking how
good our model is and we're going to
call this a loss function and so we're
going to create a cross entropy loss
function and so before we discuss
exactly what that is let's take a look
and see what we're feeding it
we're going to feed it our labels and we
have our true labels and our prediction
labels so coming in here is where the
two different variables we're sending in
or the two different probability
distributions is one that we know is
true and what we think it's going to be
now this function right here when they
talk about cross entropy uh in
information theory the cross entropy
between two probability distributions
over the same underlying set of events
measures the average number of bits
needed to identify an event drawn from
the set that's a mouthful
really we're just looking at the amount
of error in here how many of these are
correct and how many of these are
incorrect so how much of it matches and
we're going to look at that we're just
going to look at the average that's what
the mean the reduced to the mean means
here so we're looking at the average
error on this
and so the next step is we're going to
take the error we want to know our cross
entropy or our loss function how much
loss we have that's going to be part of
how we train the model so when you know
what the loss is and we're training it
you feed that back into the back
propagation setup and so we want to go
ahead and optimize that here's our
optimizer we're going to create the
optimizer using an atom optimizer
remember there's a lot of different ways
of optimizing the data atoms the most
popular used
so our optimizer is going to equal the
tf train atom optimizer if you don't
remember what the learning rate is let
me just pop this back into here here's
our learning rate when you have your
weights you have all your weights and
your different nodes that are coming out
here's our node coming out and it has
all its weights and then the error is
being prop sent back through in reverse
on our neural network so we take this
error we adjust these weights based on
the different formulas in this case the
atom formula is what we're using we
don't want to just adjust them
completely we don't want to change this
weight so it exactly fits the data
coming through because if we made that
kind of adjustment it's going to be
biased to whatever the last data we sent
through is instead we're going to
multiply that by .001 and make a very
small shift in this weight so our delta
w is only 0.001 of the actual delta w of
the full change we're going to compute
from the atom and then we want to go
ahead and train it so our training or
set up a training
variable or function and this is going
to equal our optimizer minimize cross
entropy and we make sure we go ahead and
run this
so it's loaded in there and then we're
almost ready to train our model but
before we do that we need to create one
more
variable in here and we're going to
create a variable to initialize all the
global tf variables and when we look at
this
the tf global variable initializer this
is a tensorflow
object it goes through there and it
looks at all our different setup that we
have going under our tensor flow and
then initializes those variables
so it's kind of like a magic wand
because it's all hidden in the back end
of tensorflow all you need to know about
this is that you have to have the
initialization on there which is an
operation
and you have to run that once you have
your setup going so we'll go ahead and
run this piece of code and then we're
going to go ahead and train our data so
let me run this let's load it up there
and so now we're going to go ahead and
run the model by creating a graph
session graph session is a tensorflow
term so you'll see that coming up it's
one of the things that throws me because
i always think of graphics and spark and
graph as just general graphing but they
talk about a graph session so we're
going to go ahead and run the model and
let's go ahead and walk through this
what's going on here and let's paste
this data in here and here we go so
we're going to start off with it with a
tf session as sess so that's our actual
tf session we've created
so we're right here with the tf
session our session we're creating we're
going to run tf global variable
initializer so right off the bat we're
initializing our variables here and then
we have for i in range 500. so what's
going on here remember 500 we're going
to break the date up and we're going to
batch it in at 500 points each we've
created our session run so we're going
to do with tf session as session right
here we've created our variable session
uh and then we're going to run and we're
going to go ahead and initialize it so
we have our tf global variables
initializer that we created um that
initializes our our session in here the
next thing we're going to do is we're
going to go for i in range of 500 batch
equals ch.nextbatch
so if you remember correctly this is
loading up
100 pictures at a time and
this is going to loop through that 500
times so we are literally doing uh what
is that uh 500 times 100 is uh 50 000.
so that's 50 000 pictures we're going to
process right there and the first
process is we're going to do a session
run we're going to take our train we
created our train variable or optimizer
in there we're going to feed it the
dictionary we had our feed dictionary
that we created and we have x equals
batch 0 coming in y true batch 1 hold
the probability 0.5 and then just so
that we can keep track of what's going
on we're going to every 100 steps we're
going to run a print so currently on
step format
accuracy is um and we're going to look
at matches equals tf.equal tf argument y
prediction one tf.arg
max y true comma one so we're going to
look at this is how many matches it has
and here our acc uh all we're doing here
is we're going to take the matches how
many matches they have it creates it
generates a chart we're going to convert
that to float that's what the tfcast
does and then we just want to know the
average we just want to know the average
of the accuracy and then we'll go ahead
and print that out print session run
accuracy feed dictionary so it takes all
this and it prints out our accuracy on
there so let's go ahead and take this
oops screen's there let's go ahead and
take this and let's run it and this is
going to take a little bit to run uh so
let's see what happens on my old laptop
and we'll see here that we have our
current uh we're currently on step zero
it takes a little bit to get through the
accuracy and this will take just a
moment to run we can see that on our
step zero it has an accuracy of 0.1 or
0.1028
and as it's running we'll go ahead you
don't need to watch it run all the way
but this accuracy is going to change a
little bit up and down so we've actually
lost some accuracy during our step two
but we'll see how that comes out let's
come back after we run it all the way
through and see how the different steps
come out it's actually reading that
backwards
the way this works is the closer we get
to one the more accuracy we have so you
can see here we've gone from a point one
to a point three nine
and we'll go ahead and pause this and
come back and see what happens when
we're done with the full run all right
now that we've
prepared the meal got it in the oven and
pulled out my finished dish here if
you've ever watched any of the old
cooking shows let's discuss a little bit
about this accuracy going on here and
how do you interpret that we've done a
couple things first we've defined
accuracy
the reason i got it backwards before is
you have
loss or accuracy and with loss you'll
get a graph that looks like this it goes
oops that's an s by the way there we go
you get a graph that curves down like
this and with accuracy you get a graph
that curves up this is how good it's
doing now in this case uh 1 is supposed
to be really good accuracy that means it
gets close to one but it never crosses
one so if you have an accuracy of one
that is phenomenal in fact that's pretty
much
you know unheard of and the same thing
with loss if you have a loss of zero
that's also unheard of the zero is
actually on this this axis right here as
we go in there so how do we interpret
that because you know if i was looking
at this and i go oh 0.51 that's uh 51
you're doing 50 50. no this is not
percentage let me just put that in there
it is not percentage uh this is log
rhythmic what that means is that 0.2 is
twice as good as point one and uh when
we see point four that's twice as good
as point 0.2 real way to convert this
into a percentage you really can't say
this is is a direct percentage
conversion what you can do though is in
your head if we were to give this a
percentage uh we might look at this as
50 percent we're just guessing equals
0.1 and if 50 percent roughly equals 0.1
that's we started up here at the top
remember at the top here here's our
0.1028 the accuracy of 50
then 75 percent is about 0.2 and so on
and so on don't quote those numbers
because that doesn't work that way they
say that if you have 0.95
that's pretty much saying 100
and if you have uh anywhere between
you'd have to go look this up let me go
and remove all my drawings there
so the magic number is 0.5 we really
want to be over a 0.5 in this whole
thing and we have
both 0.504 remember this is accuracy if
we were looking at loss then we would be
looking the other way but 0.05 you know
instead of how high it is we want how
low it is uh but with accuracy being
over a 0.5 is pretty valid that means
this is pretty solid and if you get to a
0.95 then it's a direct correlation
that's what we're looking for here in
these numbers you can see we finished
with this model at 0.5135
so still good
and if we look at when they ran this in
the other end remember there's a lot of
randomness that goes into it when we see
the weights they got
.5251 so a little better than ours but
that's fine you'll find your own uh
comes up a little bit better or worse
depending on just that randomness and so
we've gone through the whole model we've
created we've trained the model and
we've also gone through on every 100th
run to test the model to see how
accurate it is
welcome to the rnn tutorial that's the
recurrent neural network do you know how
google's auto complete feature predicts
the rest of the words a user is typing i
love that auto complete feature as i'm
typing away saves me a lot of time i can
just kind of hit the enter key and it
auto fills everything and i don't have
to type as much well first there's a
collection of large volumes of most
frequently occurring consecutive words
this is fed into a recurrent neural
network analysis the data by finding the
sequence of words occurring frequently
and builds a model to predict the next
word in the sentence and then google
what is the best food to eat in loss i'm
guessing you're going to say loss mexico
no it's going to be las vegas
so the google search will take a look at
that and say hey the most common
autocomplete is going to be vegas in
there and usually it gives you three or
four different choices so it's a very
powerful tool it saves us a lot of time
especially when we're doing a google
search or even in microsoft words has a
some people get very mad at it auto
fills with the wrong stuff but you know
you're typing away and it helps you
autofill i have that in a lot of my
different packages it's just a standard
feature that we're all used to now so
before we dive into the rnn and getting
into the depths let's go ahead and talk
about what is a neural network neural
networks used in deep learning consist
of different layers connected to each
other and work on the structure and
functions of a human brain you're going
to see that thread human in human brain
and human thinking throughout deep
learning the only way we can evaluate an
artificial intelligence or anything like
that is to compare it to human function
very important note on there and it
learns from a huge volumes of data and
it uses complex algorithm to train a
neural net so in here we have image
pixels of two different breeds of dog
one looks like a nice floppy eared lab
and one a german shepherd you know both
wonderful breeds of animals that image
then goes into an input layer
that input layer might be formatted at
some point because you have to let it
know like you know different pictures
are going to be different sizes and
different color content then it'll feed
into hidden layers so each of those
pixels or each point of data goes in and
then splits into the hidden layer which
then goes into another hidden layer
which then goes to an output layer r and
n there's some changes in there which
we're going to get into so it's not just
a straightforward propagation of data
like we've covered in many other
tutorials and finally you have an output
layer and the output layer has two
outputs it has one that lights up if
it's a german shepherd and another that
lights up is if it's a labrador so
identify as a dog's breed set networks
do not require memorizing the past
output so our forward propagation is
just that it goes forward and doesn't
have to be memorized stuff and you can
see there that's not actually me in the
picture uh dressed up in my suit
i haven't worn a suit in years so as
we're looking at this we're going to
change it up a little bit before we
cover that let's talk about popular
neural networks first there's the feed
forward neural network used in general
regression and classification problems
and we have the convolution neural
network used for image recognition deep
neural network used for acoustic
modeling deep belief network used for
cancer detection and recurrent neural
network used for speech recognition now
taken a lot of these and mixed them
around a little bit so just because it's
used for one thing doesn't mean it can't
be used for other modeling but generally
this is where the field is and this is
how those models are generally being
used right now so we talk about a feed
forward neural network in a feed forward
neural network information flows only in
the forward direction from the input
nodes through the hidden layers if any
into the output nodes there are no
cycles or loops in the network and so
you can see here we have our input layer
i was talking about how it just goes
straight forward into the hidden layers
so each one of those connects and then
connects to the next hidden layer
connects to the output layer and of
course we have a nice simplified version
where it has a predicted output the
refer to the input is x a lot of times
and the output as y decisions are based
on current input no memory about the
past no future scope why recurrent
neural network issues in feed forward
neural network so one of the biggest
issues is because it doesn't have a
scope of memory or time a feed-forward
neural network doesn't know how to
handle sequential data uh it only
considers only the current input so if
you have a series of things and because
three points back affects what's
happening now and what your output
affects what's happening that's very
important so whatever i put as an output
is going to affect the next one um a
feed forward doesn't look at any of that
it just looks at this is what's coming
in and it cannot memorize previous
inputs so it doesn't have that list of
inputs coming in solution to feed
forward neural network you'll see here
where it says recurrent neural network
and we have our x on the bottom going to
h going to y that's your feed forward
but right in the middle it has a value c
so there's a whole another process was
memorizing what's going on in the hidden
layers and the hidden layers as they
produce data feed into the next one so
your hidden layer might have an output
that goes off to y
but that output goes back into the next
prediction coming in what this does is
this allows it to handle sequential data
it considers the current input and also
the previously received inputs and if
we're going to look at general drawings
and solutions we should also look at
applications of the rnn image captioning
rnn is used to caption an image by
analyzing the activities present in it a
dog catching a ball in midair that's
very tough i mean you know we have a lot
of stuff that analyzes images of a dog
and the image of a ball but it's able to
add one more feature in there that's
actually catching the ball in midair
time series prediction any time series
problem like predicting the prices of
stocks in a particular month can be
solved using rnn and we'll dive into
that in our use case and actually take a
look at some stock one of the things you
should know about analyzing stock today
is that it is very difficult and if
you're analyzing the whole stock the
stock market at the new york stock
exchange in the u.s produces somewhere
in the neighborhood if you count all the
individual trades in fluctuations by the
second
it's like three terabytes a day of data
so we're going to look at one stock just
analyzing one stock is really tricky in
here we'll give you a little jump on
that so that's exciting but don't expect
to get rich off of it immediately
another application of the rnn is
natural language processing text mining
and sentiment analysis can be carried
out using rnn for natural language
processing and you can see right here
the term natural language processing
when you stream those three words
together is very different than ice if i
said processing language natural leap so
the time series is very important when
we're analyzing sentiments it can change
the whole value of a sentence just by
switching the words around or if you're
just counting the words you may get one
sentiment where if you actually look at
the order they're in you get a
completely different sentiment when it
rains look for rainbows when it's dark
look for stars both of these are
positive sentiments and they're based
upon the order of which the sentence is
going in machine translation given an
input in one language rnn can be used to
translate the input into a different
languages as output i myself very
linguistically challenged but if you
study languages and you're good with
languages you know right away that if
you're speaking english you would say
big cat and if you're speaking spanish
you would say cat big so that
translation is really important to get
the right order to get there's all kinds
of parts of speech that are important to
know by the order of the words here this
person is speaking in english and
getting translated and you can see here
a person is speaking in english in this
little diagram i guess that's denoted by
the flags i have a flag i own it no um
but they're speaking in english and it's
getting translated into
chinese italian french german and
spanish languages some of the tools
coming out are just so cool so somebody
like myself who's very linguistically
challenged i can now travel into worlds
i would never think of because i can
have something translate my english back
and forth readily and i'm not stuck with
a communication gap so let's dive into
what is a recurrent neural network
recurrent neural network works on the
principle of saving the output of a
layer and feeding this back to the input
in order to predict the output of the
layer sounds a little confusing when we
start breaking it down i'll make more
sense and usually we have a propagation
forward neural network with the input
layers the hidden layers the output
layer with the recurrent neural network
we turn that on its side so here it is
and now our x comes up from the bottom
into the hidden layers into y and they
usually draw very simplified x to h with
c as a loop a to y where a b and c are
the perimeters a lot of times you'll see
this kind of drawing in here digging
closer and closer into the h and how it
works going from left to right you'll
see that the c goes in and then the x
goes in so the x is going upward down
and c is going to the right a is going
out and c is also going out that's where
it gets a little confusing so here we
have xn
cn and then we have y out and c out and
c is based on ht minus one so our value
is based on the y and the h value are
connected to each other they're not
necessarily the same value because h can
be its own thing and usually we draw
this or we represent it as a function h
of t equals a function of c where h of t
minus 1 that's the last h output and x
of t going in so it's the last output of
h combined with the new input of x where
h t is the new state f c is a function
with the parameters c that's a common
way of denoting it
h t minus one is the old state coming
out and then x of t is an input vector
at time of step t
well we need to cover types of recurrent
neural networks and so the first one is
the most common one which is a one to
one single output
one to one neural network is usually
known as a vanilla neural network used
for regular machine learning problems
why because vanilla is usually
considered kind of a just a real basic
flavor but because it's very basic a lot
of times they'll call it the vanilla
neural network which is not the common
term but it is kind of a slang term
people will know what you're talking
about usually if you say that then we
run one to many so you have a single
input and you might have a multiple
outputs in this case uh image captioning
as we looked at earlier where we have
not just looking at it as a dog but a
dog catching a ball in the air and then
you have many to one network takes in a
sequence of inputs examples sentiment
analysis where a given sentence can be
classified as expressing positive or
negative sentiments and we looked at
that as we were discussing if it rains
look for a rainbow so positive sentiment
where rain might be a negative sentiment
if you're just adding up the words in
there and then the course if you're
going to do a one-to-one mini to one one
to many there's many to many networks
takes in a sequence of inputs and
generates a sequence of outputs example
machine translation so we have a lengthy
sentence coming in english and then
going out in all the different languages
you know just a wonderful tool very
complicated set of computations you know
if you're a translator you realize just
how difficult it is to translate into
different languages one of the biggest
things you need to understand when we're
working with this neural network is
what's called the vanishing gradient
problem while training an rnn your slope
can be either too small or very large
and this makes training difficult when
the slope is too small the problem is
known as vanishing gradient and you'll
see here they have a nice
image loss of information through time
so if you're pushing not enough
information forward that information is
lost and then when you go to train it
you start losing the third word in the
sentence or something like that or
doesn't quite follow the full logic of
what you're working on exploding
gradient problem oh this is one that
runs into everybody when you're working
with this particular neural network when
the slope tends to grow exponentially
instead of decaying this problem is
called exploding gradient issues in
gradient problem long training time poor
performance bad accuracy and i'll add
one more in there uh your computer if
you're on a lower end computer testing
out a model will lock up and give you
the memory error explaining gradient
problem consider the following two
examples to understand what should be
the next word in the sequence
the person who took my bike and blank a
thief the students who got into
engineering with blank from asia and you
can see in here we have our x value
going in we have the previous value
going forward and then you back
propagate the error like you do with any
neural network and as we're looking for
that missing word maybe we'll have the
person took my bike and blank was a
thief and the student who got into
engineering with a blank were from asia
consider the following example the
person who took the bike so we'll go
back to the person who took the bike was
blank a thief in order to understand
what would be the next word in the
sequence the rnn must memorize the
previous context whether the subject was
singular noun or a plural noun so was a
thief as singular the student who got
into engineering well in order to
understand what would be the next word
in the sequence the rnn must memorize
the previous context whether the subject
was singular noun or a plural noun and
so you can see here the students who got
into engineering with blank were from
asia it might be sometimes difficult for
the air to back propagate to the
beginning of the sequence to predict
what should be the output so when you
run into the gradient problem we need a
solution the solution to the gradient
problem first we're going to look at
exploding gradient where we have three
different solutions depending on what's
going on one is identity initialization
so the first thing we want to do is see
if we can find a way to minimize the
identities coming in instead of having
it identify everything just the
important information we're looking at
next is to truncate the back propagation
so instead of having whatever
information it's sending to the next
series we can truncate what it's sending
we can lower that particular set of
layers make those smaller and finally as
a gradient clipping so when we're
training it we can clip what that
gradient looks like and narrow the
training model that we're using when you
have a vanishing gradient the option
problem we can take a look at weight
initialization very similar to the
identity but we're going to add more
weights in there so it can identify
different aspects of what's coming in
better choosing the right activation
function that's huge so we might be
activating based on one thing and we
need to limit that we haven't talked too
much about activation function so we'll
look at that just minimally there's a
lot of choices out there and then
finally there's long short term memory
networks the lstms and we can make
adjustments to that so just like we can
clip the gradient as it comes out we can
also
expand on that we can increase the
memory network the size of it so it
handles more information and one of the
most common problems in today's
setup is what they call long term
dependencies suppose we try to predict
the last word in the text the clouds are
in the and you probably said sky here we
do not need any further context it's
pretty clear that the last word is going
to be sky suppose we try to predict the
last word in the text i have been
staying in spain for the last 10 years i
can speak fluent maybe you said
portuguese or french no you probably
said spanish the word we predict will
depend on the previous few words in
context here we need the context of
spain to predict the last word in the
text it's possible that the gap between
the relevant information and the point
where it is needed to become very large
lstms help us solve this problem so the
lstms are a special kind of recurrent
neural network capable of learning
long-term dependencies remembering
information for long periods of time is
their default behavior all recurrent
neural networks have the form of a chain
of repeating modules of neural network
connections in standard rnns this
repeating module will have a very simple
structure such as a single tangent h
layer lstms
also have a chain like structure but the
repeating module has a different
structure instead of having a single
neural network layer there are four
interacting layers communicating in a
very special way lstms are a special
kind of recurrent neural network capable
of learning long-term dependencies
remembering information for long periods
of time is their default behavior ls
tmss also have a chain like structure
but the repeating module has a different
structure instead of having a single
neural network layer there are four
interacting layers communicating in a
very special way as you can see the
deeper we dig into this the more
complicated the graphs get in here i
want you to note that you have x of t
minus one coming in you have x a t
coming in and you have x a t plus one
and you have h of t minus one and h of t
coming in and h of t plus 1 going out
and of course on the other side is the
output a
in the middle we have our tangent h but
it occurs in two different places so not
only when we're computing the x of t
plus one are we getting the tangent h
from x to t but we're also getting that
value coming in from the x of t minus
one so the short of it is as you look at
these layers not only does it does the
propagate through the first layer goes
into the second layer back into itself
but it's also going into the third layer
so now we're kind of stacking those up
and this can get very complicated as you
grow that in size it also grows in
memory too and in the amount of
resources it takes but it's a very
powerful tool to help us address a
problem of complicated long sequential
information coming in like we were just
looking at in the sentence and when
we're looking at our long short term
memory network there's three steps of
processing sensing in the lstms we look
at the first one is we want to forget
irrelevant parts of the previous state
you know a lot of times like you know is
as in a unless we're trying to look at
whether it's a plural noun or not they
don't really play a huge part in the
language so we want to get rid of them
then selectively update cell state
values so we only want to update the
cell state values that reflect what
we're working on and finally we want to
put only output certain parts of the
cell state so whatever is coming out we
want to limit what's going out too and
let's dig a little deeper into this
let's just see what this really looks
like uh so step one decides how much of
the past it should remember first step
in the lstm is to decide which
information to be omitted in from the
cell in that particular time step it is
decided by the sigmoid function it looks
at the previous state h to t minus 1 and
the current input x t and computes the
function so you can see over here we
have a function of t
equals the sigmoid function of the
weight of f the h at t minus 1 and then
x a t plus of course you have a bias in
there with any very neural network so we
have a bias function so f of t equals
forget gate decides which information to
delete that is not important from the
previous time step considering an stm is
fed with the following inputs from the
previous and present time step alice is
good in physics john on the other hand
is good in chemistry so previous output
john plays football well he told me
yesterday over the phone that he had
served as a captain of his college
football team that's our current input
so as we look at this the first step is
the forget gate realizes there might be
a change in context after encountering
the first full stop compares with the
current input sentence of x a t so we're
looking at that full stop and then
compares it with the input of the new
sentence the next sentence talks about
john so the information on alice is
deleted okay that's important to know so
we have this input coming in and if
we're going to continue on with john
then that's going to be the primary
information we're looking at the
position of the subject is vacated and
is assigned to john and so in this one
we've seen that we've weeded out a whole
bunch of information and we're only
passing information on john since that's
now the new topic so step two is then to
decide how much should this unit add to
the current state in the second layer
there are two parts one is the sigmoid
function and the other is the tangent h
in the sigmoid function it decides which
values to let through zero or one
tangent h function gives a weightage to
the values which are passed deciding
their level of importance minus one to
one and you can see the two formulators
that come up the i of t equals the
sigmoid of the weight of i h of t minus
one x of t plus the bias of i and the c
of t equals the tangent of h of the
weight of c of h of t minus 1 x of t
plus the bias of c so our i of t equals
the input gate determines which
information to let through based on its
significance in the current time step if
this seems a little complicated don't
worry because a lot of the programming
is already done when we get to the case
study understanding though that this is
part of the program is important when
you're trying to figure out these what
to set your settings at you should also
note when you're looking at this it
should have some semblance to your
forward propagation neural networks
where we have a value assigned to a
weight plus a bias very important steps
than any of the neural network layers
whether we're propagating into them the
information from one to the next or
we're just doing a straightforward
neural network propagation let's take a
quick look at this what it looks like
from the human standpoint as i step out
of my suit again consider the current
input at x of t john plays football well
he told me yesterday over the phone that
he had served as a captain of his
college football team that's our input
input gate analysis the important
information john plays football and he
was a captain of his college team as
important he told me over the phone
yesterday is less important hence it is
forgotten this process of adding some
new information can be done via the
input gate now this example is as a
human form and we'll look at training
this stuff in just a minute uh but as a
human being if i wanted to get this
information from a conversation maybe
it's a google voice listening in on you
or something like that um how do we weed
out the information that he was talking
to me on the phone yesterday well i
don't want to memorize that he talked to
me on the phone yesterday or maybe that
is important but in this case it's not i
want to know that he was the captain of
the football team i want to know that he
served i want to know that john plays
football and he was the captain of the
college football team those are the two
things that i want to take away as a
human being again we measure a lot of
this from the human viewpoint and that's
also how we try to train them so we can
understand these neural networks finally
we get to step three decides what part
of the current cell state makes it to
the output the third step is to decide
what will be our output first we run a
sigmoid layer which decides what parts
of the cell state make it to the output
then we put the cell state through the
tangent h to push the values to be
between -1 and 1 and multiply it by the
output of the sigmoid gate so when we
talk about the output of t we set that
equal to the sigmoid of the weight of
zero of the h of t minus one and back
one step in time by the x of t plus of
course the bias the h of t equals the
outer t times the tangent of the tangent
h of c at t so our o t equals the output
gate allows the passed in information to
impact the output in the current time
step let's consider the example to
predicting the next word in the sentence
john played tremendously well against
the opponent and one for his team for
his contributions brave blank was
awarded player of the match there could
be a lot of choices for the empty space
current input brave is an adjective
adjectives describe a noun john could be
the best output after brave thumbs up
for john awarded player of the match and
if you were to pull just the nouns out
of the sentence team doesn't look right
because that's not really the subject
we're talking about contributions you
know brave contributions or brave teen
brave player brave match
so you look at this and you can start to
train this these this neural network so
starts looking at and goes oh no john is
what we're talking about so brave is an
adjective
going to be the best output and we give
john a big thumbs up and then of course
we jump into my favorite part the case
study use case implementation of lstm
let's predict the prices of stocks using
the lstm network based on the stock
price data between 2012 2016. we're
going to try to predict the stock prices
of 2017.
and this will be a narrow set of data
we're not going to do the whole stock
market it turns out that the new york
stock exchange generates roughly three
terabytes of data per day that's all the
different trades up and down of all the
different stocks going on and each
individual one
second to second or nanosecond to
nanosecond but we're going to limit that
to just some very basic fundamental
information so don't think you're going
to get rich off this today but at least
you can give an eye you can give a step
forward in how to start processing
something like stock prices a very valid
use for machine learning in today's
markets
use case implementation of lstm
let's dive in we're going to import our
libraries we're going to import the
training set and get the scaling going
now if you watch any of our other
tutorials a lot of these pieces just
start to look very familiar because it's
very similar setup let's take a look at
that and just reminder we're going to be
using anaconda the jupiter notebook so
here i have my anaconda navigator when
we go under environments i've actually
set up a cross python 36 i'm in python36
and nice thing about anaconda especially
the newer version i remember a year ago
messing with anaconda in different
versions of python in different
environments anaconda now has a nice
interface
and i have this installed both on a
ubuntu linux machine and on windows so
it works fine on there you can go in
here and open a terminal window and then
in here once you're in the terminal
window this is where you're going to
start installing using pip to install
your different modules and everything
now we've already pre-installed them so
we don't need to do that in here but if
you don't have them installed in your
particular environment you'll need to do
that and of course you don't need to use
the anaconda or the jupiter you can use
whatever favorite python id you like i'm
just a big fan of this because it keeps
all my stuff separate you can see on
this machine i have specifically
installed one for cross since we're
going to be working with cross under
tensorflow we go back to home i've gone
up here to application and that's the
environment i've loaded on here and then
we'll click on the launch jupiter
notebook now i've already in my jupiter
notebook
have set up a lot of stuff so that we're
ready to go kind of like martha
stewart's in the old cooking show so we
want to make sure we have all our tools
for you so you're not waiting for them
to load and if we go up here to where it
says new you can see where you can
create a new python 3. that's what we
did here underneath the setup so it
already has all the modules installed on
it and i'm actually renamed this if you
go under file you can rename it we've
i'm calling it rnn stock and let's just
take a look and start diving into the
code let's get into the exciting part
now we've looked at the tool and of
course you might be using a different
tool which is fine let's start putting
that code in there and seeing what those
imports and uploading everything looks
like now first half is kind of boring
when we hit the run button because we're
going to be importing numpy as np that's
uh the number python which is your numpy
array and the matplot library because
we're going to do some plotting at the
end and our pandas for our data set our
pandas is pd and when i hit run it
really doesn't do anything except for
load those modules just a quick note let
me just do a quick draw here oops shift
alt there we go you'll notice when we're
doing this setup if i was to divide this
up oops i'm going to actually let's
overlap these here we go
this first part that we're going to do
is
our data
prep
a lot of prepping involved
in fact depending on what your system is
since we're using karass i put an
overlap here uh but you'll find that
almost
maybe even half of the code we do is all
about the data prep and the reason i
overlapped this with uh cross let me
just put that down because that's what
we're working in uh is because cross has
like their own preset stuff so it's
already pre-built in which is really
nice so there's a couple steps a lot of
times that are in the kara setup uh
we'll take a look at that to see what
comes up in our code as we go through
and look at stock and the last part is
to evaluate and if you're working with
shareholders or
classroom whatever it is you're working
with the evaluate is the next biggest
piece
so the actual code here crossed is a
little bit more but when you're working
with some of the other packages you
might have like three lines that might
be it all your stuff is in your
pre-processing and your data since cross
has is is cutting edge and you load the
individual layers you'll see that
there's a few more lines here and
crosses a little bit more robust and
then you spend a lot of times like i
said with the evaluate you want to have
something you present to everybody else
and say hey this is what i did this is
what it looks like so let's go through
those steps this is like a kind of just
general overview and let's just take a
look and see what the next set of code
looks like and in here we have a data
set train and it's going to be read
using the pd or pandas dot read csv and
it's a google googlestockpricetrain.csv
and so under this we have training set
equals dataset train dot ilocation and
we've kind of sorted out part of that so
what's going on here let's just take a
look at let's look at the actual file
and see what's going on there now if we
look at this
ignore all the extra files on this i
already have a train and a test set
where it's sorted out this is important
to notice because a lot of times we do
that as part of the pre-processing of
the data we take 20 percent of the data
out so we can test it and then we train
the rest of it that's what we use to
create our neural network that way we
can find out how good it is uh but let's
go ahead and just take a look and see
what that looks like as far as the file
itself and i went ahead and just opened
this up in a basic word pad and text
editor just so we can take a look at it
certainly you can open up an excel or
any other kind of spreadsheet
and we note that this is a comma
separated variables we have a date uh
open high low close volume this is the
standard stuff that we import into our
stock or the most basic set of
information you can look at in stock
it's all free to download in this case
we downloaded it from google that's why
we called the google stock price
and specifically is google this is the
google stock values from as you can see
here we started off at 1 3 2012.
so when we look at this first setup up
here
we have a data set train equals pd
underscore csv and if you noticed on the
original frame
let me just go back there
they had it set to home ubuntu downloads
google stock price train i went ahead
and changed that because we're in the
same file where i'm running the code so
i've saved this particular python code
and i don't need to go through any
special paths or have the full path on
there and then of course we want to take
out
certain values in here and you're going
to notice that we're using our data set
and we're now in pandas
so pandas basically it looks like a
spreadsheet
and in this case we're going to do eye
location which is going to get specific
locations the first value is going to
show us that we're pulling all the rows
in the data and the second one is we're
only going to look at columns 1 and 2.
and if you remember here from our data
as we switch back on over columns we saw
we start with zero which is the date
and we're going to be looking at open
and high which would be one and two
we'll just label that right there so you
can see now
when you go back and do this you
certainly can extrapolate and do this on
all the columns
but for the example let's just limit a
little bit here so that we can focus on
just some
key aspects of stock
and then we'll go up here and run the
code and again i said the first half is
very boring whenever we hit the run
button it doesn't do anything because
we're still just loading the data and
setting it up
now that we've loaded our data we want
to go ahead and scale it we want to do
what they call feature
scaling and in here we're going to pull
it up from the sk learn or the sk kit
pre-processing import min max scaler and
when you look at this you got to
remember that biases in our data we want
to get rid of that so if you have
something that's like a really high
value let's just draw a quick graph
and i have something here like the maybe
the stock has a value one stock has a
value of a hundred and another stock has
a value of five
you start to get a bias between
different stocks and so when we do this
we go ahead and say okay 100 is going to
be the max
and 5 is going to be the min
and then everything else goes and then
we change this so we just squish it down
i like the word squish so it's between 1
and 0. so 100 equals 1 or 1 equals 100
and 0 equals 5. and you can just
multiply it's usually just a simple
multiplication we're using uh
multiplication so it's going to be minus
5 and then 100 divided or 95 divided by
one so or whatever value is is divided
by 95.
and once we've actually created our
scale we've tolling is going to be from
zero to one we want to take our training
set and we're going to create a training
set scaled and we're going to use our
scalar sc we're going to fit we're going
to fit and transform the training set
so we can now use the sc this this
particular object will use it later on
our testing set because remember we have
to also scale that when we go to test
our model and see how it works and we'll
go ahead and click on the run again it's
not going to have any output yet because
we're just setting up all the variables
all right so we pasted the data in here
and we're going to create the data
structure with the 60 time steps and
output
first note we're running 60 time steps
and that is where this value here also
comes in so the first thing we do is we
create our x train and y train variables
and we set them to an empty python array
very important to remember what kind of
array we're in what we're working with
and then we're going to come in here
we're going to go for i in range 60 to
1258 there's our 60 60 time steps and
the reason we want to do this is as
we're adding the data in there there's
nothing below the 60. so if we're going
to use 60 time steps we have to start at
point 60 because it includes everything
underneath of it otherwise you'll get a
pointer error and then we're going to
take our x train and we're going to
append training set scaled this is a
scaled value between 0 and 1 and then as
i is equal to 60 this value is going to
be
60 minus 60 is 0. so this actually is
0 to i so it's going to be 0 60 1 to 61.
let me just circle this part right here
1 to 61
2 to 62 and so on and so on and if you
remember i said 0 to 60 that's incorrect
because it does not count remember it
starts at 0 so this is a count of 60 so
it's actually 59. important to remember
that as we're looking at this and then
the second part of this that we're
looking at so if you remember correctly
here we go we go from zero to 59 of i
and then we have a comma a zero right
here and so finally we're just going to
look at the open value now i know we did
put it in there for one to two
if you remember correctly it doesn't
count the second one so it's just the
open value we're looking at just open
and then finally we have y train dot
append training set i to zero and if you
remember correctly i2 or i comma zero if
you remember correctly this is zero to
59 so there's 60 values in it so we do i
down here this is number 60. so we're
going to do this is we're creating an
array and we have 0
to 59
and over here we have number 60 which is
going into the y train it's being
appended on there and then this just
goes all the way up so this is down here
is a
0 to 59 and we'll call it 60 since
that's the value over here and it goes
all the way up to 12
58. that's where this value here comes
in that's the length of the data we're
loading
so we've loaded two arrays we've loaded
one array that has uh which is filled
with arrays from 0 to 59 and we loaded
one array which is just the value and
what we're looking at you want to think
about this as a time sequence uh here's
my open open open open open open what's
the next one in the series so we're
looking at the google stock and each
time it opens we want to know what the
next one 0 through 59 what's 60 1
through 60 what's 61 2 through 62 what's
62 and so on and so on going up and then
once we've loaded those in our for loop
we go ahead and take x train and y train
equals
dot np np.arrayxtrain.npray y train
we're just converting this back into a
numpy array that way we can use all the
cool tools that we get with numpy array
including reshaping so if we take a look
and see what's going on here we're going
to take our x train
we're going to reshape it
wow what the heck does reshape mean uh
that means we have an array if you
remember correctly um so many numbers by
60.
that's how wide it is
and so we're when you when you do x
train dot shape that gets one of the
shapes and you get um x train dot shape
of one gets the other shape and we're
just making sure the data is formatted
correctly and so you use this to pull
the fact that it's 60 by um
in this case where's that value
60 pi
1199 1258 minus 60 11.99 and we're
making sure that that is shaped
correctly so the data is grouped into
11 99 by 60 different arrays and then
the one on the end just means at the end
because this when you're dealing with
shapes and numpy they look at this as
layers and so the in layer
needs to be one value that's like the
leaf of a tree where this is the branch
and then it branches out some more
and then you get the leaf np dot reshape
comes from and using the existing shapes
to form it we'll go ahead and run this
piece of code again there's no real
output and then we'll import our
different cross modules that we need so
from cross models we're going to import
the sequential model dealing with
sequential data we have our dense layers
we have actually three layers we're
going to bring in our dents our lstm
which is what we're focusing on and our
drop out and we'll discuss these three
layers more in just a moment but you do
need the with the lstm you do need the
dropout and then the final layer will be
the dents but let's go ahead and run
this and they'll bring port our modules
and you'll see we get an error on here
and if you read it closer it's not
actually an error it's a warning what
does this warning mean these things come
up all the time when you're working with
such cutting edge modules are complete
being updated all the time we're not
going to worry too much about the
warning all it's saying is that the h5py
module which is part of cross is going
to be updated at some point and if
you're running new stuff on cross and
you start updating your cross system you
better make sure that your h5 pi is
updated too otherwise you're going to
have an error later on and you can
actually just run an update on the h5 pi
now if you wanted to not a big deal
we're not going to worry about that
today and i said we were going to jump
in and start looking at what those
layers mean i meant that and we're going
to start off with initializing the rnn
and then we'll start adding those layers
in and you'll see that we have the lstm
and then the dropout lstm then dropout
lstm then dropout what the heck is that
doing so let's explore that we'll start
by initializing the rnn regressor equals
sequential because we're using the
sequential model and we'll run that and
load that up and then we're going to
start adding our lstm layer and some
dropout regularization and right there
should be the q dropout regularization
and if we go back here and remember our
exploding gradient well that's what
we're talking about the dropout drops
out unnecessary data so we're not just
shifting huge amounts of data through
the network so and so we go in here
let's just go ahead and add this in i'll
go ahead and run this and we had three
of them so let me go ahead and put all
three of them in and then we can go back
over them there's the second one and
let's put one more in let's put that in
and we'll go ahead and put two more in i
mean i said one more end but it's
actually two more in and then let's add
one more after that and as you can see
each time i run these they don't
actually have an output so let's take a
closer look and see what's going on here
so we're going to add our first lstm
layer in here we're going to have units
50. the units is the positive integer
and it's the dimensionality of the
output space this is what's going out
into the next layer so we might have 60
coming in but we have 50 going out we
have a return sequence because it is a
sequence data so we want to keep that
true and then you have to tell it what
shape it's in well we already know the
shape by just going in here and looking
at x train shape so input shape equals
the x train shape of one comma one makes
it really easy you don't have to
remember all the numbers that put in 60
or whatever else is in there you just
let it tell the regressor what model to
use and so we follow our stm with a
dropout layer now understanding the
dropout layer is kind of exciting
because one of the things that happens
is we can over train our network that
means that our neural network will
memorize such specific data that it has
trouble predicting anything that's not
in that specific realm to fix for that
each time we run through the training
mode we're going to take point two or
twenty percent of our neurons and just
turn them off so we're only gonna train
on the other ones and it's going to be
random that way each time we pass
through this we don't over train these
nodes come back in in the next training
cycle we randomly pick a different 20.
and finally i see a big difference as we
go from the first to the second and
third and fourth the first thing is we
don't have to input the shape because
the shapes already the output units is
50 here this item the next step
automatically knows this layer is
putting out 50 and because it's the next
layer it automatically sets that and
says so 50 is coming out from our last
layer that's coming up you know goes
into the regressor and of course we have
our dropout and that's what's coming
into this one and so on and so on and so
the next three layers we don't have to
let it know what the shape is it
automatically understands that and we're
going to keep the units the same we're
still going to do 50 units it's still a
sequence coming through 50 units and a
sequence now the next piece of code is
what brings it all together let's go
ahead and take a look at that and we
come in here we put the output layer the
dense layer and if you remember up here
we had the three layers we had lstm
dropout and dents dense just says we're
going to bring this all down into one
output instead of putting out a sequence
we just know i want to know the answer
at this point and let's go ahead and run
that and so in here you notice all we're
doing is setting things up one step at a
time so far we've brought in our way up
here we brought in our data we bought in
our different modules we formatted the
data for training it we set it up you
know we have our y x train and our y
train we have our source of data and the
answers where we know so far that we're
going to put in there we've reshaped
that we've come in and built our cross
we've imported our different layers and
we have in here if you look we have what
five total layers now cross is a little
different than a lot of other systems a
lot of other systems put this all in one
line and do it automatic but they don't
give you the options of how those layers
interface and they don't give you the
options of how the data comes in cross
is cutting edge for this reason so even
though there's a lot of extra steps in
building the model this has a huge
impact on the output and what we can do
with this these new models from keras so
we brought in our dense we have our full
model put together a regressor so we
need to go ahead and compile it and then
we're going to go ahead and fit the data
we're going to compile the pieces so
they all come together and then we're
going to run our training data on there
and actually recreate our regressor so
it's ready to be used so let's go ahead
and compile that and i'd go ahead and
run that and if you've been looking at
any of our other tutorials on neural
networks you'll see we're going to use
the optimizer atom atom is optimized for
big data there's a couple other
optimizers out there beyond the scope of
this tutorial but certainly atom will
work pretty good for this and loss
equals mean squared value so when we're
training it this is what we want to base
the loss on how bad is our error we're
going to use the mean squared value for
our error and the atom optimizer for its
differential equations you don't have to
know the math behind them but certainly
it helps to know what they're doing and
where they fit into the bigger models
and then finally we're going to do our
fit fitting the rn into the training set
we have the
dot fit x train y train epochs and batch
size so we know where this is this is
our data coming in for the x train our y
train is the answer we're looking for of
our data our sequential input epics is
how many times we're going to go over
the whole data set we created a whole
data set of x trains so this is each
each of those rows which includes a time
sequence of 60. and bad size another one
of those things where cross really
shines is if you were pulling the save
from a large file instead of trying to
load it all into ram it can now pick
smaller batches up and load those
indirectly we're not worried about
pulling them off a file today because
this isn't big enough to cause a
computer too much of a problem to run
not too straining on the resources but
as we run this you can imagine what
happened if i was doing a lot more than
just one column in one set of stock in
this case google stock imagine if i was
doing this across all the stocks and i
had instead of just the open i had open
close high low and you can actually find
yourself with about 13 different
variables times 60 because there's a
time sequence suddenly you find yourself
with a gig of memory you're loading into
your ram which will just completely you
know if it's just if you're not on
multiple computers or cluster you're
going to start running into resource
problems but for this we don't have to
worry about that so let's go ahead and
run this and this will actually take a
little bit on my computer it's an older
laptop and give a second to kick in
there there we go all right so we have
epic so this is going to tell me it's
running the first run through all the
data and as it's going through it's
batching them in 32 pieces so 32 lines
each time and there's 1198 i think i
said 11.99 earlier but it's 11.98 i was
off by one and each one of these is 13
seconds so you can imagine this is
roughly 20 to 30 minutes run time on
this computer like i said it's an older
laptop running at 0.9 gigahertz on a
dual processor and that's fine what
we'll do is i'll go ahead and stop go
get a drink of coffee and come back and
let's see what happens at the end and
where this takes us and like any good
cooking show
i've kind of gotten my latte i also have
some other stuff running in the
background so you'll see these numbers
jumped up to like 19 seconds 15 seconds
but you can scroll through you can see
we've run it through 100 steps or 100
epics so the question is what does all
this mean one of the first things you'll
notice is that our loss can is over here
it kind of stopped at 0.0014 but you can
see it kind of goes down until we hit
about 0.014 three times in a row so we
guessed our epic pretty close since our
losses remain the same on there so to
find out we're looking at we're going to
go ahead and load up our test data the
test data that we didn't process yet and
a real stock price data set test eye
location this is the same thing we did
it when we prepped the data in the first
place so let's go ahead and go through
this code and we can see we've labeled
it part three making the predictions and
visualizing the results so the first
thing we need to do is go ahead and read
the data in from our test csv you see
i've changed the path on it for my
computer and then we'll call it the real
stock price and again we're doing just
the one column here and the values from
i location so it's all the rows and just
the values from these that one location
that's the open stock open let's go
ahead and run that so that's loaded in
there and then let's go ahead and create
we have our inputs we're going to create
inputs here and this would all look
familiar because this is the same thing
we did before we're going to take our
data set total we're going to do a
little panda concat from the datastate
train now remember the end of the
dataset train is part of the data going
in let's just visualize that just a
little bit here's our train data let me
just put tr for train and it went up to
this value here but each one of these
values generated a bunch of columns it
was 60 across and this value here equals
this one and this value here equals this
one and this value here equals this one
and so we need these top 60 to go into
our new data so to find out what we're
looking at we're going to go ahead and
load up our test data the test data that
we didn't process yet and a real stock
price data set test eye location this is
the same thing we did it when we prep
the data in the first place so let's go
ahead and go through this code and we
can see we've labeled it uh part three
making the predictions and visualizing
the results so the first thing we need
to do is go ahead and read the data in
from our test csv you see i've changed
the path on it for my computer and then
we'll call it the real stock price and
again we're doing just the one column
here and the values from i location so
it's all the rows and just the values
from these that one location that's the
open stock open let's go ahead and run
that so that's loaded in there and then
let's go ahead and create we have our
inputs we're going to create inputs here
and this should all look familiar
because this is the same thing we did
before we're going to take our data set
total we're going to do a little panda
concat from the data state train now
remember the end of the data set train
is part of the data going in let's just
visualize that just a little bit here's
our train data let me just put tr for
train and it went up to this value here
but each one of these values generated a
bunch of columns it was 60 across and
this value here equals this one and this
value here equals this one and this
value here equals this one and so we
need these top 60 to go into our new
data because that's part of the next
data or it's actually the top 59. so
that's what this first setup is over
here is we're going in we're doing the
real stock price and we're going to just
take the data set test and we're going
to load that in and then the real stock
price is our data test.test location so
we're just looking at that first column
the open price and then our data set
total we're going to take pandas and
we're going to concat and we're going to
take our data set train for the open and
our dataset test open and this is one
way you can reference these columns
we've referenced them a couple different
ways we've referenced them up here with
the one two but we know it's labeled as
a panda set as open so pandas is great
that way lots of versatility there and
we'll go ahead and go back up here and
run this there we go and you'll notice
this is the same as what we did before
we have our open data set where pended
our two different or concatenated our
two data sets together we have our
inputs equals data set total length data
set total minus length data set minus
test minus 60 values so we're going to
run this over all of them and you'll see
why this works because normally when
you're running your test set versus your
training set you run them completely
separate but when we graph this you'll
see that we're just going to be we'll be
looking at the part that we didn't train
it with to see how well it graphs and we
have our inputs equals inputs dot
reshapes or reshaping like we did before
we're transforming our inputs so if you
remember from the transform between zero
and one and uh finally we want to go
ahead and take our x test and we're
going to create that x test and for i in
range 60 to 80. so here's our x test and
we're appending our inputs i to 60 which
remember is 0 to 59 and i comma 0 on the
other side so it's just the first column
which is our open column and once again
we take our x test we convert it to a
numpy array we do the same reshape we
did before and then we get down to the
final two lines and here we have
something new right here on these last
two lines let me just highlight those or
or mark them predicted stock price
equals regressor dot predicts x test so
we're predicting all the stock including
both the training and the testing model
here and then we want to take this
prediction and we want to inverse the
transform so remember we put it between
zero and one well that's not going to
mean very much to me to look at a float
number between 001 i want the dollar
amount so i want to know what the cash
value is and we'll go ahead and run this
and you'll see it runs much quicker than
the training that's what's so wonderful
about these neural networks once you put
them together it takes just a second to
run the same neural network that took us
what a half hour to train add and plot
the data we're going to plot what we
think it's going to be and we're going
to plot it against the real data what
the google stock actually did so let's
go ahead and take a look at that in code
and let's uh pull this code up so we
have our plt that's our oh if you
remember from the very beginning let me
just go back up to the top we have our
matplot library.piplot as plt that's
where that comes in and we come down
here we're going to plot let me get my
drawing thing out again we're going to
go ahead and plt is basically kind of
like an object it's one of the things
that always threw me when i'm doing
graphs in python because i always think
you have to create an object and then it
loads that class in there well in this
case plt is like a canvas you're putting
stuff on so if you've done html5 you'll
have the canvas object this is the
canvas so we're going to plot the real
stock price that's what it actually is
and we're going to give that color red
so it's going to be in bright red we're
going to label it real google stock
price and then we're going to do our
predicted stock and we're going to do it
in blue and it's going to be labeled
predicted and we'll give it a title
because it's always nice to give a title
to your graph especially if you're going
to present this to somebody you know to
your shareholders in the office and uh
the x label is going to be time because
it's a time series and we didn't
actually put the actual date and times
on here but that's fine we just know
they're incremented by time and then of
course the y label is the actual stock
price
plt.legend tells us to build the legend
on here so that the color red and real
google stock price show up on there and
then the plot shows us that actual graph
so let's go ahead and run this and see
what that looks like and you can see
here we have a nice graph and let's talk
just a little bit about this graph
before we wrap it up here's our legend i
was telling you about that's why we have
the legend to show the prices we have
our title and everything and you'll
notice on the bottom we have a time
sequence we didn't put the actual time
in here now we could have we could have
gone ahead and
plotted the x since we know what the
dates are and plotted this to dates but
we also know that it's only the last
piece of data that we're looking at so
last piece of data which in somewhere
probably around here on the graph i
think it's like about 20 of the data
probably less than that we have the
google price and the google price has
this little up jump and then down and
you'll see that the actual google
instead of a turn down here just didn't
go up as high and didn't go
down so our prediction has the same
pattern but the overall value is pretty
far off as far as um stock but then
again we're only looking at one column
we're only looking at the open price
we're not looking at how many volumes
were traded like i was pointing out
earlier we talk about stock just right
off the bat there's six columns there's
open high low close volume then there's
weather i mean volume shares then
there's the adjusted open adjusted high
adjusted low adjusted close they have a
special formula to predict exactly what
it would really be worth based on the
value of the stock and then from there
there's all kinds of other stuff you can
put in here so we're only looking at one
small aspect the opening price of the
stock and as you can see here we did a
pretty good job this curve follows the
curve pretty well it has like a little
jumps on it bins they don't quite match
up so this bin here does not quite match
up with that bin there but it's pretty
darn close we have the basic shape of it
and the prediction isn't too far off and
you can imagine that as we add more data
in and look at different aspects in the
specific domain of stock we should be
able to get a better representation each
time we drill in deeper of course this
took a half hour for my program my
computer to train so you can imagine
that if i was running it across all
those different variables it might take
a little bit longer to train the data in
today's exciting world of ai artificial
intelligence we're going to cover some
of the many uses it's being applied to
healthcare entertainment composing music
image coloring robotics image captioning
advertising earthquake prediction and
there's many more it's just an exciting
time to be in the field of ai and deep
learning and artificial intelligence now
all these fields are just booming it's
just amazing what's going on so let's
take a quick glance at some of the
things going on and we'll start with our
healthcare we take a look at healthcare
deep learning is reshaping healthcare
industry by delivering new possibilities
to improve people's lives and we have
computer aided disease detection i know
a number of startups have come up where
they're working on you take a picture
like if you have some kind of irritation
or rash and they use that or even you
know some infection in the eye and they
use the deep learning to help identify
what it is hey this is um 99.99
nothing don't worry about it or this is
93 chance um it usually doesn't come out
93 chance if you do deep learning but it
says hey you know you should probably
take this into the doctor you know have
them take a look at it and see what it
is these are the things that could be
analyzing genomes that's a big one very
controversial nowadays with all the
different genome editing and options
they have and things they're doing but
deep learning is definitely diving into
the genome projects we have discovering
new drugs and this there's so many
directions for new drugs going on it's
like one of the booming industries
especially in the us but all across the
world and they range from
exploring different plants and the
opening up of let's say marijuana in the
u.s a number of cities are exploring
that for medical use to how do you
reprogram t cells in the human body to
combat disease there's whole industries
in data analysis another one is
chemistry how do you use a chemical cell
or a chemistry molecule not cell a
chemical molecule to imitate the t cell
so you can then put those molecules in
there and then they grab the diseased
cells out or the cancer cells or
whatever out just like the human body
would so discovering new drugs and how
to apply that is just a huge industry
all these are huge industries and
medical imaging we'll even take a glance
closer at that but being able to analyze
you know you get your mri you get your
cat scans the doctors can spend a long
time looking at those and taking careful
measurements and most of that's done by
hand but as we start applying deep
learning the deep learning can do a lot
of that work not only do it the same but
it'll be uniform from one hospital to
the next meaning that as a industry it
continues to progress and you get better
results and better services so deep
learning is reshaping healthcare
industry by delivering new possibilities
to improve people's life and deep
learning helps in early detection of
cancer cells and tumors improves a
time-consuming process of synthesizing
new drugs and inverse sophisticated
medical instruments and not even
sophisticated they're using iphones and
deep learning to help with medical
diagnosis so it's at all levels it's
just amazing what they're doing in the
healthcare industry with deep learning
and they've just barely tapped what
there's possible they're just now
evolving into the beginning of this
where it's exploding out there so
entertainment uh that's always a fun one
a lot of people go into the
entertainment and deep learning because
it's just fun you know what's my
favorite movie
all that fun stuff deep learning is used
in the entertainment industry such as
netflix amazon and filmmaking and you
have like your recommendations that's
probably the most common one you see and
you can see here where they have india
transform the true story the third
pillar now markets in the state leave so
it comes up and says hey this is based
on whoever and of course this is showing
up on amazon or amazon prime netflix
does a good job of grouping movies for
you and says since you like these movies
you might like these movies over here
same thing with vivo it does that also
amazon netflix and vivo use recommender
systems to provide personalized
experience to its viewers using their
show preferences time of access history
etc so really this is one of the cool
things is instead of having to dig for
the information deep learning starts
doing that for you so instead of
spending hours trying to figure out what
you want to watch you can actually just
enjoy the movies and have them come up
deep learning is used in the
entertainment industry such as netflix
amazon and filmmaking continue on in
deep learning we have things like the
ibm watson this is just really cool i
didn't know this till i read this until
we did this slide wimbledon 2018 used
ibm watson to analyze player emotions
and expressions through hundreds of
hours of footage then it auto-generated
highlights for the telecast so you can
imagine somebody sitting there looking
through all the boring stuff i want to
look at the interesting stuff it helps
us sort that out again you know just
like the netflix and referral it helps
you find your choices without having to
do all the heavy work of digging through
really bad b rated movies and music and
audio generation another huge part of
the industry and this kind of blends
right in with video and movie making
voice and audio recognition technology
can be used to train deep learning
network to produce music compositions so
it learns the patterns and generates new
music google's wavenet and beidou's deep
speech can train a computer to learn the
patterns and the statistics that are
unique to the music it can then generate
a complete new composition that's a
little scary i always thought that
creativity would always be the human
factor that we would always have our
creativity but you know computers can do
some of that too and then we have our
reed's lip movements oxford and google
scientists created a neural network
called lipnet that could read people's
lips with 93 success this can be used to
add sounds to silent movies i like that
it'd be fun to hear what they actually
were saying back there they probably
said something totally different than
what's actually on the movie that'd be
pretty funny on the scary note this
would allow surveillance equipment to
pull what people are saying even if
they're really far away as long as they
can see the lips that's a little scary
coloring images and videos deep learning
can be used to color images and videos
by taking the objects in their context
within the photograph so you have your
black and white images fed in and you
have a convolutional neural network is
used to learn the patterns and usually
you train it you train it with hundreds
of black and white photos that you
already have the color image for so you
know what to expect and you take the new
one and it recreates the image by adding
the colors and this is also used in the
movie industry to add in special effects
there's all kinds of cool things it can
do with this it goes way beyond just
coloring pictures of course the coloring
pictures is something that you can
probably do in your own lab on your own
computer and build your own neural
network to do that robotics one of my
favorites robotics all these tools that
make them so exciting is that you can go
out and even now used to be you'd have
to spend four five six ten thousand us
dollars to buy your own robot and then
start programming it and doing neural
networks now it's around two thousand
dollars and that continues to plummet uh
there's even kid robots much cheaper
robotic hands all of that that you can
purchase and generate your own neural
network and start trying to figure out
how to get it to do things and so we
talk about deep learning it's heavily
used these days in building robots to
perform human-like tasks robots are
built to understand the world around
them very important how to figure out
what's what i remember if you go back 20
years they could not get a robot to
figure out the difference between a coke
can and a pencil because they're both
cylinders and they just they just had no
idea how to do that back then you know
they did the beginning of robotics
really the neural networks was mid-90s
where it started really taking off and
the theory started coming in and so you
go back to that time and and figuring
out those differences was almost
impossible before then and they trained
to make better and safer decisions
without supervision and you can see in
this case you know in outer space having
a robot up there uh you know if the
window blows out air pressure is lost
the robot is you know not going to be
hurt by it because they don't need air
and oxygen and their decisions usually
instead of being like a human's tired in
this case the robot never is tired so
you know there's definitely a lot of
tasks for a robot that can be used to
replace humans it would be safer think
uh nuclear reactors that melted down
after the tsunami in japan using
robotics to go in there and clean up
would be really important instead of
putting a person in a hazmat suit that
might or might not protect him from the
radiation in boston dynamics we have uh
spot mini he's fun to watch if you pull
up the video or the atlas robots by
boston dynamics react to people pushing
them around get up when they fall can
unload a dishwasher and do other tasks
as well so we're starting to see this
kind of robotics coming into the house
the atlas obviously is a very expensive
robot but there is certainly more common
ones you can actually bring into the
house and then spot mini is fun to watch
run you can i forget how fast he goes
but he goes pretty fast image caption
generation another part of the industry
in deep learning deep learning is used
to display the contents of an image i
love this with my google photos the
system is trained with very large
convolutional neural networks for
detecting objects in the photographs and
then a recurring neural network like an
lstm is used to turn the labels into
coherent sentence dog catching a ball so
this is awesome this is like you go into
your google photos and you say hey i
want all the pictures of my dog or i
want all the pictures of kids or
whatever it is and they get to the point
we can now do i want pictures where my
dog is catching the ball advertising one
of the better paid fields in ai is in
marketing and advertising especially if
you are working on bonuses and
commission so advertising and
advertising deep learning allows
optimizing a user's experience so deep
learning helps publishers and
advertisers to increase the relevancy of
the ads and boost the advertising
campaigns allows a network to reduce
costs by dropping the cost per
acquisition of a campaign from sixty to
thirty dollars create data data-driven
predictive advertising real-time bidding
of their ads and target display
advertising and again this goes uh from
experimental where i'm just going to
guess what people want and we'll put out
a pink sign that says
you want to add on widget to your order
well nobody wants widgets and nobody
wants to see the pink sign maybe you got
three people want to see the pink sign
and you find out that the blue sign a
lot of people are reading that and they
really want a widget number two whatever
that is uh so when you talk about
advertising it also deals with marketing
and also uh preference of merchandise so
it becomes really huge as far as what
you're advertising and generating profit
and sells for a company and that's
across the board whether you're talking
big real estate or property management
and rentals or
amazon uses this for all their
merchandise coming out of their
warehouses any of those are generated
from the ai generates more sales and
that's the bottom dollar business is
always looking at the bottom dollar
where can i make money on this
earthquake prediction so now we're
getting to something safety human safety
you can also think weather predictions
all those fun things deep learning model
can be used to predict earthquakes by
considering a factor called von mice's
yield criterion scientists at harvard
use deep learning to teach a computer
perform viscoelastic computations that
is quite the mouthful which are used in
prediction of earthquakes this
application helped to improve the
earthquake calculation by 50 000 percent
that's amazing we went from just
guessing when an earthquake is going to
happen where we have almost no
reliability to being able to have a
decent guess as when the earthquakes are
going to hit today we're going to help
you prepare for interview questions
dealing with deep learning and we're
going to go from the very basics of
neural networks and deep learning into
some of the more commonly used models so
you can have an understanding of what
kind of questions are going to come up
and what you need to know in interview
questions we'll start with a very
general concept of what is deep learning
this is where we take large volumes of
data in this case on cats and dogs or
whatever a lot of times you use
a training setup to train your model
remember it's kind of like a magic black
box going on there then we use that to
extract features or extract information
and in this case classify the image of a
cat and a dog so the primary takeaway
we're talking about deep learning is it
learns from large volumes of structured
and even unstructured data and uses
complex algorithms to train neural
network it also performs complex
operations to extract hidden patterns
and features and if we're going to
discuss deep learning in this very
simplified overview and we also have to
go over what is a neural network this is
a common image you'll see of a drawing
of a forward propagation neural network
and it's it's a human brain
system which replicates the way humans
learn so this is inspired how our own
neurons and our brain fire but at a much
simplified level obviously it's not
ready to take over the human uh
population and be our leader yet not for
many years it's very much in its infant
stage but it's inspired by how our
brains work
and they use a lot of other inspirations
you can study brains of moths and other
animals that they've used to figure out
how to improve these neural networks the
most common one consists of three layers
of network and this is generally how you
view these networks is you have an input
you have a hidden layer and an output
and the neural network is uh broken up
into many pieces but we focus just on
the neural network it's always on the
hidden layers that we're making all the
adjustments and figuring out how to best
set up those hidden layers for their
functions to both train faster and to
function better when we look at this of
course we have our input hidden and
output each layer contains neurons
called as nodes perform various
operations and you can see here we have
the list of the nodes we have both our
input nodes and our output nodes and
then our hidden layer nodes and it's
used in deep learning algorithm like cnn
rnn jn etc we'll address some of these
models a little closer at least the most
common models as we go down the list and
we study the deep learning and the
neural network framework
let's start with what is a multi-layer
perceptron or mlp a lot of time is
referred to and you'll see these
abbreviations i'll be honest i have to
write them down on a piece of paper and
go through them because i never remember
what they all mean even though i play
with them all the time what is a
multi-layer perceptron well if you look
at the image on the right it's very
similar to what we just looked at you
have your input layer your hidden layer
and your output layer and that's exactly
what this is it has the same structure
of a single layer perceptron with one or
more hidden layers except the input
layer each node in the other layers uses
a non-linear activation function what
that means is your input layers your
data coming in and then your activation
function is based upon all those nodes
and weights being added together and
then it has the output mlp uses
supervised learning method called back
propagation for training the model very
key word there is back propagation
single layer perceptron can classify
only linear separable classes with
binary output 0 1 but the mlp can
classify non-linear classes so let's
break this down just a little bit the
multi-layer perceptron with an input
layer and a hidden layer and an output
layer as you see that it comes in there
it has adds up all the numbers and
weights depending on how your setup is
that then goes to the next layer that
then goes to the next hidden layer if
you have multiple hidden layers and
finally to the output layer the back
propagation takes the error that it sees
so whatever the output is it says hey
this has an error to it it's wrong and
it sends that error backwards from where
it came from and there's a lot of
different functions used to uh train
this based on that error and how that
error goes backwards in the notes so
forward is you get your answers backward
is for training you see this every day
even my
google pixel phone has this it they
train the neural network which takes a
lot more data to train than it does to
use and then they load up that neural
network into in this case i have a pixel
2 which actually has a built-in neural
network for processing pictures and so
it's just a forward propagation i use
when it processes my photos but when
they were training it used a back
propagation to train it with the errors
they had we'll be coming back to
different models that are used for right
now though multi-layer perceptron mlp
put that down as your vocabulary word
and of course back propagation what is
data normalization and why do we need it
this is so important we spend so much
time in normalizing our data and getting
our data clean and setting it up so we
talk about data there's a pre-processing
step to standardize the data so whatever
we have coming in we don't want it to be
a
one gigabyte file here a two gigabyte
picture here and a three kilobyte text
there even as a human i can't process
those all in the same group i have to
reformat them in some way that loops
them together so the standardized format
we use this uh data normalization in
pre-processing to reduce it and
eliminate data redundancy a lot of times
the data comes in and you end up with
two of the same images or
the same information in different
formats then we want to rescale values
to fit into a particular range for
achieving better convergence what this
means is with most neural networks they
form a bias we've seen this in recently
in attacks on neural networks where they
light up one pixel or one piece of the
view and it skews the whole answer so
suddenly
because one pixel is really bright uh it
doesn't know what to do but when we
start rescaling it we put all the values
between say minus one and one and we
change them and refit them to those
values it helps get rid of that bias
helps fix for some of those problems and
then finally we restructure the data and
improve the integrity we want to make
sure that we're not missing values or we
don't have partial data coming in one
way to look at this is uh bad data in
bad data out
so we want clean data in and you want
good answers coming out one of the most
basic models used is a boltzmann machine
so let's address what is a boltzmann
machine and if you know we just did the
mlp multi-layer perceptron so now we're
going to come into almost a simplified
version of that and in this we have our
visible input layer and we have our
hidden layer the boltzmann machines are
almost always shallow they're usually
just two layer neural nets that make
stochastic decisions whether a neuron
should be on or off true false yes no
first layer is a visible layer and
second layer is the hidden layer nodes
are connected to each other across
layers but no two nodes of the same
layer are connected hence it is also
known as restricted boltzmann machine
now that we've covered a basic mlp or
multi-layer perceptron and we've gone
over the boltzmann machine also known as
the restricted boltzmann machine let's
talk a little bit about activation
formulas and this is a huge topic that
can get really complicated but it also
is automated so it's very simple so you
have both a complicated and a simple at
the same time so what is the role of
activation functions in a neural network
activation function decides whether a
neuron should be fired or not that's the
most basic one and that actually changes
a little bit because it's either whether
fired or not in this case activation
function or what value should come out
when it's fired but in these models
we're looking at just the boltzmann
restricted layers so this is what causes
them to fire either they don't or they
do it's a yes or no true false all or
nothing it accepts the weighted sum of
the inputs the bias as input to any
activation function so whatever
activation function is it needs to have
the sum of the weights times the input
so each input if you remember on that
model and let's just go back to that
model real quick and then you always
have to add a bias and you can look at
the bias if you remember from your
euclidean geometry you draw a straight
line formula for that line has a
y-coordinate at the end it's always
cx plus m or something like that where m
is where it crosses the y-coordinates if
you're doing a straight line with these
weights it's very similar but a lot of
times we just add it in as its own
weight we take it as a node of a one
value coming in and then we compute its
new weight and that's how we compute
that bias just like we compute all the
other weights coming in the node which
gets fires depends on the y value and
then we have a step function in the step
function this is where remember i said
is going to get complicated and simple
all at the same time we have a lot of
different step functions we have the
sigmoid function we have just the
standard step function we have the relu
it's pronounced like rey the
from the sun and lu like a name so relu
function and we have the tangent h
function and if you look at these they
all have something similar they all
either force it to be
one value or the other they force it to
be in the case of the first three is
zero or one and in the last one it's
either a minus one or a one and you can
easily convert that to a zero one yes no
true false and on this one of the most
common ones is the step function itself
because there is no middle value there
is no um discrepancy that says well i'm
not quite sure but as you get into
different models probably the most
commonly used used to be the sigmoid was
most commonly used but i see the relu
used more often really depending on what
you're doing you just have to play with
these and find out which one works best
depending on the data and your output
the reason to have a non zero one answer
or something kind of in the middle is
when you're looking at this and it's
coming out you can actually process that
middle ground as part of the answer into
another neural network so it might be
that the relu function says hey this is
only a 0.6 not a 1. and even though the
1 is what's going into the next neural
network or the next hidden layer as an
input the 0.6 value might also be going
in there to let you know hey this is not
a straight up 1 or straight up 0 is
someplace in the middle this is a little
uncertain what's coming out here so it's
a very powerful tool but the basic
neural network you usually just use the
step function it's yes or no let's take
a a big step back and take a kind of an
overview the next function is what is a
cost function that we're going to cover
this is so important because this is
your end result that you're going to do
over and over again and use to decide
whether the model is working or not
whether you need to try a different step
function whether you need to try a
different activation whether you need to
try a fully different model used so what
is the cost function cost function is
the measure to evaluate how good your
model's performance is it is also
referred as loss or error used to
compute the error of the output layer
during back propagation there's our back
propagation where we're training our
model that's one of our key words mean
squared error is an example of a popular
cost function and so here we have the
cost function c equals half of y minus y
predicted and then you square that so
the first thing is um you know real
quick if you haven't done statistics
this is not a percentage it's not a
percentage of how accurate it is it's
just a measurement of the error and we
take that error for training it and we
push that error backwards through the
neural network and we use that through
the different training functions
depending on what model you're using to
train the neural network so when you
deploy the network you're usually done
training it because it takes a lot of
computational force to train it this is
a very simple model and so you deploy
the trained one but we want to know how
your error is and so how do we do that
well you split your data part of your
data is for trading and part of your
data is for testing and then we can also
test the error on there so it's very
important and then we're going to go one
more step on this we got to look at both
the local and the global setup it might
work great to test your data on what you
have on your computer but that's
different than in the field so when
we're talking about all these different
tests in the error test as far as your
loss you don't you want to make sure
that you're in a closed environment when
you do initial testing but you also want
to open that up and make sure you follow
up with the testing on the larger scale
of data because it will change it might
not fit the larger scale there might be
something in there in the way you
brought the data in specifically or the
data group you used or any of those
could cause an error so it's very
important to remember that we're looking
at both the local and the global context
of our error and just one other side
note on a lot of the newer models of
neural networks by comparing the error
we get on the data our training data
with a portion of the test data we can
actually figure out how good the model
is whether it's overfitted or not we'll
go into that a little bit more as we go
into some of the different models so we
have our output we're able to
figure out the error on it based on the
square means usually although there's
other functions used so we want to talk
about what is gradient descent another
vocabulary word gradient descent is an
optimization algorithm to minimize the
cost function or to minimize the error
aim is to find the local or global
minima of a function determine the
direction the model should take to
reduce the error so as we're looking at
this we have our squared error that we
just figured out the cop based on the
cost function it says how bad is my
model fitting the data i just put
through it and then we want to reduce
that error so how do you figure out what
direction to do that in well it could be
that you're looking at just that line of
that line of data coming in so that
would be a local minima we want to know
the error of that particular setup
coming in and then you have your global
your global minima we want to minimize
it based on the overall data we're
putting through it and with this we can
figure out the global minimum cost we
want to take all those local minimum
cost of each piece of data coming in and
figure out the global one how we're
going to adjust this model to fit all
the data we don't want it to be biased
just on three or four lines of data
coming in we wanted to kind of
extrapolate a general answer for all the
data coming in but this of course we
mentioned it briefly about back
propagation this is where really comes
in handy is training our model neural
network technique to minimize the cost
function helps to improve the
performance of the network back
propagates the error and updates the
weights to reduce the error so as you
can see here is a very nice depiction of
a back propagation we have our
predicted y coming out and then we have
since it's a training set we already
know the answer and the answer comes
back and based on case of square means
was one of the functions we looked at
one of the activation functions based on
cost function that cost function then
depending on what you choose for your
back propagation method and there's a
number of them we'll change the weights
it will change the weight going to each
of the one of those nodes in the hidden
layer and then based upon the error
that's still being carried back it'll
change the it's going to the next hidden
layer and then it computes an error
level on that and sends that back up and
you're going to say well if it computes
the air into the first hidden layer and
fixes it why would it stop there well
remember we don't want to create a
biased neural network so we only make
small adjustments on these weights we
don't make a big adjustment that changes
everything right off the bat so no
matter how far back you go you're always
going to have a small amount of error
and that's still going to continue to go
all the way back up the hidden layers
for right now focus on the back
propagation is taking that error and
moving it backwards on the neural
network to change the weights and help
program it so that it'll have the
correct answers so far we've been
talking about forward propagation neural
networks everything goes forwards goes
left to right but let's just take a
little detour and let's see what is the
difference between a feed-forward neural
network and a recurrent neural network
now this is in the function not when
we're training it using the back
propagation so you've got new
information coming in and you want to
get the answer and there's a couple
different networks out there and we want
to know we have a feed forward neural
network and we have a new vocabulary
term recurrent neural network a feed
forward neural network signals travel in
one direction from input to output no
feedback loops considers only the
current input cannot memorize previous
inputs one example of one of these feed
forward neural networks and we've
covered a number of them but one of the
ones that has a big highlight nowadays
is the cnn a convolutional neural
network tensorflow the one put out by
google is probably most known for their
cnn where the information goes forward
it first takes a picture splits it apart
goes through the individual pixels on
the picture so it picks up a different
reading then calculates based on that
goes into a regular feed forward neural
network and then gives your
categorization on there now we're not
covering the cnn today but we do have a
video out that you can look up on
youtube put out by simply learn the
convolutional neural network wonderful
tutorial check that out and learn a lot
more about the convolutional neural
network but you do need to know that the
cnn is a forward propagation neural
network only so it's only moving in one
direction so we will look at a recurrent
neural network signals travel in both
directions making it a looped network
considers the current input along with
the previous received inputs for
generating the output of a layer has the
ability to memorize past data due to its
internal memory and you can see they
have a nice image here we have our input
and for some reason they always do the
recurrent neural network in reverse from
bottom up in the images kind of a
standard although i'm not sure why your
x goes into your hidden layer and your
hidden layer the answer for part of the
answer from that it generates feeds back
into the hidden layer so now you have an
input of both x and part of the hidden
layer and then that feeds into your
output now if we go back to the forward
let me just go back a slide and we're
looking at
our forward propagation network one of
the tricks you can do to use just a
forward propagation network is if you're
in a what they call a time sequence
that's a good uh term to remember are a
time series meaning that a sequential
data each term comes after the other you
can trick this by creating your input
nodes as with the history so if you know
that you have values 1 5 and 7 going in
and you know what the output is from one
with those outputs are you can expand
the input to include the history input
that's one of the ways to trick a
forward propagation network into looking
at that but when you do with the
recurrent neural network you let the
hidden layer do that for you it sends
that data and reprocesses it back into
itself what are some of the applications
of recurrent neural network the rnn can
be used for sentiment analysis and text
mining getting up early in the morning
is good for health it's a positive
sentiment one of the catches you really
want to look at this when you're looking
at the language is that i could switch
this around and totally negate the
meaning of what i'm doing so would no
longer be positive so when you're
looking at a sentence knowing the order
of the words is as important as the
meaning of the words you can't just
count how many good words there are
versus bad words to get some positive
sentiment you now have to know what
they're addressing and there's lots of
other different uses uh kids are playing
football or soccer as we call it in the
us rn can help you caption an image so
based on previous information coming in
it refeeds that back in and you have a
image setter and then time series
problems like predicting the prices of
stocks in a month or quarter or sell a
product can be solved using an rnn and
this is a really good example you have
whatever your stocks were doing earlier
this month will have a huge effect on
what they're doing today if you're
investing so having an rnn model a
recurrent neural network feeding into
itself what's happening previously
allows it to take that model and program
in the whole series without having to
put in the whole a month at a time of
data you only put in one day at a time
but if you keep them in order it will
look back and say oh this because what
happened yesterday i need some
information from that and i'm going to
use that to help predict today's and so
on and so on we're going to go back to
our activation functions remember i told
you rayleigh was one of the most common
functions used so let's talk a little
bit more about relu and also softmax
softmax is an activation function that
generates the output between 0 and 1. it
divides each output such that the total
sum of the outputs is equal to 1. it is
often used in the output layers soft max
l of the n equals e to l on the n over
the absolute value of e to the l so what
does this function mean i mean what is
actually going on here so we have our
output notes and our output nodes are
giving us let's say they give us 1.2 0.9
and 0.4 as a human being i look at that
and i say well the greatest value is 1.2
so whatever category that is if you have
three different categories maybe you're
not just doing if it's a cat or it's a
dog or oh let's say it's a cow maybe we
had cats and dogs earlier why the cats
and dogs are hanging out with a cow i
don't know but we have a value and it
might say 1.2 is a cat 0.9 is the dog
and .4 is a cow for some reason it
thinks that there's a chance of it being
any one of these three items and that's
how it comes out of the output layer
well as a human i can look at 1.2 and
say this is definitely what it is it's
definitely a cat or whatever it is maybe
it's looking at different kinds of cars
might be a bitter whether it's a car
truck or a motorcycle maybe that'd be a
better example well from a computer
standpoint that might be a little
confusing because they're just numbers
waving at us and so with the soft max we
want all those numbers to always add up
to one so when i add three numbers
together i want the final output to be
one on there and so it goes through this
formula changes each of these numbers in
this case it changes them to 0.46 0.34
and 0.20 they all add up to 1. and
that's a lot easier to register because
it's very set it's a set output it's
never going to be more than one it's
never gonna be less than zero and so you
can see here that there's probably a
pretty high chance that it's the first
one so you're a human being we have no
problem knowing that but this output can
then also go into say another input so
it might be
an automated car that's picking up
images and it says that image in front
of us is probably a big truck we should
deal with it like it's a big truck it's
probably not a motorcycle or whatever
those categories are that's the soft max
part of it but now we have the relu well
what's where's the relu coming from well
the relu is what's generating the 1.2
and the 0.9 and the 0.4 and so if you
remember our relu stands for rectified
linear unit and is the most widely used
activation function we looked at a
number of different activation functions
including tangent h the step function
remember i said the step function is
really used if that's what your actual
output is because then you know it's a
zero or one but the ray loop if you have
that as your output you now have a
discrepancy in there and if that's going
into another neural network or another
process having that discrepancy is
really important and it gives an output
of x if x is positive and 0 otherwise so
it says my x value is going to be
somewhere between zero or one and then
the
usually unless it's really uncertain the
output's usually a one or zero and then
the other little piece of uncertainty
there that you can send forward to
another network or you can look at to
know that there's uncertainty involved
and is often used in the hidden layers
this is what's coming out of the hidden
layers into the output layer usually or
as we reference the convolutional neural
network the cnn you'd have to go to
another video to review the relu is the
most common used
for
convolutional part of that network it
has a bunch of little pieces that are
very simplified looking at all the
different images or different sections
of the map and the rayleigh works really
good for that like i said there's other
formulas used but that this is the most
common one and you'll see that in the
hidden layers going maybe between one
layer and the next layer so just a quick
recap we have our soft max which means
that if you have numerous categories
only one of them is going to be picked
but you also want to have some value
attached to it how well it picked it and
you put that between 0 1 so it's very uh
standardized so we have our soft max we
looked at that let's go back one we
looked at that here where it transforms
the numbers and then we have our relu
function which takes the information and
the summation and puts it between a zero
and a one where it's either clearly a
zero or depending on how confident our
model is it'll go between the zero and
one value what are hyper parameters wow
this is a great interview question
hyperparameters when you are doing
neural networks this is what you're
playing with most the time once you've
gotten the data formatted correctly a
hyperparameter is a parameter whose
value is set before the learning process
begins determines how a network is
trained and the structure of the network
this includes things like the number of
hidden units how many hidden layers are
you going to have and how many nodes in
each layer learning rate learning rate
is usually multiplied once you've
figured out the error and how much you
want to change the weights we talked
about or i mentioned it early just
briefly you don't want to just make a
huge change otherwise you're gonna have
a biased model so you only take some
little incremental changes and that's
what the learning rate is is those small
incremental changes epics how many times
are you going to go through all the data
in your training set so one epic is one
trip through all the data and there's a
lot of other things depending on which
model you're working with and which
programming script you're working with
like the python sk learn package will
have a slightly different than say
google's tensorflow package which will
be a little bit different than the spark
machine learning package so these are
just some examples of the hyper
parameters and so you see in here we
have a nice image of our data coming in
and we train our model then we do a
comparison to see how good our model is
and then we go back and we say hey this
this model is pretty good but it's
biased so and we send it back and we
change our hyper parameters to see if we
get an unbiased model or we can have a
better prediction on it it matches our
data closer what will happen if learning
rate is set too low or too high we have
a nice couple graphs here we have one
over here says the learning rate set to
load you can see that it slowly works
its way down the curve and on the right
you can see a learning rate set too high
it's just bouncing back and forth when
your learning rate is too low that's
what we studied at two slides though
that's what the learning rate was
training of the model will progress very
slowly as we are making very tiny
updates to the weights we'll take many
updates before reaching the minimum
point so i just mentioned epic going
through all the data you might have to
go through all the data a thousand times
instead of 500 times for it to train
learning rate too high causes
undesirable divergent behavior to the
loss function due to drastic updates and
weights at times it may fail to converge
or even diverge so if you have your
learning rate set too high and it's
training too quickly maybe you'll get
lucky and it trains after one epic run
but a lot of times it might never be
able to train because the weights are
changing too fast they flip back and
forth too easy and you see down here
we've introduced two new terms converge
and diverge a converge means that our
model has reached a point where it's
able to give a fairly good answer for
all the data we put in all those weights
have adjusted and it's minimized the
error diverged means that the data is so
chaotic that it can never manage to to
train to that data the data is just too
chaotic for it to train so we have two
new words there converge and diverge are
important to know also what is dropout
and batch normalization dropout is a
technique of dropping out hidden and
visible units of a network randomly to
prevent overfitting of data it doubles
the number of iterations needed to
converge the network so here we have our
standard neural network and then after
applying dropout now it doesn't mean we
actually delete the node the node is
still there and we're still going to use
that note what it means is that we're
only going to work with a few of the
notes
a lot of times i think the most common
one right now used is 20
uh so you'll drop out 20 of the nodes
when you do your training you reverse
propagate your data and then you'll
randomly pick another 20 nodes the next
time you go through an epic data
training so each time you go through one
epic you will randomly pick 20 of those
nodes not not to mess with and this
allows for less overfitting of the data
so by randomly doing this you create
some i guess it just kind of pulls some
nodes off to the side and says we're
going to handle the data later on so we
don't overfit batch normalization is a
technique to improve the performance and
stability of neural network the idea is
to normalize the inputs in every layer
so that they have mean output and
activation of zero and standard
deviation of one this question covers a
lot of different things which is great
it's a great interview question because
it pulls in that you have to understand
what the mean value is so a mean output
activation of zero that means our
average activation is zero so when you
normalize it remember usually we're
going between minus one and one on a lot
of these it's a very standard setup so
you have to be very aware that this is
your mean output activation of zero and
then we have our standard deviation of
one so we want to keep our error down to
just a one value the benefits of this
doing a batch normalization is it
provides regularization it trains faster
higher learning rates and weights are
easier to initialize what is the
difference between batch gradient
descent and stochastic gradient descent
batch gradient descent batch gradient
computes the gradient using the entire
data set it takes time to converge
because the volume of data is huge and
weights update slowly so you can look at
the batches a lot of times if you're
using big data batch the data in but you
still go through a full epic you still
go through all the data on there so bash
graded descent means you're going to use
it to fit all the data and look for
convergence there stochastic gradient
descent stochastic gradient computes the
gradient using a single sample it
converges much faster than batch
gradient because it updates weight more
frequently explain overfitting and
underfitting and how to combat them
overfitting happens when a model learns
the details and noise and the training
data to the degree that it adversely
impacts execution of the model on the
new information it is more likely to
occur with non-linear models that have
more flexibility when learning a target
function an example of this would be if
you're looking at say cars and trucks
and motorcycles it might only recognize
trucks that have a certain box-like
shape it might not be able to notice a
flatbed truck unless it's only a
specific kind of flatbed truck or only
ford trucks because that's what it saw
on the training set this means that your
model performs great on your train data
and rate on maybe a small test amount of
data but when you go to use it in the
real world it leaves out a lot and start
and is not very functional outside of
your small area your slow laboratory
data coming in under fitting doing the
opposite when you under fit your data
underfitting alludes to a model that is
neither well trained on training data
nor can generalize to new information
usually happens when there is less and
improper data to train a model has a
verb performance and accuracy so if
you're using underfitted data and you
generate a model and you distribute that
in a commercial zone you'll have a lot
of people unhappy with you because it's
not going to give them very good answers
so we've explained overfitting and under
fitting so now we want to ask how to
combat them combating overfitting and
underfitting resampling the data to
estimate the model accuracy k-fold cross
validation having a validation data set
to evaluate the model so we do the
resampling we're randomly going to be
picking out data and we'll run it a few
times to see how that works depending on
our random data and how we sample the
data to generate our model and then we
want to go ahead and validate the data
set by having our training data and then
keeping some data on the side testing
data to validate it how are weights
initialized in a network initializing
all weights to zero all the weights are
set to zero this makes your model
similar to a linear model so if you have
linear data coming in doing a basic
setup like that might work all the
neurons in every layer perform the same
operation given the same output and
making the deep net useless right there
is a key word it's going to be useless
if you initialize everything to zero at
that point be looking into some other
machine learning tools initializing all
weights randomly here the weights are
assigned randomly by initializing them
very close to zero it gives better
accuracy to the model since every neuron
performs different computations and here
we have the weights are set randomly we
have our input layer the hidden layers
and the output layer and w equals np
random random in layer size l layer size
l minus one this is the most commonly
used is to randomly generate your
weights what are the different layers in
cnn convolutional neural network first
is the convolutional layer that performs
a convolutional operation we have our
other video out if you want to explore
that more so go into detail exactly how
to see the convolutional layer works in
the cnn as far as creating a number of
smaller picture windows to go over the
data the second step is as a rayleigh
layer rayleigh brings non-linearity to
the network and converts all the
negative pixels to zero output is
rectified feature map so it goes into a
mapping feature there pooling layer
pulling is a down sampling operation
that reduces the dimensionality of the
feature map so we have all our relu
layer which is pulling all these little
maps out of our convolutional layer it's
taking that picture and little creating
little tiny neural networks to look at
different parts of the picture then we
need to pull it together and then
finally the fully connected layer so we
flatten our pulling layer out and we
have a fully connected layer recognizes
and classifies the objects in the image
and that's actually your forward
propagation reverse propagation training
model usually i mean there's a number of
different models out there of course
what is pooling in cnn and how does it
work pooling used to reduce the spatial
dimensions of a cnn performs down
sampling operation to reduce the
dimensionality creates a pooled feature
map by sliding a filter matrix over the
input matrix i mentioned that briefly on
the previous slide it's important to
know that you have if you see here they
have a rectified feature map and so each
one of those colors like the yellow
color that might be one of the a smaller
little neural network using the relu
you'll look at it'll just kind of
go over the main picture and look at all
the different areas on the main picture
so you might step one two three four
spaces um and then you have another one
that's also looking at features and it
has a two seven eight five each one of
those is a map so it might be the first
one might be a map looking for cat ears
the second one looking for human eyes
when it does this you then have this
rectified feature map looking at these
different features and the max pooling
with the two by two filters in a stride
of two stride means instead of skipping
every pixel you're going to go every two
pixels you take the maximum values and
you can see over here we look at a
pulled feature map one of the features
says hey i had a max value of eight so
somewhere in here we saw a human eye
labeled as eight pretty high label and
maybe seven was a human hand and maybe
four was cat whiskers or something that
we thought might be cat whiskers four is
kind of a low number in this particular
case compared to the other ones so you
have your full pool feature map you can
see the process here is we have our
stepping we look for the max value and
then we create a pool feature map of the
max values how does a lstm network work
that's long short-term memory so the
first thing to know is that an lstms are
a special kind of recurrent neural
network capable of learning long-term
dependencies remembering information for
long periods of time is their default
behavior we did look at the rnn briefly
talked about how the hidden layer feeds
back into itself with the lstm has a
much more complicated feedback and you
can see here we have the hidden layer of
t minus one and the hidden area that's
what the h stands for hidden layer of t
and the formula is going in as we can
see here we have the hidden layers we
have t minus one and then h of t where t
stands for time so this is a series
remember working with series we want to
remember the past and you can see you
have your x your input of t and that
might be a frame in a
video as the frame comes in the usually
using this one the tangent h activation
formula but you also see that it goes
through a couple other formulas the
omega formula and so when it combines
these that then goes into the next layer
your next hidden layer that then goes
into the data that's submitted to the
next input so you have your x of t plus
one so when you have that coming in then
you have your h values coming forward
from the last process and depending on
how many of these omega structures you
put in there depends on how long term
the memory gets so it's important to
remember this is more for your long
long-term recurrent neural networks the
three steps in an lstm step one decides
what to forget and what to remember step
two selectively update cell state values
so based on what we want to remember and
forget we want to update those cell
values and then decides what part of the
current state make it to the output so
now we have to also have an output on
there what are vanishing and exploding
gradients this is a great question that
affects all our neural networks while
training an rnn your slope can become
either too small or too large and this
makes the training difficult when the
slope is too small the problem is known
as vanishing gradient so our slope we
have our change in x and our change in y
when the slope decreases gradually to a
very small value sometimes negative and
makes training difficult when the slope
tends to grow exponentially instead of
decaying this problem is called
exploding gradient the slope grows
exponentially you can see a nice graph
of that here issues in gradient problem
long training time poor performance and
low accuracy what is the difference
between epic batch and iteration and
deep learning epic an epic represents
one iteration over the entire data set
so that's everything you're going to go
ahead and put into that training model
batch we cannot pass the entire data set
into the neural network at once so we
divide the data set into a number of
batches and then iteration if we have 10
000 images as data and a batch size of
200 then the epic should run 10 000
times over 200 so that means we have our
total number over the 200 equals 50
iterations so in each epic we're running
over all the data set we're going to
have 50 iterations and each of those
iterations includes a batch of 200
images in this case why tensorflow is
the most preferred library in deep
learning uh well first tensorflow
provides both c plus plus and python
apis that makes it easier to work on has
a faster compilation time than other
deep learning libraries like cross and
torch tensorflow supports both cpus and
gpus computing devices so right now
tensorflow is at the top of the market
because it's so easy to use for both
programmer side and for hardware side
and for the speed of getting something
up and running what do you mean by
tensor in tensorflow tensor is a
mathematical object represented as
arrays of higher dimension these arrays
of data with different dimensions and
ranks that are fed as input to the
neural network are called tensors you
can see here we have a tensor of
dimensions five comma four so it's a two
dimensional tensor coming in you can
look at an image like this that each one
of those pixels is a different value if
it's a black and white so it might be
zero and ones and then each one
represents a black and white image in a
color photo you might either find a
different value system or you might have
a tensor value that has the x y
coordinates as we see here plus the
colors so you might have three more
different dimensions for the three
different images the red the blue and
the yellow coming in and even as you go
from one layer or one tensor to the next
these layers might change we might
flatten them might bring in numerous in
the case of the convergence neural
network we have all those smaller
different mappings of features that come
in so each one of those layers coming
through is a tensor if it has multiple
dimensions coming in and weights
attached to it what are the programming
elements in tensorflow well we have our
constants constants are parameters whose
value does not change to define a
constant we use tf.constant command
example a equals tf.constant 2.0 tf
float32 so it's a tensorflow value of
32. b equals tf constant 3.0 print a b
if we did a print of a b we'd have
tf.constant and then of course b is that
instance of it variables variables allow
us to add new trainable parameters to
graph to define a variable we use
tf.variable command and initialize them
before running the graph in session
example w equals tf variable 0.3d type
tf float32 or b equals the tf variable
minus 3 comma d typefloat32 placeholders
placeholders allow us to feed data to a
tensorflow model from outside a model
and permits a value to be assigned later
to define a placeholder we use tf
placeholder command example a equals tf
placeholder b equals a times two with
the tf session as sess result equals
session run b comma feed dictionary
equals a 3.0 print result uh so we have
a nice example there replace holder
session a session is run to evaluate the
nodes this is called as the tensorflow
runtime so for example you have a equals
tf constant 2.0 b equals tf constant 4.0
c equals a plus b and at this point
you'd go ahead and create a session
equals tf session and then you can
evaluate the tensor c print session run
c that would input c as an input into
your session what do you understand by a
computational graph everything in
tensorflow is based on creating a
computational graph it has a network of
nodes where each node performs an
operation nodes represent mathematical
operation and edges represent tensors
since data flows in a form of a graph it
is also called a data flow graph and we
have a nice visual of this graph or
graphic image of a computational graph
and you can see here we have our input
nodes our add multiply nodes and our
multiply node at the end and then we
have the edges where the data flows so
we have from a going to c a going to d
you can see we have a 2 flowing 4
flowing explain generative adversarial
network along with an example suppose
there's a wine shop that purchases wine
from dealers which they will resell
later so we have a dealer going to the
wine or shop owner that then sells it
for a profit but there are some
malfactor dealers who sell fake wine in
this case the shop owner should be able
to distinguish between fake and
authentic wine the forger will try to
different techniques to sell fake wine
and make sure certain techniques go past
the shop owner's check so here's our
forager fake wine shop owner the shop
owner would probably get some feedback
from the wine experts that some of the
wine is not original the owner would
have to improve how he determines
whether a wine is fake or authentic goal
of forger to create wines that are
indistinguishable from the authentic
ones goal of shop owner to accurately
tell if the wine is real or not there
are two main components of generative
adversarial network and we refer to as a
noise vector coming in we have our
forger who's going to generate fake wine
and then we have our real authentic wine
and of course our shop owner has to
figure out whether it's real or fake the
generator is a cnn that keeps producing
images that are closer in appearance to
the real images while the discriminator
tries to determine the difference
between real and fake images the
ultimate aim is to make the
discriminator learn to identify real and
fake images what is an auto encoder the
network is trained to reconstruct its
inputs it is a neural network that has
three layers here the input neurons are
equal to the output neuron the network's
target outside is same as the input it
uses dimensionality reduction to
restructure the input input image comes
in we have our latin space
representation and then it goes back out
reconstructing the image it works by
compressing the input to a latin space
representation and then reconstructing
the output from this representation what
is bagging and boosting bagging and
boosting are ensemble techniques where
the idea is to train multiple models
using the same learning algorithm and
then take a call so we have in here
where we're bagging we take a data set
and we split it we're gonna have our
training data and our test data very
standard thing to do then we're going to
randomly select data into the bags and
train your model separately so we might
have bag one model one bag two model two
bag three model three and so on in
boosting the emphasis is to select the
data points which give wrong output in
order to improve the accuracy so in
boosting we have our data set again we
split it to test data and train data and
we'll take a bag one and we'll train the
model data points with wrong predictions
then go into bag two and we then train
that model and repeat i hope this helps
you in your interview with that we've
reached the end of this complete deep
learning tutorial i hope you guys
enjoyed this video do like and share it
thank you for watching and stay tuned
for more from simply learn
[Music]
you